So, da sind wir auferstanden aus einer Sendepause.
Hallo, hier ist die Freakshow. Ich bin's Tim, Tim Brittlaff.
Ich begrüße alle zur 279.
Ausgabe oder sowas. So ist es. So steht es geschrieben.
Und wenn es so geschrieben steht,
dann ist es auch so. Aber man kann es ja danach nicht mehr editieren.
was einmal ins Internet gesprochen wurde, kann nicht wieder zurückgenommen werden.
Ich begrüße die Runde. Hallo Roddy.
Hallo Tim.
Du hast schon wieder Zweifel an meinen Aussagen. Ich merke es ja an deiner Nasenspitze an.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ja, ja. Ralf ist da.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend. Das Schlimme ist, wenn es im Internet stand,
ist es dann auch schon von der KI gelernt und wird uns die nächsten 500 Jahre immer wieder peinigen.
Ungekaut, genau. Da lässt sich dann gar nichts mehr dran drehen.
Es sei denn, man redet so sehr auf sie ein, dass sie dann meint,
nee, stimmt alles auch wieder nicht.
Ist alles nochmal anders. Insofern haben wir noch eine Chance.
Und Max ist mit dabei. Hallo Max. Guten Tag.
Guten Tag. Wir haben fleißig Keynote geguckt, wie alle anderen Kinder natürlich auch. Ja.
Es ist wieder soweit. Und große Überraschung, wir wollen uns dann dazu äußern.
Denn wir fühlen uns Beruf Wir haben die Ahnung gepachtet Also ich meine,
wir sind ja jetzt Wie lange verfolgt ihr Apple-Kinots jetzt schon so?
Will ich darüber wirklich nachdenken?
Naja Ich weiß nicht, was war denn Ich überlege gerade Was könnte die erste,
WWDC-Kinot sein Die ich so bewusst wahrgenommen habe Aber das war ja am Anfang
noch gar nicht so einfach, da überhaupt ranzukommen.
Also eine Videoaufzeichnung oder so davon zu bekommen.
Das war eine Zeit lang, gab es die live und dann haben sie mit dem live aufgehört.
Keine Ahnung warum. Und dann haben
sie irgendwann viel, viel später wieder angefangen, bilde ich mir ein.
Wie mit live? Achso, du meinst jetzt on stage?
Nee, auch live, dass man es live streamen konnte.
Das stimmt.
Das haben die irgendwie für Quicktime, Streaming oder irgendwie sowas,
haben sie das mal eingeführt.
Und dann wieder sein gelassen?
Und dann haben sie es erstmal wieder sein gelassen.
Richtig, da war was. Ja.
Ja, ja.
Ja, also ich weiß, dass ich mal zu so einem Presse-Event eingeladen wurde,
da wurde dann die Keynote, als die den Power Mac G5 vorgestellt haben, da eingeladen.
Ja, das war doch schon spät.
Ja, aber das war insofern ganz lustig, als dann saßen alle in dem großen Saal
mit der großen Leinwand und dann sollte das irgendwie losgehen.
Und dann hat es halt just in dem Moment die Satellitenschüssel vom Dach geweht.
Und dann mussten sie es irgendwie in so einem kleinen, blockigen Internet-Stream
zeigen und nicht in der hohen Qualität über Satellit.
Das war sehr lustig.
Ja, das ist schon geil, wie das heutzutage geht. So ein 4K-Stream,
ganz bequem nach Hause, alles super.
Ja, aber es ist alles dieses vorproduzierte, hochverdichtete Zeug.
Es ist mir ehrlich gesagt, also okay, gut, es ist schön, dass es das in dieser
Form gibt, aber ich würde mir trotzdem wünschen, dass das sozusagen,
so wie es früher war, mehr so, was ist das richtige Wort, wenn die da so agieren, nicht fremdschämen.
Dass sie auf die Bühne kommen und wieder von der Bühne runtergehen und man so
eine kurze Pause hat, während da Umbaupause ist.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch so die Awkwardness, die manchmal mit Fehlern und Behavior so verbunden ist.
Also wenn man so Steve Jobs dann zwei Minuten dabei zuschaut,
wie er durch Fotos durchscrollt und es einfach geil findet, wo man sich ja nur
fragen kann, was jetzt eigentlich los ist.
Oder wenn er eine Kamera von der Bühne wirft, weil er sie nicht ankriegt. Hat er gemacht?
Ja, das hat er mal gemacht.
Oder das Publikum anschimpft, dass sie alle ihre WLAN-Router ausschalten sollen,
damit irgendwie seine WLAN-Demo ordentlich funktioniert.
Wo ich es ja wirklich vermisse, sind ja die ganzen anderen WWDC-Videos,
die ganzen Erklär-Videos, die man früher noch in NDA unterschreiben musste,
um einen Apple-Developer-Account zu brauchen, das braucht man ja nicht mehr.
Die sind ja so langweilig und steif geworden und das ist ja nur noch so,
ja, ist alles total easy und hier ist total easy und hier haben wir jetzt den
neuen Tab-View und guck mal, was ich hier mache. mache ich eine Kopie,
ich schreibe das hier rein und schon geht alles und total easy.
Und das war früher, fand ich, so ein bisschen mehr, da hat man gemerkt,
da standen die auf der Bühne und haben teilweise Sachen gesagt,
von denen ihnen klar war, dass sie die eigentlich nicht sagen sollten,
aber gesagt ist halt gesagt, jetzt ist es raus und dann wusste es zumindest der Raum.
Und dann gab es ja auch noch so, dass Leute das dann live mitgeschrieben haben,
als es noch keine Videoaufzeichnungen gab und so was, weil da relevante Informationen
drin waren. Und jetzt ist das halt diese vorproduzierte Scheiße und dann denkst
du dir nach zehn Minuten so...
oh, ich sollte mal auf anderthalbfache Geschwindigkeit hochschalten,
weil ansonsten ist das ja ganz unerträglich und dann merkst du,
du hast schon auf anderthalbfache Geschwindigkeit hochgeschaltet.
Das finde ich aber nicht, ganz im Gegenteil. Ich finde die viel angenehmer zu
gucken, weil die kompakter sind und weil die nicht auf biegen und brechen eine,
Dreiviertelstundenslot füllen müssen, sondern wenn es halt nicht reicht,
dann ist das Video halt noch 25 Minuten lang.
Wir haben uns ja schon ein paar Mal darüber ausgelassen, dass wir das dann doch
jetzt mittlerweile bedauern, aber es ist mir noch nie so hart aufgeschlagen,
wie jetzt bei der WWDC Keynote.
Also ich finde gerade die WWDC, die schreit doch danach, das dann auch wirklich
live zu machen, wenn du da die ganzen Deaf-Leute alle sitzen hast und Partystimmung im Plenum.
Die letzten Male, als es noch live war, war es sowieso ein fürchterliches Gerangel
um die Tickets und die Sache ist zu groß geworden. Du kriegst die Leute ja nicht mehr in einen Raum.
Du kannst sie ja immer noch dann alle da, wo sie jetzt auch saßen,
vor dem Riesenscreen da draußen in der prallen Sonne irgendwie schwitzen lassen,
da spricht ja nichts gegen, aber dass sie komplett weg sind von,
wir machen jetzt hier ein Live-Event und,
gehen da ein bisschen ins Risiko und machen das ein bisschen lockerer.
Ich finde, einmal im Jahr sollte auch Apple sich das irgendwie gönnen.
Ja, wenn sie aus dem Flugzeug springen, dann sollen sie es live machen.
Dann bitte schön live, das fordert die.
Google hat das auch mal live gemacht, ne?
Mit in der Google Glass doch, oder?
Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht mehr, was es war, aber die Einführung kann sein.
Die sind aus dem Flugzeug live mit dem gelandeten offen aus Ponys.
Gar nicht peinlich.
Ja, aber wenn, dann live.
Wenn, dann live, ja. Was ich schlimm fand, diesmal war der Ton.
Das habe ich nicht ertragen, weil es so fürchterlich komprimiert war und dann
haben sie immer, wenn jemand Siri sagte, haben sie so einen komischen Filter
drauf gemacht. Ach, ernsthaft?
Damit das im Publikum nicht losgeht, oder was? Ah, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Das war ein ganz, ganz merkwürdigen Audiofilter, der dann aber manchmal auch
länger an war und du dachtest, Ja, mach den Filter aus, ich will wieder zuhören
können, das ist ja furchtbar.
Was mir bei State of the Union aufgefallen ist, an einer Stelle war da so ganz
leise Musik hinten drin.
Ich weiß keine Ahnung, wie das reingekommen ist, aber es war einfach plötzlich
in einem Segment Musik hinten drin.
Naja, wir werden das alles gleich noch detailliert auseinanderklammbüsern.
Ich fürchte das. Bevor wir allerdings voll in die neue Welt der Apple-Intelligenz
einsteigen, denke ich mal, sollten wir vorher noch auf ein paar andere Sachen
hinweisen, die uns vielleicht vorher so bewegt haben.
Übrigens ist gerade Jubiläum wieder mal, ist mal wieder was alt geworden.
Wir.
Wir auch. Ich finde das immer ganz interessant, dass man das dann auch mal so
in den Kontext setzen kann, aber Tetris ist jetzt irgendwie vor 40 Jahren,
erschienen.
Habt ihr das schon mal gespielt?
Tetris, nee.
Damals, in der Tat, ja. Gameboy. Das war ja auch vom ersten Gameboy.
Das war überall.
Machen keine Gewaltspieler.
Ich habe im Wesentlichen dieses dreidimensionale Tetris gespielt,
was es dann da irgendwann mal gab.
Dreidimensionales Tetris?
Ja, da guckst du von oben in den Schacht rein und dann sind die Blöcke halt
dreidimensional. Dann kannst du sie um zwei Achsen drehen und dann fallen lassen.
Blockout. Hieß das Blockout? Nee, es hieß nicht Blockout.
Ich hatte selber kein Gameboy, aber ich habe es darauf gespielt,
also diese Schwarz-Weiß-Variante. Das hat mich total gestresst. Doch, hieß Blockout.
Ich habe nie gerne Tetris gespielt.
Ich habe es auf dem Macintosh LC gespielt sehr sehr viel und irgendwann habe
ich mir eine VRAM-Erweiterung gekauft,
weil wir hatten einen 13 Zoll Monitor mit 640x480 Pixeln und der konnte mit
dem standardmäßigen 256 Kilowatt Videospeicher nur 16 Farben darstellen und
dann habe ich mir irgendwann das Upgrade geleistet auf 256 Farben und dann konnte ich eine Farbvariante.
Ui.
Ja, aber es ist älter als der Gameboy, glaube ich. Nee, stimmt,
es ist nicht älter als der Gameboy.
Aber Tetris, muss man mal anerkennen, Tetris gehört ja in die Kategorie Eternal Games.
Also originale Idee, die ein ganzes Genre definiert und trotzdem wird das Original
immer das Original bleiben.
Ich glaube, wir hatten ja neulich schon mal Tetris besprochen,
weil es da ja so einen Durchbruch gab.
Leute, die das Original Tetris spielen, die dann irgendwie zum x-en Level durchgekommen
sind und das Programm dann zum Crashen bekommen haben und dann irgendwie aber
auch noch einen Weg gefunden haben, wie man das verhindern kann.
Dieser NES-Glitch.
Genau, um dann irgendwie alle 99 Level durchzuspielen und so.
Also solche Sachen, also quasi das Spiel ist eine Sportart geworden und hat
auch so seinen eigenen Kulturraum aufgemacht und es gibt nicht viele Spiele,
die halt so eternal sind.
Also klar, Pong, Padman gehören definitiv dazu und es sind halt vor allem so
die Erfindungen vom Anfang.
Vielleicht noch Donkey Kong.
Es gibt ja auch Tetris, der Film. Kann man sich ja bei Apple TV Plus angucken.
Das ist über die Geschichte. Ja, habe ich mir gegeben irgendwann mal. Ist quasi, also,
Ich will es nicht sagen, aber der Mörder war der Block. Es geht um die Geschichte
von Tetris und wie Tetris aus Russland oder aus der Sowjetunion in den Westen gekommen ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man ihn unbedingt gesehen haben muss, aber ganz unterhaltsam, mittelunterhaltsam.
Ich bin hier gerade auf dem Wikipedia-Artikel, da steht 1985,
also nicht 84, also es wird nächstes Jahr 40, oder?
Interpretiere ich jetzt hier was falsch?
Wir lassen die Sendung einfach ein Jahr liegen.
Das Nintendo kam dann sogar vier Jahre später her.
1989 mit dem Gameboy-Load.
1989, genau, aber 1985 gab es quasi die erste Version davon.
Also Heise schreibt, die Urform des Spiels entstand 1984 auf einem Elektronika
60, einem russischen Klon des DEC LSI 11.
Da dieser Großrechner keine Grafik unterstützte, bestanden die ursprünglichen
Tetrominos. Ach so heißen die? Tetrominos?
Tetrominus.
Das hat sich doch Chachapiti ausgedacht.
Wieder was gelernt.
Aus ASCII-Zeichen. So, also im Westen gab es das dann erst später,
aber das kommt ja aus Russland.
Ich glaube, das war einfach nur um die Geschichte dann. Aber das war auch irgendwie
von Anfang an drin, dass Tetris aus Russland kommt, oder? Das war schon in der ersten Version.
Das ist ja so. Das ist eher, was halt in die andere Richtung zeigt.
Darin hat es jeder sofort gesehen.
Und Hammer und Sichel und die, scheiße, jetzt weiß ich nicht,
wie die Kirche da heißt auf dem Roten Platz.
Die Kirche auf dem Roten Platz. Wir wissen es eh alle nicht.
Jetzt kriege ich das raus.
Ziemlich weit unten im Wikipedia-Artikel steht dann wirklich auch 1984.
Aber da muss man ganz schön scrollen, bis man da hinkommt.
Mensch, Mensch, Mensch, was für eine Anstrengung.
Alexej Leonidovich Patschitnov. Patschitnov. Ja. Ja, das geht doch locker runter von der Zunge, oder?
Naja, auf jeden Fall Russlands Beitrag zur Digitalkultur.
Und ich glaube, damit war es das dann im Wesentlichen. Seitdem kommen eigentlich
nur noch Hackerbanden, die einem irgendwie das Geld aus der Tasche ziehen wollen.
An andere große Würfe kann ich mich jetzt so richtig nicht erinnern.
Und sehr viele Entwickler, die keinen Humor, keine Witze verstehen.
Ist nicht in jedem Team, mit dem man jemals zusammengearbeitet hat,
auch irgendein russischer Entwickler dabei, der sehr, sehr schlau ist,
aber wirklich keine Witze versteht.
Ist das so?
Ja.
Hatte ich noch nicht, aber kann durchaus sein.
Ich auch nicht.
Na gut, dann bin ich jetzt hier mal. Menno.
Du bist internationaler unterwegs gewesen als wir.
Du hast sowas noch gesehen, aber wir haben keine Ahnung. Naja,
auf jeden Fall 40 Jahre Tetris.
Und da sind viele Sachen am Kreml.
Am Rotenplatz, da ist der Kreml, da ist das Kaufhaus GUM und da sind diese berühmten
Türme von der Kirche, die ich nicht kenne.
Siehst du gerade auf dem Kreml?
Weil da jemand meint.
Der Kreml.
Das Lenin-Mausoleum natürlich, klar.
Und die Kirche mit diesen komischen Muffin-Hütchen auf dem Turm.
Ja, sie sehen so aus wie so Sahne-Kringel auf Muffins.
Jo. Das sollte ich mal erwähnt haben, dachte ich mir.
Ich komme auch gleich nochmal auf ein anderes Ding, was auch so ein Klassiker ist,
was später aber erst zum Klassiker zu werden sich anschickte.
So, das war meine Formulierung.
Du machst es so spannend.
Ich mache es so spannend. Soll ich da jetzt gleich drauf eingehen?
Jetzt hast du es eingelitten, jetzt musst du. Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Ich dachte, ich könnte jetzt eine reine Vorschau machen.
Also ich wollte nämlich eigentlich einen Reisebericht einwerfen,
weil ich war auf Reisen und ich war nämlich auf der Veranstaltung mit dem schönsten Namen,
also der Hacker-Veranstaltung mit dem allerschönsten Namen und das ist, wie ihr wisst, na?
Also in der Liste steht EMF.
Und das heißt?
Elektromagnetik Field.
Genau, das Electromagnetic Field ist der schönste Name für ein Open-Air-Event.
Und wenn man da hinkommt, dann ist auch ganz klar Elektromagnetismus ganz vorn.
In allen Wellenlängen.
Also es gibt auch Gravity, was sich da niederschlägt, weil man da an relativ schrägen Hängen kämmt.
Das spielt da durchaus eine Rolle.
Aber da gibt es kein Käse fangen oder so.
Käse fangen?
Na, die Briten machen doch jedes Jahr dieses Käse fangen am Hang.
Da wird dann ein Käse runtergerollt und dann schmeißen die sich alle vom Berg
runter und versuchen den Käse zu fangen.
Da habe ich ein Video von den Slow Mo Guys gesehen.
Stimmt, da gibt es jetzt eins. Das habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Das ist mir ja nicht bekannt. Man ist sehr überrascht.
Dass da niemand bei dir stirbt.
Man zweifelt an der Menschheit, wenn man sieht, was die da tun.
Weil die sich wirklich wie die Bekloppten den Berg runter schmeißen.
Also der Käse rollt den Berg runter.
Der Käse wird runtergerollt und das ist ein erstaunlich steiler Berg und die
Leute rennen hinterher.
Also wir reden jetzt von so einem großen Käsewagenrad oder so.
Es ist nicht so groß.
Keine Ahnung.
Also die haben das nur in einer Hand gehalten.
Nicht mal LP, vielleicht LP, aber so ist er nicht.
Also es ist das Coopers Hill Cheese Rolling and Wake.
Viertägige Veranstaltung. Coopers Hill. Drei bis vier Kilo schwerer Käseleib.
Und dieser Hang sieht wirklich sehr steil aus.
Oh ja.
Gibt es da irgendwo Unfälle in dieser Liste?
Unter Garantie.
Das haben sie erstmal rausgelassen, aber es gibt da Aufnahmen davon,
da wird einem anders und man zweifelt ein bisschen an der Vernunft der Leute, die da mitmachen.
Aber bitte, soll ja jeder seine Jugend ruinieren, wie er will.
Also ich meine, Da muss ich den Briten aber zugute halten.
Also es ist besser, man rennt einen Berg runter, einem Käse hinterher,
als ein paar Ploner vor irgendwelchen Stieren weg. Hört.
Muss kommen, assen. Ist alles relativ.
Es kommen wenigstens keine Tiere zu Schaden.
Anyway, ich war auf jeden Fall auf dem Electromagnetic Field und ich meine,
dass ich auch, als ich das letzte Mal da schon war, das muss so 2018 gewesen
sein, habe ich hier vermutlich davon berichtet, Aber das ist ja jetzt schon
eine Weile her. Von daher kann ich es ja einfach nochmal machen.
Weiß nicht, habt ihr irgendwelche Vorabfragen zu der Veranstaltung?
Das klingt ein bisschen so, als ob wir der Lehrer jetzt gerade alle die Hausaufgaben vergessen haben.
Ihr habt noch eine Chance.
Ich weiß ja nicht, vielleicht bevor ich... Sollten wir welche haben?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, worauf ich mich konzentrieren soll.
Ich mach's auch relativ kurz.
Also das Ganze ist halt Open Air, mit anderen Worten, Leute sind halt so mit
Wohnwagen da und mit Zelten und lalala.
Also im Wesentlichen alles auch sehr ähnlich zum deutschen und holländischen
Camp und das war ja auch ein bisschen die Vorlage.
Nur kommt dann doch sehr die britische oder die englische Spezialisierung hervor. Vor.
Alle schlafen auf der falschen Zeltseite.
Nee,
aber sagt doch mal, was ihr meint, was ich damit wohl meinen könnte.
Also es gibt etwas, da sind die irgendwie besser als wir.
Frühstück?
Nee, nee, jetzt so konkret, was so Hackdisziplin betrifft.
Hackdisziplin. Die haben alle noch Blackberries, diese da in der Zwergbeutel.
Keine Ahnung, also die Stecker sind es nicht, diese klobigen Teile.
Micro BBC irgendwas?
BBC Micro? Naja gut, also dieser ganze Retro-Touch, das spielte da auch eine
Rolle, weil es gab auch so einen Film-Track, wo sehr viele Filme gezeigt wurden,
unter anderem auch Dokumentationen.
Dann war da auch so einiges über die Geschichte von Sinclair Computer,
Elkhorn und da wurde mir dann auch erstmal wieder klar, wie wichtig eigentlich
die britische Computerindustrie in den 80er Jahren war, während die deutsche
eigentlich schon keine Rolle mehr spielte.
Also es war ja so das Jahrzehnt des Home-Computings und einen deutschen Home-Computer gab es nicht.
Keiner der deutschen Unternehmen hat es geschafft, sich auch nur vorzustellen,
einen Home-Computer zu bauen. Und das obwohl...
Gab es nicht irgendeinen Schneider CPC oder so was?
Ja, aber der Schneider CPC war ein Amstrad-Computer. Und Amstrad und Sinclair
und Eccorn, das waren so die drei großen britischen Computerhersteller.
Eccorn war auch für diesen BBC Micro zuständig.
Hier sagt jemand Robotron KC85. Das müssen wir gelten lassen.
Das war doch aber irgendein PC-Klon.
Nee, das war ein C64-Klon, glaube ich.
Nein, das war ein Z80. Genau und das war ja auch Sinclair,
Okay, das lasse ich euch. Also Robotron...
Ich meine, die wichtigste Prozessor-Plattform überhaupt wahrscheinlich auf diesem
Planeten, du hast ja Elkhorn schon gesagt, ARM ist ja aus Elkhorn hervorgegangen.
Genau, das ist sozusagen dann das Ende der Geschichte. Also sie sind ja eigentlich
alle sehr schnell sehr groß geworden.
Also das fing so 82 ging das los oder 80 ging Sinclair los.
Der Typ war ja so ein Universal-Erfinder, der so alles mögliche gemacht hat.
Der wollte ja dann so einen tragbaren Mini-Fernseher pushen,
das schlug aber nicht so richtig ein und vorher ist er sehr bekannt geworden
durch seine Taschenrechner tatsächlich.
Also Sinclair hat so Ende der 70er Jahre Taschenrechner gemacht.
Und ein Elektroauto.
Und naja, das war so auch so eins seiner Dinge, die er immer umsetzen wollte.
Also Elektroauto, es war halt mehr so ein kleines Elektrofahrrad,
kann man fast sagen, oder so ein Elektro-Dreirad.
Und im Prinzip war er da seiner Zeit damit ja auch weit voraus.
Nur damals war das halt nicht die Zeit.
Und das hat aber auch dann dazu beigetragen, dass Sinclair einerseits ein hohes
Ansehen genoss in der englischen Gesellschaft und ja letzten Endes auch den
Sir verliehen bekommen hat von der Queen.
Sir Clive Sinclair, aber er war schon irgendwie ein schräger Vogel.
Und er hat ja dann diesen ZX80 rausgebracht, also er war quasi besessen davon,
dass Computer billig sein mussten.
Und hatte halt für verhältnismäßig wenig Geld,
also damalig so zweistellige Pfundbeträge, das übersetzt sich glaube ich,
sagen wir mal heute so in den 200-300 Euro Bereich würde ich mal sagen ungefähr,
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger sogar noch.
Und der ZX80 war halt so,
ja Z80 und absolut minimalistisch, so eine Platine, so ein dünnes Teil,
aber schon geil designt und auch die Sinclair Taschenrechner sahen einfach extrem geil aus.
Und das Sinclair-Logo sieht auch schon extrem geil aus.
Das sind diese bunten Streifen, oder?
Nein, die bunten Streifen, die kamen dann erst beim Spektrum dazu,
der dann halt das Branding für dieses eine Gerät war.
Das war dann der erste richtige Homecomputer, der in dieser C64-Kategorie aufgelaufen ist.
Und für damalige Verhältnisse schon ein ziemlich großer Wurf war.
Also klar, C64 war halt besser, aber das Ding konnte halt Farbe,
er konnte zwar nur sieben Farben und auch immer nur die gleichen und er hatte
irgendwie Sprites, aber auch alles nicht so toll wie beim C64.
Das ist ja jetzt auch gar nicht so wichtig, aber was sich halt in England dann
aber quasi damit manifestiert hat, ist so dieses, wir können Sachen selber bauen.
Und es gab dann halt Sinclair und Eckhorn.
Also wir als Nation oder wir als Individuen?
Wir als englische Gesellschaft, als Kulturnation, sag ich mal.
Der fairerweise, muss man natürlich sagen, diese ganzen Sinclair-Computer hatten
alle mega beschissene Tastaturen.
Also der ZX81 mit seiner Folientastatur, das war...
Aber der Punkt war, sie waren billig, sie waren erschwinglich.
Leute konnten sich damit überhaupt einen Computer leisten, für die die anderen
Modelle überhaupt gar nicht im Bereich des Möglichen waren.
Und Ekkorn hat es halt geschafft, diesen Deal mit BBC zu machen,
weil BBC wollte halt so eine Schulungssendung aufsetzen im Fernsehen,
in den 80er Jahren über Programmieren im Fernsehen.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, in Deutschland...
Ich weiß nicht, ob der Telekolleg irgendwann mal da angekommen ist,
aber es hat ewig gedauert.
Und Sinclair und damit dann eben auch Econ, die waren halt einfach wirklich
zu Gange und Amstrad auch, zu sagen, wir bauen unsere eigenen Computer,
wir bauen unsere eigenen Betriebssysteme und wir verkaufen die auch auf dem Markt.
Und das hat ja dann auch bis Ende der 80er Jahre in etwa funktioniert,
aber dann sind sie natürlich von der PC-Welle überrollt worden.
Also die Dynamik, die sich letzten Endes da im Silicon Valley abgespielt hat,
die hat ja eigentlich alles mitgerissen.
Auch die Japaner waren in den 80er Jahren noch mit im Boot mit diesen MS-Lix-Systemen.
Ja gut, ich meine, die hatten ja mit ihren Spielekonsolen auch nochmal so ein eigenes Ding.
Und weil sie halt Kanji, Kanji heißt die Schrift,
darstellen können mussten und das konnten PCs sehr, sehr lange nicht und darum
haben die noch sehr lange in die PC-Zeit hinein, quasi bis Windows oder sowas
dann irgendwann die True-Type-Fonds oder die entsprechenden Fonds hatte,
Daseinsberechtigung.
Mit Sicherheit mag das ein Faktor gewesen sein, aber vor allem war es erstmal
entscheidend, dass sie halt solche Systeme überhaupt gebaut haben,
während Deutschland halt sowas überhaupt nicht mal probiert hat.
Also mir würde jetzt aus dem Stand nichts einfallen, wo in den 80er Jahren irgendein
Computerhersteller in Deutschland auch nur ansatzweise in die Richtung Homecomputer gedacht hätte.
Ich habe irgendwann mal, es gibt Asianonomy oder ich weiß nicht wie die heißen,
also so ein YouTube-Channel, der sehr viel über so Deep Dives macht in solchen Themen.
Hervorragender Kanal.
Und der hat mal einen gemacht über die
Erfindung des digitalen Schaltkreises und die sind eigentlich in Frankreich
erfunden worden und dann kurze Zeit später in den USA nochmal.
Und während die Deutschen und die Franzosen da nie wirklich was draus gemacht
haben, hatten die Amerikaner das Glück, dann ein Raumfahrtprogramm zu haben,
wo man halt integrierte Computer sehr gut gebrauchen konnte.
Und da sieht man auch so ein bisschen, wie lange wir Europäer eigentlich aus
dem Bereich schon raus sind.
Das ist kein Thema, was irgendwie erst in den letzten 20 Jahren kam,
sondern eigentlich schon in den 50ern, 60ern waren. Es ist nicht so,
dass die das alles nicht gemacht haben, sondern die haben dann halt...
Die haben dann halt auch Fördergelder reingesteckt, auch Deutschland,
und haben das dann an irgendwelche an Grundig gegeben.
Die haben gesagt, oh, damit können wir bessere Radios entwickeln,
das ist ja praktisch. Und das haben die dann halt auch gemacht.
Und dafür reicht das dann. Und währenddessen haben die Amerikaner ihr Mondfahrtprogramm
gemacht und haben das Silicon Valley aus dem Boden gestampft.
Und wir haben bis heute nicht aufgeholt.
Aber schöne Radios.
Ja, schöne Radios.
Braun und so.
Der Chat hat mich gerade etwas korrigiert. Es gab tatsächlich den NDR-Kleinkomputer.
Das hatte ich wieder ganz vergessen.
Siehste wohl.
Kein besonders erfolgreiches System, meiner Erinnerung nach,
aber tatsächlich auch der Begleiter für NDR Schulfernsehen und das 84 immerhin. Ja, genau.
Z80 basiert. Das war so damals so, ja, das war immer so das Red, ne? Z80 oder 6502.
Eckhorn ist halt 6502 gewesen. Das war der BBC Micro.
Wenn ich die Bilder hier richtig sehe, dann musst du mal da wirklich unten anfangen.
Wenn du welche Bilder siehst.
Also ich sehe ja ein Bild gerade von einer Platine und dann sehe ich so ein
paar Chips, die daneben liegen und dann holt die Lippenholmen raus.
Genau, wie ein Computer gebaut wird. Das ist ja auch völlig in Ordnung.
Während der BBC Micro mehr so ein fertiger Computer war mit Tastatur,
wo es dann schon darum ging, Basic zu programmieren.
Das war eigentlich so die Zielrichtung. Naja, auf jeden Fall,
um vielleicht kurz die englische Homecomputer-Geschichte abzuschließen,
sowohl Sinclair als auch Amstrad als auch Eccorn sind letzten Endes irgendwie
ineinander aufgegangen und ich glaube Eccorn wurde dann von Olivetti gekauft,
haben allerdings einen Teil nicht übernommen, nämlich den Prozessor.
Weil Acorn hat ja zum Schluss noch diesen Archimedes Computer rausgebracht und
das war halt derjenige, der mit der Acorn Risk Machine ausgestattet war.
Also dort wurde quasi der Risk Computer geboren und das fand aber Olivetti wohl
nicht so interessant und dann sind die halt in Cambridge geblieben und haben
halt ihren Prozessor ausgebaut.
Und heute ist das sozusagen die Plattform der Welt.
Was bleibt davon jetzt übrig? Dass halt irgendwie in England so eine Kultur
des Computer-Basteln-und-selber-Machens da ist.
Und diese ganze Maker-Szene ist halt einfach extrem stark.
Also wenn du über dieses Electromagnetic-Field gehst, dann siehst du einfach
überall Leute, die Roboter bauen, krasse Maschinen bauen, irre Geräte.
Und der absolute Oberhammer war ein Flappy Bird.
In 3D gedruckt. In mechanisch.
Also ihr müsst euch vorstellen, da ist so ein Rondell mit diesen Flappy Bird
Säulen in so eine Arkade Maschine eingebaut.
Und diese Säulen drehen sich sozusagen im Kreis. Also immer eine Säule oben, eine Säule unten.
Diese beiden Elemente sind auch höhenverstellbar. Das heißt immer,
wenn du in den nächsten Level kommst, dann gehen die irgendwie weiter zusammen
oder bewegen sich ich auch mal.
Und dein Flappy Bird in der Mitte ist so ein kleine, mit Pixelgrafik verziertes,
mechanisches Element, was halt wirklich durch diese mechanischen Säulen fliegen soll.
Aber wenn du es halt nicht schaffst, mit deiner einen Taste,
mit der du Flappy Bird halt immer wieder zum Flappen bringst,
ihn wirklich durch die Säulen, durch den Zwischenraum zwischen den Säulen durchzubekommen,
dann stößt er also mechanisch gegen diese Diese Säulen.
Und als ich da war, war dann auch der Typ, der das gebaut hat,
war dann irgendwie da und er fragte uns, was meinst du, wie ich das gebaut habe?
Also wie hat er diesen Bewegungselement des Vogels, der halt wirklich physisch
gegen diese Säule kracht, in voller Bewegung, wie hat er den gebaut?
Herr Lehrer, ich habe die Hausaufgaben nicht gemacht.
Ja, das war die Frage, die ich gestellt bekommen habe. Und ja,
kurz darüber nachgedacht, war mir nicht so sicher, aber dann kam dann die Auflösung auch schon raus.
Er hat einfach so einen Joystick aus so einem Nintendo-Controller sozusagen
genommen, der in jede Richtung dreht.
Und der guckt sozusagen von hinten nach vorn. Vorne ist einfach der Vogel drauf.
Das heißt, wenn der Vogel... Um den Kontakt herzustellen quasi.
Genau, wenn der Vogel gegen die Säule fliegt, dann wird einfach dieser Joystick
kurz bewegt. Dadurch geht dann auch nichts kaputt und bricht nichts ab.
Und man kann dann aber auch sofort einfach detektieren, dass da was ist und die Maschine anhalten.
Schön.
So großartig. Also wirklich, Kids des Schaßes nach vor Stunden lang und haben
Flappy Bird gespielt auf dieser Maschine. Das war einfach grandios.
Und davon war wirklich viel zu sehen. Es gab auch noch einen Lunalander,
den der Typ schon mal vorher gebaut hat, der ähnlich funktioniert.
Und all so eine Sachen, aber dann gab es also viel. Also Electromagnetic Field
war auf jeden Fall eine tolle Sache und kann ja jedem nur raten, da hinzugehen.
Insbesondere, wenn man so auf Hardware-Basteleien steht. Ja.
Ich probiere jetzt gerade, da ein Video zu finden.
Gerade schon probiert, nix da.
Ich habe ein Video gemacht, ich werde das nochmal hochladen und dann entsprechend
verlinken mich das auf meinem Kanal.
Achso, und ich habe Matt Parker getroffen. tatsächlich. Da war ich ja ganz begeistert.
Der stand auf einmal vor mir. Und ich war wirklich ein bisschen starstruck dann in dem Moment.
Ach, der Typ!
Der Erfinder des Parker Squares.
Matt Parker, ja, wie heißt sein Kanal? Ja.
Stand-Up-Math.
Stand-Up-Math, genau. Er ist ja, wie ich dann gelernt habe, tatsächlich Australier eigentlich.
Aber er trat sich glaube ich im Wesentlichen in Großbritannien rum.
Klingt aber gar nicht.
Klingt auch überhaupt nicht so. Zumindest ist er,
eigentlich Australier. Oder ist es auch noch.
Es waren auch noch diverse andere YouTuber. Steve Mould war auch noch da und
überhaupt sehr viel lustige Mathematiker.
Die haben auch alle Vorträge gegeben, die leider immer noch nicht veröffentlicht
wurden. Ich hoffe, das kommt noch.
Und das war sehr unterhaltsam. Das war also ganz groß.
Da hat auf jeden Fall England auch einen Vorteil, dass sie da in ihrer Community
so viel wirklich hervorragende Entertainer haben, die auch tolle Talks gemacht
haben. Auch von Numberphile waren einige da.
Also das hat schon ganz gut funktioniert.
Die haben auch ein paar gute YouTuber. Tom Scott, also ich meine,
Tom Scott ist jetzt nicht mehr.
Ja, aber Tom Scott war auch einst schon auf EMF und so weiter.
Also der hatte auch schon mal einen Vortrag gehalten. Schon 20, wann war das?
2016, glaube ich, als er damit angefangen hat mit dem ganzen Videokram.
Ja, und insofern war das eine tolle, tolle Sache. Tolle Reise war das.
Nicht Holland.
Holland ist dann nächstes Jahr gibt es da wieder ein Camp.
Alright. Vielleicht kurz noch Feedback. Wir haben uns letztes Mal über Schlagbohrer
unterhalten. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, warum eigentlich.
Ich kann mich auch nicht erinnern.
Wir wurden auf jeden Fall korrigiert.
Es wurde bemängelt, dass ein Schlagbohrer und eine Schlagbohrmaschine zwei unterschiedliche
Dinge sind und ein Bohrhammer und eine Schlagbohrmaschine sind zwei unterschiedliche Dinge.
Kannst du den Unterschied erklären für uns?
Ich wollte gerade nicht fragen.
Also wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, dann ist es so,
dass der Bohrhammer hat so eine Art Zylinder,
der Luft zusammendrückt und dieser Zylinder,
bewegt so ein Metallteil und dadurch, dass er dieses Metallteil hin und her
bewegt, gibt er dann Schläge auf den eigentlichen Bohrer, der sich zwar auch
dreht, aber dadurch, dass er vor allen Dingen hämmert,
hämmerst du mehr ein Loch, als dass du es bohrst.
Während so eine Schlagbohrmaschine halt eine Bohrmaschine ist,
die aber auch so eine komische Ratsche hat, dass sie halt so ein bisschen lauter ist.
Also sind es zwei komplett verschiedene Dinge, die eigentlich nichts miteinander zu tun haben.
Ja, das eine ist halt mehr ein Bohrer und das andere ist mehr ein Hammer. Also das ist so... Na ja.
Alles klar. Wollen wir nochmal vielleicht, also wir könnten natürlich auch unsere
lokale Intelligenz befragen. Das wäre natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit.
Der Bohrhammer hämmert und kann auch drehen und die Bohrmaschine bohrt und kann
auch ein bisschen hämmern.
So ist der Unterschied. Und die Frage, ob man einen Bohrhammer mit einem Akku
betreiben will, ist glaube ich, kann man auch relativ einfach mit Nein beantworten.
Und je schwieriger halt die Wand, desto eher möchtest du einen Bohrhammer in der Hand halten.
Richtig, also bei einem guten...
Aber bei Bohrhammer ist trotzdem noch Wand da am Ende. Also es ist nicht so... Ich meine, es kann ja...
Wenn du einen ordentlichen Stahlbeton hast,
dann kommst du da mit einem Schlagbohrer zwar einigermaßen rein,
solange du nicht den Armierungsstahl triffst, aber aber nach ein bis zwei Löchern
ist dann auch dein Bohrer durch.
Okay.
Während du mit einem Bohrhammer, je nachdem, also zumindest so Produkte der
Firma Hilti, da musst du den nur an die Wand anlegen, dich schön dagegen lehnen
und dann fährt er von alleine in die Wand rein.
Okay. Aber es sieht schon aus wie so eine Bohrmaschine.
Ja, aber in größer.
Natürlich.
Und die haben auch ein extra Futter. Also du hast nicht dieses,
ich schraube und drehe da irgendwie zu, sondern das ist so mit so Racklack und
dann hält das auch und so.
Das ist der unter... Aber die gibt es auch für Schraubmaschinen,
wo man die einfach so vorne reinsteckt, die Bohrfutter.
Ja, ja, richtig. Aber ein Bohrhammer hat vor allen Dingen so ein Bohrfutter,
damit die etwas größer ausgefallenen Werkzeuge, die du da benutzt,
halt auch ordentlich halten.
Ja, das Stecksystem ist eigentlich die bessere Methode, die man gerne haben würde.
Genau, SDS Plus schreibt hier jemand. Genau, so hieß das. Als ich meinen Bohrhammer
gekauft habe, habe ich auch erstmal eine Runde rumgegoogelt,
was denn diese ganzen Standards sein sollen, bis mehr oder weniger rauskam,
dass es im Prinzip alles das gleiche ist.
Ihr allwissender Müllhalde definiert eine Schlagbohrmaschine als eine Schlagbohrmaschine,
hat eine drehende und eine schlagende Bewegung.
Der Schlagmechanismus wird durch ein mechanisches Zahnradsystem erzeugt,
das eine oszillierende Bewegung auf den Bohrer überträgt.
Ein Bohrhammer nutzt einen elektropneumatischen Schlagmechanismus,
bei dem Druckluft einen Kolben bewegt, der dann auf einen Schlagbolzen trifft
und diesen auf den Bohrer überträgt.
Dies erzeugt eine stärkere Schlagbewegung.
Naja, damit hätten wir das geklärt. Ein für alle Mal.
Vielen Dank für die Korrekturen.
Und dann haben wir uns glaube ich auch noch über Airtex ganz viel unterhalten.
Fahrräder und so weiter. Und dann kam so ein kleiner Hinweis in den Kommentaren,
wo ich etwas aufgelauscht habe.
Und dann habe ich auch gleich so ein Shopping-Urge verspürt und musste das dann
unbedingt mal ausprobieren.
Maus gerutscht.
Genau. Maus gerutscht.
Das hatte mal eine andere Bedeutung.
Ich weiß. Aber nicht mehr.
Nicht mehr. Ja, man kann natürlich auch im Bestellvorgang ausrutschen mit der
Maus. Das ist definitiv so.
Und zwar handelt es sich um das Produkt KeySmart, beziehungsweise die Firma
KeySmart. Ich überlege jetzt gerade, wie genau dieses Produkt heißt. Ich habe es gleich.
KeySmart SmartCard praktischerweise. Und es handelt sich dabei um ein Stück
Plastik mit etwas Elektronik drin, was so aussieht wie so ein Batch oder halt
so Kreditkartenform mit einem kleinen Loch, dass man also auch noch einen Naniat durchmachen kann.
und rein technisch handelt es sich dabei einfach um ein AirTag.
Das Ding ist also zu 100% Find My kompatibel, hat so eine Stelle,
wo so eine leichte Taste angedeutet ist, mit der man dann halt so Pairing und sowas aktivieren kann.
Man muss das dann als Other Device hinzufügen zu Find My, aber dann taucht es
eben genauso auf. Es hat auch einen Pieper.
Und es gibt tatsächlich verschiedenste Produkte dieser Art.
Allerdings gibt es einen Unterschied zwischen diesem Teil und den anderen Produkten dieser Art.
Nämlich, die anderen haben eine Batterie zum Austauschen.
Also haben die so eine Knopfbatterie, die sie da irgendwo noch reinschieben.
Dieses Teil lädst du einfach mit einem Wireless-Ladegerät auf.
Das ist praktisch.
So, und das ist sozusagen alles. Also du kannst es halt einfach auf so ein Ladegerät
legen und dann ist es halt irgendwann voll, Lampe leuchtet grün oder so und
dann hält es wieder ein Jahr, sagen sie.
Ich habe so ein Ding, das, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das heißt,
das muss eines der ersten gewesen sein, was es damals, ich bilde mir ein irgendwas
mit B, aber ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Und da ist so ein magnetisches, ein kleines USB-magnetisches Ding dran ran.
Und da habe ich immer Schiss davor, das Ladegerät zu verlieren,
weil das ist halt so ein total proprietärer Anschluss.
Und dieses mit, das einfach auf so einen Wireless-Charger packen zu können,
vielleicht noch mit MagSafe, das hat mir sofort eingeleuchtet,
dass es eigentlich ganz fantastisch sein muss.
Das ist jetzt gerade meine Hand.
Das fühlt sich auch gut an.
Es ist schwerer als eine Kreditkarte.
Meins ist deutlich mehr plasticky.
Ungefähr doppelt so schwer und es ist auch doppelt so dick. Also die Außenmaße
sind genau gleich. Es passt auch in mein neues fancy Mini,
Portemonnaie ganz gut rein. Das geht schon. Kommt da noch raus, geschwuppst.
Okay, und du sagst, der Akku hält schon Monate irgendwie.
Also ich habe es jetzt noch nicht Monate.
Aber wenn du jetzt ein iPhone aufmachst, hast du es da ganz normal wie so ein AirTag drin.
Genau. Man kann es auch piepen lassen. Es hat natürlich jetzt keinen Ultra-Wideband so zum Feinsuchen.
Aber ich wollte halt was haben, was nicht so ein dicker, fetter AirTag-Knubbel ist.
Und probiere das jetzt einfach mal aus. Soweit funktioniert es.
Und man kann es halt einfach in so eine Brieftasche schön reinschieben.
Wie gesagt, es gibt noch andere Produkte, die ein bisschen günstiger sind,
die dann eben mit Batterien arbeiten.
Das ist jetzt das Einzige, was mir jetzt bekannt ist, was jetzt speziell sich
eben über so einen Wireless-Charger lernen lässt. Es mag auch noch andere geben.
Aber mir wurde das als funktioniert geäußert und dann habe ich halt einfach den Kauf reizt.
Aber man muss auch mal sagen, der AirTag ist wirklich die dämlichste Form für
so ein Ding, die man machen kann, oder?
Also der AirTag hat nur diese Form, damit man die Hülle von Apple für einen
dreifachen Preis dazu kaufen muss.
Also mache ich nicht, ich kaufe mir das für 3 Euro. Diese Smartie-Form,
die doch nur dafür gemacht ist, also ich meine, was kann man damit Sinnvolles machen?
Man kann es vielleicht irgendwo reinschmeißen, das ist vielleicht noch das Einzige, was geht.
Aber ich finde so, also ich habe jetzt hier an meiner Getränkeflasche,
da ist dann so eine dumme Hülle dabei, hat nicht mal ein Loch irgendwie für
ein Keyring, wie diese Karte, die du da gerade hast. Es passt nicht ins Portemonnaie rein.
Ich finde, also da hätte man schon andere Formen, die irgendwie praktischer sind, machen können.
Ja, welche?
Flacher, mit einem Loch drin, damit man es irgendwo dran befestigen kann.
Keine Ahnung. Irgendeine andere Form. Eigentlich fast eine beliebige andere
Form wäre, glaube ich, praktischer gewesen als diese Smartie-Form.
Es gibt jetzt Third-Party alle möglichen Varianten. Es gibt Geräte,
wo das alles schon eingebaut ist. Also ich finde das alles nicht so schlimm.
Der AirTag ist irgendwie auch einfach.
Ich finde die Usability vom AirTag einfach nach wie vor fantastisch.
Im Vergleich zu den anderen.
Ich habe auch schon so eine Karte halt und dieser Piezo, der da drin ist,
der klingt einfach furchtbar im Vergleich.
Diese Apple Geräusche sind ja schon echt angenehm und dann holst du es raus
aus der Verpackung, ziehst das Ding raus, hältst es einmal neben dein Telefon,
alles läuft, vergisst es, dass es überhaupt existiert und dann hast du dieses
Third Party, wo da irgendwelche Buttons sind und du musst dann,
deine Kreditkarte, deine Serious Social Security Number reinmorsen und weiß der Teufel was.
Das ist alles irgendwie, das ist schon sehr schick gemacht bei Apple.
Ich habe neulich einen SDL-File, also ein 3D-File von einem AirTag runtergeladen.
Da hat sich jemand wirklich die Mühe gemacht, das ganz genau zu vermessen.
Und dann kannst du in einer CAD-Software deiner Wahl dieses AirTag benutzen,
um da einen Hohlraum zu kreieren, wo es dann auch perfekt reinpasst.
Also mit anderen Worten, alles was ich machen muss, ist mir noch den passenden
3D-Drucker dazu kaufen.
Den hast du noch nicht?
Ich habe noch keinen 3D-Drucker.
Gut, ich bin in den Topf auch erst neulich gefallen.
Aber du gehörst zu der 75-prozentigen Minderheit. Zu kleine Wohnung dafür.
Gut, dann hast du aber auch noch einen Kaufreiz nachgegeben.
Achso, soll ich jetzt nochmal? Ja, ich habe mir von meinem ehemaligen Arbeitgeber
Meta-Facebook die Glasshole-Brille geholt.
Die heißt Ray-Ban-Meta-Wavefinder-Smartglasses. Es gibt es in verschiedensten Formen.
Wayfinder ist so ein klassisches Ray-Ban. Ich habe keine Ahnung von Ray-Ban.
Ich bin Nerd. Ich habe immer die kleinste Brille genommen und die unauffälligste
Brille, die ich kriegen konnte.
Und jetzt habe ich das erste Mal so ein fettes Ding im Gesicht hängen.
Und ich fand, also Meta baut diese Oculus Quest-Brillen und die bauen halt auch
genau das Gegenteil davon, nämlich so eine kleine unauffällige Brille,
die 90 Prozent, also die allermeisten Leute kriegen einfach nicht mit, dass man die auf...
Also, für die etwas Filmkundigen draußen, es ist die offizielle Blues Brothers
Brille. Das ist eine Ray-Ban Wayflower.
Wayfinder.
Wayfinder, ja. Dann natürlich als Shades, also als Sonnenbrille und Max trägt
sie jetzt mit ganz normal. Ich habe die Versicherungsvertreter-Variante.
Das heißt, sobald ich in die Sonne gehe, wird die dunkel.
Oh, echt? Echt? Ja.
Hatte ich schon mal bei einer anderen Brille?
Wayfarer.
Wayfarer, okay.
Dann habe ich auch falsch verstanden erzählt.
Ray-Ban Wayfarer.
Und...
Und was die eben kann, ist, die hat so ein paar Smart-Funktionen drin.
Also in erster Linie hat sie Kopfhörer, so über den Ohren sitzen, im Bügel drin.
Und die obligatorische Kamera, mit der man Fotos machen kann oder kleine Videos,
woraufhin dann eine LED leuchtet.
Wenn man nach Meta Ray-Ban Smart Glasses Hacking sucht, weil ich wollte mal
gucken, ob man die irgendwie über Bluetooth noch anders ansprechen kann oder
sowas, Das ist das Erste, was man findet.
Creepierweise. Wie kriege ich diese LED aus?
Ich will gar nicht wissen, was die Leute damit machen. Egal.
Und man kann damit telefonieren.
Hat so eine AI-Funktion, die allerdings in Deutschland noch nicht freigeschaltet
ist, weil die ganzen Meta-AI-Sachen, die sind ja noch nicht da.
Ja, also ich kann alles, was ich machen kann darüber, ist glaube ich mir auf
Englisch das Wetter erfragen und den Batteriestand und sowas.
Sie kann auch dann einem WhatsApp-Nachrichten und so Facebook-Messenger-Nachrichten
ankündigen, nur aus dem Mitte-Universum. Das geht offensichtlich.
Ich glaube, sie kriegen die Integration tatsächlich mit einer Sache nicht hin.
Und man kann sie, wenn man einen WhatsApp-Call macht, kann man sie als Kamera nutzen.
Also man kann quasi mit jemandem per WhatsApp telefonieren und dann kann die
andere Person nicht einen selber, sondern sieht das, was man selber sieht.
Da muss man sich dann vor einen Spiegelschall stellen.
Naja, oder du bist halt irgendwie, du gehst halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
es gibt ja auch solche Situationen, wo man das einfach nicht machen will.
Und man vielleicht einfach zeigen will, was man selber gerade sieht, wo das praktisch ist.
und ich bin, also ich war ewig lange so, es gibt es jetzt schon eine Weile länger,
es ist jetzt kein neues Produkt und ich war immer so, will man das,
will man es nicht und diese Idee, immer Kopfhörer aufzuhaben,
fand ich irgendwie ganz, ganz spannend und das ist auch spannend, das ist wirklich.
Wo kommt denn der Ton denn da raus?
Der kommt ja aus dem Arm aus, warte mal, ich setze jetzt mal kurz ab hier Hier
siehst du so kleine Schlitze Wir.
Müssen das jetzt natürlich für unsere.
Also in den Bügeln schreiben.
Also in den Bügeln, die sind relativ schwer. Also das ganze Teil ist relativ
schwer. Also wenn man als Max das aufhatte, sah es wie eine normale Brille aus.
Wenn ich es jetzt bei mir so in der Hand wiege, ist es gefühlt schon doppelt
so schwer wie eine normale Brille. Und auch die Bügel sind viel dicker als bei einer normalen.
Die wiegt 50 Gramm. Ich habe es mal gewogen. Meine alte Brille hat 15 Gramm
gewogen. Also wirklich.
Die ist jetzt natürlich auf meiner...
Es macht Klöng. Ich habe es gerade mal aufgesetzt.
Genau, wenn man es aufsetzt, macht es Klöng.
Also die kann auch sowas, wenn man sie absetzt, dann drückt sie erst mal vorher
Pause und sowas. Das ist alles echt gut gelöst.
Und sie hat halt an der Seite so ein Touchpad dran, worüber man dann lauter leiser machen kann.
Sie vibriert auch etwas, oder?
Da hast du jetzt wahrscheinlich den Ton angeschaltet. Und dann, wenn man Wenn.
Ich jetzt hier ganz doll dran ziehe.
Dann bricht, dann geht sie kaputt.
Und es ist eine erstaunlich praktische Sache. Also es ist halt,
Kopfhörer immer aufzuhaben ist halt, du guckst ein YouTube-Video auf deinem
Telefon und du hast es halt nicht aus dem Lautsprecher, sondern es kommt hier oben raus.
Wie viel bekommt die Umwelt dann mit davon?
Wenn man neben mir sitzt, merkt man schon, dass da was ist. Aber es ist jetzt relativ leid.
Also es ist nicht so, dass man für sich wäre. Man bekommt auch die Umwelt voll
mit, was je nach Einsatzzweck ein gigantischer Vorteil ist oder ein extremer
Nachteil. Also wenn man neben einer lauten Straße läuft, dann kann man die quasi nicht einsetzen.
Dann braucht man Kopfhörer, die was in den Ohren drin haben.
Aber wenn man gerade so einfach...
Podcast hören, so abends, weil ich brauche halt, ich mache es jetzt einfach
mal, dass es auf der Aufnahme drauf ist, dass ich einfach, dass ich auf der
Seite so drauf tippe, auf diesen Bügelarm und mein Podcast spielt einfach weiter.
Und es gibt halt einfach wahnsinnig viele Situationen, wo es deutlich angenehmer
ist, einfach jetzt als die Airpods rauszufummeln und dann in die Ohren rein und sowas.
Man drückt halt kurz gegen, so beim Geschirrspüler leer räumen,
so diese Sachen und hört jetzt einfach nebenbei noch ein bisschen Podcast,
ist das sehr, sehr, sehr angenehm.
Die Audioqualität ist nicht vergleichbar mit echten Kopfhörern.
Das muss ich sagen. Die scheppern deutlich mehr.
Man hat halt die Umgebungsgeräusche drin. Aber um Podcast zu hören, das ist fantastisch.
Und ich war neulich auf der Fahrraddemo hier in Berlin zum großen Stern.
Da ist natürlich so eine Kamera total geil, die man einfach immer im Gesicht zuhören hat.
Wie so eine GoPro, die man aber halt nicht irgendwie dranhängen hat,
sondern dann passt es halt auf dem Gesicht.
Die Bilder sind erstaunlich okay. Fand ich auch. Und die ganze Integration ist erstaunlich gut.
Also es ist so Bilder runterladen, das ist ein bisschen also es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder man macht die App auf und lädt die dann runter.
Das ist, da muss man einen Button bestätigen, dass halt iOS sagt,
ja, ich verbinde mich jetzt mit dem Hotspot von der Brille.
Das hat WLAN. Die hat auch WLAN drin.
Oder sie verbindet sich auch automatisch mit deinem WLAN und lädt dann alle,
also wenn du zu Hause bist,
die nutzt die App zum Lokalisieren und dann kannst du sagen,
ja, wenn ich zu Hause bin, dann verbindet die sich automatisch und lädt alle
deine Bilder in deine Apple Photo Library hoch.
Also sie sind dann einfach da, als ob du sie mit dem iPhone aufgenommen hättest.
As weird as it is, sich eine Kamera ins Gesicht zu hängen, ist das eine erstaunlich praktische Sache.
Benutzt du sie auch als Brille?
Ja, ich habe die jetzt als Brille, ich habe die den ganzen Tag als Brille auf.
Also die ist normale Korrektur sozusagen.
Ja, da sind Linsen drin.
Du bist jetzt immer cyber und hast sozusagen immer, was musst du jetzt genau
machen, um ein Foto zu tun?
Ich habe ja an der Seite, da ist ein physischer Button, der ist auf dem einen
Brillenarm hier drauf und den drücke ich. und dann geht eine LED an,
die du jetzt hoffentlich gerade gesehen hast.
Und dann wurde in dem Moment ein Foto gemacht.
Und wenn du jetzt das Video anmachst?
Wenn ich Video anmache, dann bleibt die einfach an.
Und die pulsiert so ein bisschen rum.
Habe ich keine Ahnung.
Man muss aber sagen.
Es ist schon so eher dezent. Also im Sonnenlicht wird man es nicht sehen und
es ist auch nicht rot. Es ist nicht rot.
Auf einer Party würde man das noch eher als fancy LED-Deko weiß ich.
Keine Ahnung. Also ich glaube, die maximale Aufnahmezeit ist eine Minute.
Also man kann ja jetzt auch nicht beliebig lange mit aufnehmen.
Ich glaube, da haben sie schon probiert, dass man halt eben dieses heimlich Leute aufnehmen.
Wie lange hält der Akku?
Nicht lang genug, aber man hält einen Tag durch. Meistens.
Einen Tag was? Tag die ganze Zeit Audio hören?
Nee, Tag die ganze Zeit aufhaben.
Aufhaben verbunden, indem sie keinen Strom haben?
Ja, aufhaben und hin und wieder mal ein Podcast.
Wieso wird die, wenn du sie nicht benutzt, leer?
Die muss ja auch mit Bluetooth verbunden sein die ganze Zeit.
Wieso muss sie das?
Weil ich nicht in die Einstellung will.
Okay, aber das ist ja Bluetooth 4, also das verbraucht ja relativ wenig.
Also ich komme meistens damit, mit hier und da mal eine halbe Stunde Podcast
hören und ein, zwei Fotos am Tag machen, komme ich meistens über den Tag.
Oder hast du mal ausprobiert, einfach mal so Video aufnehmen,
Video aufnehmen, Video aufnehmen, Video aufnehmen.
Wie lange dauert es, bis der Akku leer ist? Das habe ich tatsächlich nicht ausprobiert.
Wenn der alle ist, siehst du nichts mehr.
Das wäre die nächste Frage gewesen.
Die kann ich nicht machen. Ich muss noch nach Hause kommen. Tut mir leid, meine Brille ist leer.
Die Videos...
Ich muss jetzt weg.
Die Videos nimmt halt auch Hochkant auf. Das kann man nicht irgendwie ändern oder drehen.
Das kann man nicht ändern. Sind die Hochkant? Weiß ich jetzt gar nicht.
Also dein Fahrradvideo ist, hab ich gerade mal im Slack verlinkt,
dein Fahrradvideo ist Hochkant. Ja.
Okay, ja siehste. Ja, das ist Hochkant. Ja, das ist natürlich Instagram-tauglich.
3 zu 4 hätte ich jetzt gesagt. Das ist das Seitenverhältnis.
Und das hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht, einfach auf der Nase rumzufahren,
hin und wieder mal ein Foto zu machen oder ein Video zu machen auf dieser Fahrradtour,
halt nicht irgendwie mit dem Telefon in der Hand shaky dastehen zu müssen, das fand ich sehr nett.
Also apropos shaky, da muss auch irgendwas an Bildstabilisierung drin sein.
Ja, ja, ich glaube, was die auch machen, die machen mit AI, dass sie halt,
sie hat einen deutlich größeren Winkel, ein deutlich größeres Fischauge,
glaube ich, und wählt dann einen Ausschnitt nochmal, den sie für passend hält.
Also da ist definitiv eine Stabilisierung dabei.
Und die Qualität fällt, muss ich auch sagen, bei Dunkelheit ist das jetzt kein
iPhone oder Pixel oder Samsung irgendwas.
Also da fällt die schon deutlich ab. Wenn Licht da ist, ist das einfach super.
Hat die auch in den Fotos dann auch eine Ortsinformation?
Müsste ich mal gucken. Ich nehme mal an, dass die Brille das selber nicht hat.
Aber das kann sich ja dann holen. Beziehungsweise die App könnte das ja dann,
keine Ahnung, wenn die App weiß, dass du ein Foto gemacht hast,
könnte die App ja diese Information vielleicht schon mal notieren.
Ja, hat sie. Hat sie. Ich habe hier gerade ein Video und da ist ein Pin im entsprechenden,
in der Fotos App. Gestern habe ich ja noch eins gemacht, genau.
Und gestern waren wir, du ja auch Tim, waren wir beim Keynote gucken und da
haben Leute Wir haben heute über diese Brille geredet und nicht gemerkt.
Dass du sie aufhattest.
Was je nach Geschmacksrichtung furchtbar ist oder super.
Ja, du hast mir auch mal ein Video geschickt und in der Tat ist die Qualität okayisch.
Es ist nicht grandios, aber es ist okayisch.
Also ich finde es ganz interessant, wir erinnern uns ja, oder zumindest die
Älteren unter uns erinnern sich ja wirklich noch an Google Glass und was das
für einen Aufschrei gegeben hat.
Ja, krass, oder?
Und jetzt liegt halt sowas rum und niemand kümmert sich irgendwie.
Ich glaube, dass es halt einfach nicht so einen großen Aufschlag gemacht hat
und vor allen Dingen die Google Glass war halt auch sowas von hässlich Du.
Hast halt sofort gesehen, dass da alles irgendwie anders ist und mit diesem
eingeblotten Display haben sie sich da halt.
Also hier gehen gerade durch den Slack-Channel ein paar Reviews hier von The Verge und von Mr.
Mobile, Michael Fischer die alle erstaunlich positiv waren und was bei mir den
Ausschlag ergeben hat, war dann, dass ich auch in irgendeinem Podcast gehört habe.
So, ja, ich überlege ja, ob ich mir die holen soll oder nicht.
Do it! They are so great! Und dann, okay, jetzt mach ich das auch.
Jetzt geb ich mir das mal.
Das ist aber einfach zu überzeugen.
Wie gesagt, ich war schon länger Also.
Dass das jetzt wirklich die Blues Brothers Brille ist, finde ich ja tempting fast schon.
Also, Moment, Moment, Internet. Ich hab gerade eben den Reddit-Thread gesehen,
wo abgestritten wird, dass das eine Blues Brothers Original-Brille ist,
weil die, wie war es jetzt gerade? Wayfinder?
Wayfarer.
Wayfarer, angeblich nicht die Ray-Ban aus dem Film ist, sondern eine leicht
andere aus den 60ern, die sehr, sehr ähnlich aussieht, aber nicht genau dieses Modell ist.
Da habe ich jetzt andere Quellen gefunden.
Die das sehr wohl bestätigen. Was ich sagen muss, was krass war,
war, also ich hätte die ja gerne mal vorher aufprobiert, bevor ich sie hatte.
Schon allein, weil ich einen sehr dicken Schädel habe und ich wusste nicht, ob die passt.
Und ich bin zum Optiker meines Vertrauens gegangen und er hat gesagt,
nee, tut mir leid, ich kann die leider nicht haben, weil die gehören ja Eigentlich
gehören ja alle Brillenhersteller zu einem riesengroßen Konzern.
Der dominiert den Markt, bestimmt die Bedingungen und darum kriegt man die nirgendwo.
Jetzt gibt es aber auch keinen Ray-Ban Flagship Store in Berlin oder in Europa
oder ich weiß nicht, also in Berlin gibt es auf jeden Fall keinen.
Ich habe eine ganze Weile recherchiert. oder zumindest, vielleicht ist auch
einfach nur die Webseite von Ray-Ban so scheiße,
dass man darüber nichts findet und im Endeffekt habe ich die einfach bestellt
und war froh, dass sie gepasst hat und ich musste auch eine ganze Weile,
um mich dran zu gewöhnen,
aber so diese ganze Erfahrung mit Ray-Ban, das hat dann auch so,
ja, ich habe den bestellt und dann, ja, also nach,
Geldeingang so zwei Wochen Lieferzeit, wo du ja auch so denkst,
was ist das? Also ich meine, was braucht das so lange?
Ja, aber jeder normale Optiker braucht auch zwei Wochen, bis er dir die Brille
zusammen geht, dengelt.
Ja, aber ich habe nichts. Ich habe ohne Stärken, ich habe die dann von meinem
Optiker die richtigen Gläser einsetzen lassen.
Ich habe einfach die billigste Variante genommen, ohne irgendwelche Stärken, ohne sonst irgendwas.
Ja, there's your problem.
Vielleicht Backorder oder irgendwas.
Also die kam direkt aus China auch. Aber das war, also da hatte ich mir schon mehr erhofft.
so dass man einfach auch irgendwo hingehen kann und die mal ausprobieren kann.
Vielleicht gibt es auch irgendwelche Geschäfte, wo das geht.
Also, es gibt fünf Ray-Ban Geschäfte in ganz Deutschland und das ist Hamburg,
Köln, Frankfurt, Stuttgart, München.
Ja.
Berlin ist nicht zahlungskräftig genug.
Eindeutig.
Offensichtlich nicht.
Nicht die Zielgruppe.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Also an Coolness kannst du uns mangeln sonst nicht, daran kannst du nicht liegen. Sicher?
Also, ChadJBT sagt, die Hauptstelle des Films Blues Brothers Jake und Elwood
Blues trugen Ray-Ban Wayfarer Sonnenbrillen.
Dieses Modell ist ein ikonischer Klassiker und wurde durch den Film weiter populär gemacht.
Also wenn Chet Chippity das sagt, dann ist es ja wohl...
Also ich habe als Alternative dazu gerade hier den Beitrag von Reddit,
wo es jemand versucht genau nachzuweisen.
Mögen sich die Hörerinnen und Hörer einfach selber ein Bild machen?
Reddit. Naja, anyway.
Das ist auch nicht so wichtig.
Aber Blues Brothers, ich treffe ja in letzter Zeit immer so Leute,
die dann die ganzen tollen filme gar nicht mehr kennen und wo es dann auch schon
schwierig wird den leuten überhaupt noch zu vermitteln das ist auch schon vor
30 jahren und so geile filme gab die man unbedingt kennen muss damit man noch mitreden kann dass.
Da was kennen sie alle.
Auch wenn alle ihre freunde,
Ich hab sogar schon, also Ken, naja, von gehört und so, aber sogar Star Wars
ist da schon ein Problembereich.
Ja, ja, weiß nicht. Guck ich mir mal an. Ja, also Ich.
Gehöre definitiv zu den Leuten, die einige wirklich relevante Filme nicht gesehen haben.
Aber Blues Brothers hast du gesehen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich ihn jemals vollständig gesehen habe.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ob ich ihn jemals vollständig nicht gesehen habe. Oh man, oh man.
Doch, jetzt wären wir wieder einig.
Ich habe ihn gesehen.
Wir sitzen im Dunkeln, wir haben einen halbvollen Tank.
Es geht doch, es geht doch.
Max.
Und wir tragen Sonnenbrillen.
Herr Lehrer.
So sieht es aus.
Aber es wundert mich, dass du den kennst, Tim, weil ich jetzt nicht gedacht
habe, dass das Musik für dich ist.
Das ist fantastisch. Ich meine, das ganze Album ist doch super episch und wer
da alles mitsingt, Aretha Franklin.
Ich weiß. Ich habe ihn diverse Male gesehen.
Ich habe ihn auch diverse Male gesehen. Das ist ja auch so ein Film,
das ist ja auch, wann ist der nochmal genau gedreht worden?
Nur der eine Straßenmusiker ist leider nicht auf dem Soundtrack mit drauf.
Das finde ich jedes Mal schade.
Der ist echt gut, aber den haben sie nicht im Soundtrack.
1980.
Das ist jetzt auch schon mal 24 Jahre, nee, 44.
44 Jahre alt?
44 Jahre alt, ja, ja, genau.
Bald feiern wir 50 Jahre Blues Brothers.
Ja, und vor allem der Film ist ja aus einem äh wenn ich das richtig erinnere,
aus so einem Saturday Night Live Skit.
Diese Figuren wurden sozusagen eigentlich für Saturday Night Live geschaffen.
Also Dan Aykroyd gehörte ja damals schon schon zu dem SNL-Team und ich glaube
der, ja beide, ne, also der andere nochmal,
John Belushi und dann ist das irgendwie so populär geworden,
bis dann irgendwann John Landis gesagt hat, wir machen jetzt da mal einen Film
draus und der Film war halt so over the top und so ein großartiger,
wie soll man sagen, so ein Pop-Höhepunkt, ne, also einfach die Musik gefeiert wurde
und der Humor einfach so großartig ist und die Coolness der beiden Hauptdarsteller,
nicht zuletzt durch diese Sonnenbrillen, also diese ganze Erscheinung in meinem
Anzug mit diesen Sonnenbrillen und einfach so durchgehend cool und es kommen auch so,
dermaßen over the top viele Polizeiautos zu Schaden.
Der Film ist einfach in jeder Hinsicht grandios.
Carrie Fisher spielt übrigens auch mit.
Wollte ich gerade überleiten. Selbst Star Wars kommt hier.
Chaka Khan, Also das ganze Aretha Franklin, Ray Charles, also fantastisch.
Twiggy ist da mit dabei.
Twiggy? Twiggy.
Wo kommt die denn vor?
Autofahrerin heißt es hier. Das muss irgendeine kurze Szene sein.
Und Steven Spielberg spielt einen Finanzbeamten.
Wir spielen beide Arten.
Country und Western.
Genau. Da hat man so viele...
Ich glaube, der Alter ist auch wirklich gut. Also ich glaube,
den kann man auch immer noch...
Der ist fantastisch, genau. Also nehmt euch, wenn ihr den Film nicht kennt,
ladet alle Freunde ein, große Leinwand, Kiste, Bier.
Gute Stereoanlage dran.
Gute Stereoanlage, große Boxen.
Richtig guter Sound, ganz, ganz, ganz wichtig.
Schickt die Nachbarn in den Urlaub und dann geht's los.
Und ihr werdet der Freakshow auf ewig dankbar sein, dass ihr das getan habt.
The Blues Brothers. Wenn der Film euch nicht schon nach 30 Sekunden überzeugt
hat, würde mich das wundern.
Und jetzt kriegen Nazis aufs Maul. Richtig. Danke.
Stimmt. Nazis kriegen auch aufs Maul.
Jetzt bin ich auch überzeugt.
Spätestens das sollte überzeugen.
Wir haben alles aufgefahren.
Was soll man sonst noch sagen? Okay, dann lass uns mal in die Welt der künstlichen
Intelligenz eintreten und wir schalten um in das Epizentrum der künstlichen Intelligenz.
Der künstlichen Intelligenz?
Ja, der neue Epizentrum. Nach Berlin.
Was? Was?
Was? Herr Stockmann, übernehmen Sie.
Übernehmen Sie. Ich war letzte Woche in Hamburg, nicht in Berlin. Okay.
Und zwar auf dem Kongress, aber jetzt nicht auf irgendeinem CCC-Kongress, sondern der Bibliocon.
Genau, der Bibliocon 2024. Wisst ihr, was die Bibliocon ist?
Ich vermute mal, das ist die geile … Eine Sexmesse.
Für Bibliothekare.
Die einen sagen so, die anderen so.
Und alle ist bloß über was verkleidet.
Nein, das ist also die jährliche Convention in der Tat für das deutsche Bibliothekswesen,
wo man also dann so hinpilgert und wo drei, vier Tage, je nachdem wie man rechnet,
viele Vorträge gehalten werden.
Also es ist der Kongress halt so fürs Bibliothekswesen.
Und zu dem Anlass, das war zeitlich eher fast ein bisschen Zufall,
aber tun wir mal einfach so, als sei es totale Absicht gewesen,
haben wir von Föpp einen neuen Dienst.
Kurz Föpp erklären.
Genau, das ist der Verbund der öffentlichen Bibliotheken Berlins.
Wir erinnern uns, ich habe es glaube ich schon mal erzählt in einer früheren
Folge, Berlin ist ja in zwölf Bezirke aufgeteilt.
Ich erinnere mich nicht.
Aber. Und in diesen Bezirken gibt es jeweils quasi eigenständige mehr oder weniger
Bibliotheksunternehmungen und die verwalten insgesamt 66 Einzelstandorte an Bibliotheken.
Und der Föb sorgt dafür, dass die alle zusammenspielen. Es gab mal Zeiten,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie lange die her sind.
Kann ich einen Bug-Report da lassen?
Ja, wir kommen gleich dazu. Es gab mal Zeiten, wo du also, wenn du an zwei Bibliotheken
was ausleihen wolltest, brauchtest du zwei Bibliotheksausweiskarten.
Also je nachdem, in welchem Bezirk die halt irgendwie unterwegs waren.
Und das wurde dann alles mal vereint und im Föb zusammengeführt und jetzt hast
du also eine einzige Bibliothekskarte für ganz Berlin.
Jeder zehnte Berlinerin hat in der Tat auch eine. Das ist im Moment so die aktuelle
Zeit, ich glaube 400.000 ungefähr.
Immerhin, kann auch mehr werden, aber immerhin. Und was wir jetzt gemacht haben
in diesem Föpp-Verbund ist, dass wir das in der Tat weltweit erste KI-Chatbot-System
auf unserem Katalog gestartet haben.
Das heißt also, wenn man jetzt auf die Webseite geht vom vöb.de.
Ihr habt aber nicht vöbb.de auch gekauft.
Weiß ich nicht.
Nein, habt ihr nicht. Also zumindest nicht freigeschaltet.
Das könnte man natürlich in der Tat nochmal machen. Danke für den Hinweis.
Bitteschön.
So, dann sieht man, dass man auf dieser Seite erstmal gar nichts,
einem nichts besonders ins Auge springt, was jetzt irgendwie nach KI und so weiter aussieht.
Das liegt daran, dass wir uns, ich glaube, aus guten Gründen dafür entschieden
haben, einen sogenannten Silent-Launch zu machen.
Das heißt also, man stellt erstmal was online und guckt erstmal,
ob es ein paar Leute finden und sammelt ein bisschen Feedback ein und guckt,
wie funktioniert das Ganze überhaupt. Haupt.
Ersichtlich ist, wenn ich das jetzt hier promote, der aktuelle Status nicht mehr ganz so silent.
Ihr könnt also jetzt nach unten rechts schauen. Dort habt ihr so ein stilisiertes,
orangefarbenes, ins Rot weisende Chat-Icon mit so zwei Sprechblasen.
So ein Nehmen Sie Kontakt mit unserem Service-Mitarbeiter auf.
So ungefähr.
Und dann wandert man nur, dann kommt nur ein Chatbot, an dem man erstmal vorbeikommt.
Und dann kommt ein Chatbot, der einen vollquasselt, genau. So,
und was passiert dort aber?
Und das ist eben schon ganz spannend.
Bei mir kommt da kein Chatbot.
Wenn du drauf drückst, sollte sich ein Fenster öffnen. Das hast du wahrscheinlich
wieder mit deinem fiesen...
Wo ist das? Irgendwo unten, sagtest du?
Unten rechts. Genau, unten rechts.
Rechts ist das andere rechts. Also ich habe das eine nach oben. Ganz unten.
Du musst mal gucken, ob du irgendwo eine Prevention drin hast,
dass irgendwelche Overlays gestartet verhindert werden.
Wie? Ach, der macht ein eigenes Fenster auf?
Nee, der macht kein Fenster auf.
Der macht ein Layer oben drüber. weil das hat auch einen gewissen technischen
Grund. Über die Details würde ich da jetzt nicht so weit reingehen.
Lass mal zu, dass da Pop-Ups zugelassen sind auf der Seite, dann geht's.
Oder probier's mobil, da geht's auch.
Was man jetzt ja so machen kann, ist sich eben mit dem Katalog unterhalten.
Das heißt also Ziel dieses Chatbots ist jetzt nicht irgendwie das Weltwissen zu beantworten,
sondern konkret eine andere Art des Zugangs zu geben zu allen Beständen,
die im Fab in den verschiedenen Bibliotheken nachgewiesen sind.
Und wie haben wir das gemacht?
Dahinter werkelt jetzt quasi die normale Sprachintelligenz von einem Large Language Model.
In dem Fall ist es jetzt über OpenAI, die 3.5er API, die wir dort ansprechen.
Und da haben wir zusammen mit zwei Dienstleisterfirmen eben unseren kompletten
Metadatenkatalog als sogenanntes Embedding reingebunden.
Das ist ein Standardprozedere, was OpenAI anbietet. Das ist also nichts,
was irgendwie besonders originell ist oder was so in der Art noch keiner gemacht hat.
Das hat halt nur noch keiner mit einem kompletten Bibliothekskatalog gemacht.
Das heißt also, wir haben die Firma, die unsere ganzen Metadaten hostet,
Aztec, die haben einen JSON-Export gemacht und dann eine zweite Firma, Realport,
mit der haben wir auch schon im Bereich Video zusammengearbeitet,
die haben das Ganze dann halt in so eine Vektorraum-Datenbank überführt,
was dann halt ein entsprechendes Embedding ist.
Und das, was jetzt also passiert, ist, dass man über diesen Chatbot sich eben
erstmal ganz normal mit quasi ChatGPT 3.5 unterhält und der dann aber bei jedem
Zwischenschritt quasi mit der zweiten KI redet, zu dem, was ich glaube,
was hier gerade gesucht wird, habt ihr dort entsprechend eigentlich irgendwo
eine Literatur oder eine CD oder ein Video oder was auch immer.
Und das Ganze funktioniert so okayisch und je nachdem, was für Suchszenarien
man hat, ist das mal mehr oder weniger nützlich und sinnvoll und das versuchen
wir jetzt halt ein bisschen genauer auszuloten, wofür ist es gut und wofür ist es nicht gut.
Wofür es spektakulär gut ist, ist erstmal Fremdsprachen.
Das heißt also, das Teil spricht halt 90 Sprachen, weil JetGPT halt relativ
flüssig 90 Sprachen spricht.
Das heißt also, man muss sich jetzt nicht Gedanken darüber machen,
wie kann ich dort einen multilingualen Katalog aufsetzen oder ähnliches,
sondern in welcher Sprache die Berlinerinnen und Berliner hier auch immer aufschlagen.
Sie werden hier vernünftig empfangen und können sich dort flüssig jetzt eine
Katalogrecherche machen.
Das geht über den normalen Metadaten so ohne weiteres schon mal nicht.
Ich kann natürlich jetzt auch mit beliebigen Sprachniveaus machen.
Ich habe Unschärfe drin. Ich kann falsche Formulierungen machen.
Trotzdem versteht der KI-Chatbot das hier ganz gut.
Ich kann so Fuzzy-Suchen machen, was immer so ein klassischer Test ist,
den ich ja ganz gerne mache, um zu gucken, was verändert sich.
wie, ich habe als Kind so ein Science-Fiction-Buch gelesen, wo dreibeinige Aliens
die Erde erobert haben. Wie hieß das nochmal?
Das heißt also, ich erinnere irgendetwas von einem Buch, was ich irgendwann
mal gelesen habe, habe aber keine Ahnung, wie hieß der Autor,
habe keine Ahnung, wie jetzt irgendwie der Titel war oder ähnliches.
Solche Fragen kann das System erstaunlich gut beantworten.
Und kommt es dann daher, weil einfach aus dem Datensatz, mit dem in das GPT-Modell
trainiert worden ist oder tatsächlich irgendwie die Anbindung an eure Datenbank?
Naja, es ist halt immer dieser zweistufige Prozess. Das heißt also,
bei dem Beispiel, was ich gerade gesagt habe, weiß erstmal das Allgemeinwissen
von JetGPT, dass das die dreibeinigen Herrscher von, wie hieß er,
Jack Williams oder sowas irgendwo ist? Ne, Jack London?
Irgendwie sowas in der Art. Also Engländer ist das gewesen. So und dann fragt
er dann eben die Bibliotheks-KI, den Katalog ab, Achtung, hast du von diesem
Autor mit diesem Titel etwas?
Bekommt das zurück und das interpretiert dann wiederum ChatGPT und gibt mir
dann die entsprechende Antwort zurück.
Oder auch eine Frage, die ich gerne stelle, ist hier der klassische Science-Fiction-Film
Lost, nee, Forbidden Planet.
Ich habe irgendwann mal gelesen, dass das auf einem klassischen Stück basiert.
Was war denn das nochmal? mal.
So, versuch mal so eine Frage irgendwie in einem klassischen Bibliothekskatalog
zu stellen und dann kommt es halt dann als Antwort raus, oh ja,
das basiert auf der Sturm von Shakespeare und hier haben wir die drei Ausgaben
davon, können Sie sich ausleihen und entsprechend dann durchlesen.
Das heißt also, das sind die Szenarien, wo ich finde, wo das Ganze wirklich
glänzt und wo es total Sinn entfaltet, dass man so was hat.
Was es weniger gut kann, ist eine sogenannte Known-Item-Search.
Das heißt also das, was ein klassischer OPAC eigentlich macht.
Das heißt, ich weiß schon, wie mein Buch heißt, ich weiß, wer der Autor ist
und möchte entsprechend gucken, wo kann ich das als nächstes irgendwie abholen.
Und für solche Fragen ist es jetzt derzeit einfach schlicht nicht gedacht.
Es ist eine Ergänzung zu unserem klassischen Katalog und nicht etwas,
was hier als dauerhafter Ersatz gemeint ist.
Also spielt da mal ein bisschen mit rum.
Das ist ganz lustig. Ich habe gerade nach was gesucht und dann kam eine Antwort.
Dann habe ich da draufgeklickt und das führt ins Nirgendwo.
Dann habe ich geschrieben, der Link ist kaputt.
Schreibt er zurück, entschuldige den Fehler. Hier ist der korrigierte Link zum Buch, bla bla bla.
Und?
Ist er da korrigiert oder so?
Ja, der funktioniert.
Okay. Was können wir jetzt daran drehen? Also an den Metadaten,
das sind einfach zu viele.
Greift das auf irgendeine Datenbank zu, dass es irgendwelche Functions ruft
und dann irgendwie eine Suche durchführen kann oder sowas?
Nee, eigentlich gar nicht. Also es sind wirklich nur diese beiden Standardkomponenten.
Chat gibt es hier auf der einen Seite. Wir können im Backend auch die Version umschalten.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt den Eindruck hat, so richtig clever ist jetzt hier
der Chatbot als solches, aber nicht, dann liegt das daran, dass wir halt die
Standard 3.5er Version jetzt hier nehmen aus reinen Kostengründen.
Das heißt, wir könnten jetzt auf 4 oder 4.0 umschalten, dann wird es wahrscheinlich
nochmal einen Tucken besser.
Wir haben aber gemerkt, dass jetzt für den relativ begrenzten Use Case,
den wir jetzt hier abbilden wollen, ist der Unterschied nicht so dramatisch.
Also du kannst jetzt natürlich irgendwelche Trickfragen versuchen reinzuposten
und wirst dann sehen, dass die KI dann da auf die Knie geht,
aber dafür ist er jetzt halt einfach mal nicht gedacht.
Er soll jetzt nicht irgendwie Weltwissen halt hier vermitteln.
Also er hat keinen Zugang zu einer Datenbank oder sowas, dieses Bot-Ding?
Naja, er hat in dieses Embedding rein. Das heißt also, es ist eben quasi unser
kompletter Metadatenkatalog, also alle Titel.
Das heißt also, wie heißt das entsprechende Buch oder der entsprechende Film,
Autor, Schlagworte sind komplett drin.
Manchmal eine Beschreibung, aber schon eher selten und halt keine Volltexte.
Also das ist sicherlich nochmal eine...
Und woher kommt der Link?
Der ist Teil der Vektor-Datenbank, das heißt also zusammen, wir haben natürlich
den Deep-Link quasi in unserem Katalog, ist ja Teil des Abzuges, den wir haben.
Das heißt also du hast quasi wirklich so einen ganz klassischen bibliothekarischen
Metadaten-Record für Bibliotheken, Titel, Autor, URL.
Und die URL geht dann wieder zurück halt in unseren ganz klassischen Katalog
und da kannst du gucken, okay, an welchen Bibliotheken in Berlin kann ich mir
das Buch jetzt ausleihen oder gibt es sogar eine Online-Ausgabe,
dass ich mir das direkt irgendwie am Screen angucken kann.
Ich habe jetzt mal gesucht nach einem Buch und er hat mir verschiedene Bücher vorgeschlagen,
aber nicht das,
was ich gesucht habe und jetzt habe ich im Vergleich nochmal ChatGPT exakt dieselbe
erste Frage gestellt und das ist gleich die erste Antwort sozusagen schon das Ergebnis.
Ich benutze aber dann auch Chat-GPT 4.0 und nicht 3.5, das mag schon mal eine
Rolle haben. Aber ich habe erstmal eine andere Frage.
Welche Frage hast du denn gestellt? Ich suche einen Roman.
Wo ein Protagonist besonders gut riechen kann und dann eine besondere Lebensgeschichte entwickelt.
Das Parfum oder was?
Das Parfum, das Süßkind, das sollte er können.
Ja, kann aber nicht. Hat mir diverse andere Sachen vorgeschlagen und Duft der
Erinnerung, Haus der Düfte, die Schnüfflerin, tödlicher Düft, war alles dabei.
Am Ende habe ich sogar noch gesagt, es sind viele Morde in Serie,
die Opfer sind alle Frauen.
Leider konnte ich keine spezifische Empfehlung geben. Da weiß ich nicht so ganz genau.
Also ich glaube, da wäre sicherlich ein Upgrade des Modells nochmal ganz wertvoll.
Aber ich habe nochmal eine Verständnisfrage, weil ich selber auch immer noch
ein wenig rätsel, wie dockt man jetzt eigentlich ein spezifisch abgegrenztes
Wissen an so etwas wirklich an?
Also ihr habt euer Metadatenkram genommen und ich würde mal meinen,
es würde wohl sehr gut tun, wenn hier wirklich die Volltexte auch dabei wären.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr darauf Zugriff habt.
Kann ich gleich was zusagen.
Ähm.
Kannst du nochmal beschreiben, was für Undock-Stellen bieten diese LLMs oder
spezifisch jetzt dieses LLM?
Also was, weil man trainiert ja dann nicht das Modell weiter.
Genau.
Aber man macht ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass man jetzt vor jedem Query den kompletten
Katalog wirft und sagt, das ist jetzt hier mein Prompt.
Genau. Also was ist jetzt genau der Checkpoint? Wo kommt dieses Domänen-spezifische Wissen dazu?
Also das kommt über zwei Ebenen rein. Zum einen ist es eben,
wie ich vorhin schon sagte, wirklich diese ganz klassische, also klassisch zwei
Jahre alte, anderthalb Jahre Embedding-Schnittstelle von OpenAI. AI.
So, das ist also quasi ein Standardprozedere, ist auch alles gut dokumentiert,
kann man sich angucken, wo du also sagen kannst, okay, was auch immer du für
Daten hast, auch fast egal, wie groß die sind,
wirf die mal rüber, wir transferieren dir das in eine Vektordatenbank und dann
kannst du das halt entsprechend dann einbinden in ein Chatbot.
Das ist also relativ Standardprozedere. Was wir dann oben drüber legen,
kannst du mal den Beamer umschalten bitte, dass das Bild da mal raus ist.
Den Bild habe ich jetzt gerade eben gesetzt.
Ist dann eben ein Priming über einen Prompt, der halt vor allem da vorgeschaltet ist.
Und den haben wir, weil wir dachten, das ist doch einfach mal eine gute Idee,
auf GitHub veröffentlicht.
Das heißt also mit dem Link, den ihr jetzt hoffentlich in den Shownotes seht
oder jetzt gerade auch hier im Slack, könnt ihr mal gucken, was haben wir dort
eigentlich vorgeschaltet.
landen dann auf GitHub und dann prime-prompt.md, also Markdown-Datei.
Warum ist der Prompt auf Englisch?
Weil es besser funktioniert. Ja, okay. Das war eine der ersten Sachen, die wir gemerkt haben.
Übrigens, wenn ich jetzt immer wir sage, dann ist das ein bisschen Schmück mit falschen Federn.
Das hat im Wesentlichen der Moritz Mutter gemacht vom Fab Service Zentrum,
der ja auch Leiter ist der ganzen digitalen Welten.
Das ist derjenige, der also hier mindestens 95 Prozent der Arbeit gemacht hat,
unter anderem auch genau das Ausbaldowern dieses Prompts hier.
Da sehen wir, der ist ungefähr zwei DIN A4 Seiten lang, wenn überhaupt.
Dort steht halt erstmal drin so, okay, was ist überhaupt das Ziel der ganzen
Geschichte? Hallo Chatbot, wer bist du eigentlich?
Dein eigentliches Ziel ist es, immer zu Recommendations hinzuführen,
das heißt also eben keine Wissensfragen beantworten, sondern immer gucken,
wie leite ich jetzt über halt in diesen OPAC-Bereich.
Dann spezial wissen, wie halt hier unsere Metadaten aufgebaut sind mit diesem Mark-XML-Format.
Das ist also ein XML, das in der Bibliothekswelt halt so der Standardformat
ist, wie sich die Links zusammensetzen, wie er so kleine Vorschauen dann von
den Linktreffern machen kann.
Und am Ende auch ein paar Downs, also du hasst Hitler und hältst wirklich nichts
von Nationalsozialismus.
Das heißt also auch da kann man schon ein bisschen Nudging betreiben.
Ja, trotzdem ist das sicherlich ein Bereich, wo wir jetzt auch an Feedback sicherlich
noch sehr interessiert sind.
Das heißt also, wie man verhindern kann, dass dort dann noch wieder sonst was
für Dinge empfohlen werden.
Wobei am Ende des Tages, es gibt ja immer dieses Neutralitätsgebot von Bibliotheken.
Also wenn wir die Werke im Bestand haben, dann muss man sie natürlich auch über
den OPAG irgendwo finden können.
Also da kommt man nicht drum rum. So, der letzte Abschnitt ist dann nochmal
Information über die Bibliotheken selber und wie wir als Bibliothek funktionieren,
weil wir schon im Pre-Test gemerkt haben, dass Leute das auch fragen.
Das heißt also, wo kann ich einen Bibliotheksausweis machen oder wo kann ich
mein Konto verlängern oder ähnliches.
Da sind also einfach nochmal so eine Top Ten an häufig gefragtesten Dingen,
die jetzt gar nichts mit der eigentlichen KI-Funktion zu tun haben,
wo wir aber versuchen nochmal das auch einigermaßen mit abzudecken,
weil es halt einfach häufig gefragte Dinge sind, die passieren und die mit reinzunehmen.
Wenn man so eine kleine Konversation gemacht hat, nach fünf Fragen hin und her
oder vier glaube ich im Moment sogar, ist Schluss.
Dann kann man wieder von vorne anfangen, aber die jeweilige Konversation ist dann zu Ende.
Das ist von uns eine ganz bewusst gesetzte Marke, um...
Erstmal Fernsteuerung und Überlast zu verhindern, dass also jemand vollautomatisiert
jetzt anfängt, da einfach zigtausendfach irgendwelche Requests hinzuschicken.
Wie gesagt, man kann sofort sagen, starte nochmal ein neues Gespräch und dann
zählt der Counter wieder los, aber nicht, dass man sich da wundert.
Nachdem man einmal diese vier Frage-Antwort-Paare durch hat,
kommt man, wenn man möchte, zu einem Feedback-Formular und da freuen wir uns
sicherlich über viel Feedback.
Also wenn ich das richtig verstehe, der eigentliche Glue, der jetzt quasi den
Chatbot mit den importierten Daten verbindet, ist tatsächlich dieser Metaprompt,
in dem man das explizit beschreibt.
You have access to a tool called Load Embeddings to generate recommendations,
use it when necessary und später Catalog Entries are human readable derived
from Mark XML, was vermutlich da euer Metadatenformat ist.
Und diese Load Embeddings.
Das ist einfach, also hat das irgendwelche Parameter oder sowas,
der Befehl oder schmeißt das einfach die ganze Datenbank rein?
Da müsste man jetzt, glaube ich, mal Moritz fragen. Also wir haben ein paar
Schrauben, an die man da im Backend noch drehen kann, die uns die zweite Firma
bereitstellt, aber nicht so rasend viel.
Sondern im Wesentlichen ist die Arbeit jetzt, Schrauben an dem Prompt auf der
einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite nochmal überlegen, ob wir vielleicht unseren
Datenabzug doch nochmal anders bauen, als wir das jetzt gemacht haben.
Mit noch ein bisschen mehr Informationen von irgendwo angereichert.
Das sind die beiden Stellschrauben. Und auch gerade dieses an dem Prompt Pfeilen,
Das ist schon auch ein hartes Brot, weil du halt, wir haben halt so ein Standard-Set
von 20 Standard-Fragen,
so verschiedener Komplexität, so relativ einfache Sachen wie empfehlen wir irgendwas
zu Urban Gardening oder so, da kommen also immer gute Sachen bei rum, egal was man macht.
andere Geschichten, wie ich es ja gerade eben gesagt habe, sind auch schon ein
bisschen komplizierter und bei jeder Änderung, die man halt jetzt hier in dem
Prompt macht, also in dem Priming, muss man halt gucken, okay,
welche Auswirkung hat das?
Habe ich vielleicht das eigentliche Problem gelöst, was ich gerade lösen wollte,
habe dadurch aber vielleicht woanders wieder was schlechter gemacht?
Das ist also schon eine Sache, wo man sich wirklich nur so auf dem Boden robbend vorwärts bewegen kann,
aber darum dachten wir eben auch, sei es einigermaßen eine clevere Idee,
dass auch gerade halt in dem GIT zu versionieren, dass man auch nachvollziehen
kann, okay, was ist die aktuelle Version, welche Iterationsschritte hat das
genommen, dass andere Bibliotheken oder,
vergleichbare Institutionen davon ein bisschen lernen können und einen Eindruck
bekommen, welche Auswirkungen oder welche Änderungen, welche Art von Auswirkungen.
Der letzte Commit war vor vier Stunden.
Habt ihr so eine Art Test-Suite, mit der ihr dann testet, dass ihr da auch keine
Regressionen reinbaut?
Genau. Aber die ist natürlich auch endlich. Es ist jetzt keine Automatisierung,
kein automatisiertes Testing,
wo wir dann also sagen würden, das ist aber auch schwierig umzusetzen,
weil es ist eben nicht deterministisch, sondern es ist am Ende halt dann LLM,
was auch jedes Mal wieder ein bisschen anders reagiert aufgrund von Hotness.
ist, das heißt also du kannst auch richtig oder falsch, ist auch schwer bei
einer Antwort dann so automatisiert festzulegen.
Die nächste LLM dahinter hängt, die dann prüft.
Ja, also am ehesten halt noch der Link in den eigentlichen Katalog,
ob der richtig ist oder falsch, das könnte man schon relativ gut in dem Testverfahren
absetzen, aber da sind wir im Moment noch nicht.
Wie gesagt, das Ganze ist Alpha, ist jetzt so seit drei Wochen ungefähr online,
ich habe es auf Mastodon auch schon mal ein bisschen verbreitet,
so dieses erste Feedback war ganz gut, wenn man halt immer im Hinterkopf hat,
was für ein Problem das lösen soll.
Und das ist eben Barrieren abbauen, Leuten helfen, die halt nicht irgendwie
ständig von vielen schlauen Leuten umgeben sind.
Also für Kinder ist das glaube ich auch ein ganz guter Zugang.
Und dass die ganze Grundseite drumherum, die Feb-Seite, dass die so einige technische
Issues hat, das wissen wir selber am allerbesten. Da arbeiten wir auch dran,
dass das in nächster Zeit nochmal besser und moderner wird.
Also man hat da Sessions, die ablaufen, obwohl man überhaupt nirgendwo eingeloggt
ist und so. Das hat so ein paar Sonderlichkeiten, die bitte ignorieren bis auf
Weiteres. Das wird auch noch besser.
Ja, aber hier in Berlin weltweit zum ersten Mal. Hurra.
Es findet jetzt ein Webinar statt von der Firma Heute1 und Übermorgen1,
wo sich insgesamt, ich glaube, zusammen über 350 Bibliotheken und Institutionen
angemeldet haben weltweit, um zu erfahren, wie wir das gemacht haben.
Aber wäre das nicht sinnvoll, an dem Punkt dann zu sagen, wir stellen diesem
Tool tatsächlich die Datenbank zur Verfügung und erklären ihm in dem Prompt,
wie es selber eine Suche durchführt?
Dann hast du aber eben diese ganzen Mapping-Probleme wie ich möchte etwas über Haustiere lernen,
So, wie übersetzt du diesen Prompt jetzt in die Logik, okay,
Haustiere sind eben im Wesentlichen Katzen Hunde, Vögel Wie würden das Bibliothekare machen?
Die würden hoffen, dass in den entsprechenden Werken,
das Zusatz-Tag Haustier vergeben Das würde ich aber sagen, ist schon sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Das heißt also, wenn du ein Standardwerk hast, dein Hund, der beste Freund des
Menschen, wäre ich mir nicht sicher, ob dort irgendwo in den Metadaten ein Haustier auftaucht.
Und wenn du dann nach Haustier suchst, findest du dieses Werk nicht,
obwohl es total einschlägig gewesen wäre.
Und mit der Suche in diesem Vektorraum ist es kein Problem, das zu finden,
weil dort eben das Wissen in Anführungszeichen verdrahtet ist.
Das ist ein Haustier. Gib dir mal zurück den Treffer.
Also was ich mal gebaut habe ist, ich habe mit, habe ich das letzte Mal hiervon
schon erzählt, von meiner Scannerlösung Paperless?
Nee, ich glaube davon hast du noch gar nicht berichtet, das könnten wir allerdings
auch nochmal einschmeißen.
Genau, es gibt so ein Paperless.
Sind wir jetzt durch mit ihm?
Das passt da fast rein, würde ich sagen.
Aber sind wir jetzt...
Also ich war durch soweit.
Das ist ja jetzt ein neues...
Tested, ja ja, Feedback.
Habt Spaß. Weiß ja, Kapitel machen wir uns.
Also ich habe irgendwann mal meinen Scan, meinen Snapscan, den ich mir irgendwann
hier mal in einer Freakshow damals...
Scansnap?
Scansnap oder ein Mobile Max damals noch, habe aufschwatzen lassen.
Snapscan?
Ich habe den heißt Zuhause stehen.
Scansnap?
Ich weiß nicht, wie er heißt, ich nutze ihn nur.
Das müsst ihr sehen. Tim sitzt neben dem Gerät und googelt jetzt den Namen,
statt auf das Gerät zu gucken, wo er drauf steht.
Auf dem Gerät steht nichts drauf, weil ich das alles überklebt habe.
Ah, nee, hier steht es. Scan-Snap.
Auf der einen Seite grandioses Gerät, auf der anderen Seite furchtbares Gerät.
Egal. Ich habe den irgendwann mal so umgebaut.
Eine Zeit lang dann habe ich einfach alles in eine Dropbox reingescannet und
das ist dann irgendwann mal ausgeartet und hat nicht mehr funktioniert und das
OCR von diesem Ding ist ganz furchtbar und aber es scannt halt,
also es ist halt so ein Ding, man, so ein, so ein,
wie ein Drucker rückwärts, sage ich jetzt mal.
Also nicht so ein Flachbett-Scanner, wo man ein Dokument nach dem anderen drauflegen muss,
sondern man kann einfach so ein Stapel Sachen reinlegen und wann immer irgendein
Brief kommt von irgendeinem Amt oder irgendwem, was irgendwie halbwegs wichtig erscheint,
dann schmeiße ich das Ding da rein und scanne das einmal und dann ist es halt
weg und dann bleibt es da auch drin liegen in dem Stapel und dann wird irgendwann
mal der Stapel, wenn er wieder voll ist, wird in irgendeine Kiste gepackt und
dann nie wieder aufgepasst.
Und das habe ich mit einer Software verbunden, die heißt Paperless NX.
Das ist eine Weiterentwicklung von Paperless und das ist so ein Webinterface
für PDF-Dokumente und relativ nett und da habe ich mir irgendwann dann mal in Python...
NGX.
NGX, genau, danke. Ähm,
Und da habe ich das erste Mal mit LLMs ein bisschen Erfahrung gesammelt,
nämlich ich schmeiße da einfach mal den Inhalt von dem Dokument mit rein und
schicke das an OpenAI und sage dem,
hey, mach mir mal einen Titel für das Dokument und hier folgende Tags habe ich definiert,
sag mal, welche Tags darauf jetzt passen.
und seitdem läuft das und es hat mich am Anfang sehr viel Geld gekostet,
weil ich hab irgendwann mal 30 Dollar verbraten, also so viel Geld jetzt auch
nicht, aber für irgendwie 20 Scans,
nee, ein paar 100 Scans waren für ein paar 100 Scans 20 Dollar,
weil ich das gesamte Dokument mit reingeschmissen habe und teilweise waren da
eben auch PDFs von irgendwelchen mehrseitigen Artikeln drin,
das hat dann richtig viel gekostet.
Irgendwann hatte ich dann nur die ersten 3000 Zeichen oder sowas von dem Dokument,
weil eigentlich steht da immer
alles drin schon und seitdem schmeiße ich das mit rein und das läuft.
Und das ist halt so ein Chat-GPT, so ein Open AI-API, die halt sagt,
ja, jetzt schlag mir mal einen Titel vor, extrahiere das Datum,
ist die zweite Funktion. Also, dass wenn irgendwo das Datum in dem Dokument
erwähnt wird, dass es das Datum dann von dem Brief direkt mit rausholt.
Stimmt erstaunlich oft, stimmt auch nicht immer.
Wenn man noch ein bisschen Tipps mitgibt, so, hey, wahrscheinlich ist das Dokument
nicht 1978 mein Geburtsjahr entstanden, sondern deutlich in den 2010ern oder
sowas oder später, dann geht das auch alles ganz gut.
Ich habe das ein bisschen zurechtgepromptet und das läuft eigentlich ganz gut.
Und was ich aber, wenn ich es jetzt machen würde, würde ich das wahrscheinlich,
es gibt so ein Framework namens Langchain heißt das, also Language Chain, Langchain.
Das gibt es für Python, das gibt es für TypeScript. Das ist so eine Abstraktion
für alle gängigen LLM APIs.
Also das funktioniert mit OpenAI, das funktioniert mit Ulama,
das funktioniert mit mit Together AI, mit GROK, mit allem.
Und was die drinnen haben, ist eine Function Call API. Das heißt, dass man...
Anstatt dass man eine Antwort kriegt, übergibt man dem Language Model ein JSON-Schema
und sagt, hier, das ist das, was du zu befüllen hast.
Man muss die Temperatur auf 0 untersetzen, ansonsten denkt sich JSON aus.
und baue das mal hier an den entsprechenden Stellen ein und dann kriegst du
JSON zurück und dann macht dieses Langchain wohl offensichtlich nicht viel mehr,
als das tatsächlich zu parsen und dir dann einfach zu übergeben.
Das heißt, dass man von dieser LLM dann strukturierte Daten in einer Form zurückbekommt,
mit der man was anfangen kann.
Und damit habe ich spaßeshalber mal ein Tool gebaut, was mir meine.
Blu-Ray-Backup-Sammlung sortiert nach TV-Show oder TV-Show, Also Movie oder TV-Show.
Und so, jetzt krieg mal raus, ob das eine TV-Show ist oder ob das keine TV-Show ist.
TV-Shows haben es überall, üblicherweise Seasons und Episode-Numbers drin.
Was für Daten hast du da reingeschmissen?
Dateinamen.
Nur den Dateinamen der Blu-Ray?
Den Pfad, den Pfad der Datei, die ich auf meiner Platte liegen habe.
Und daraus krieg jetzt mal raus, krieg jetzt mal raus, ist das eine TV-Show oder ist das ein Film?
Und aus welchem Jahr stammt das denn?
Das reicht schon, ja.
Und das funktioniert in 100% aller Fälle, nach dem, was ich bisher gesehen habe.
Ich finde, du bist schon...
Das könnte man mit einem Rackaxe auch machen wahrscheinlich, aber...
Muss ich ehrlich sagen. Aber du hast mir das ja mal zwischenzeitlich gezeigt
und ich war ehrlich gesagt ziemlich beeindruckt von den Ergebnissen,
was jetzt allein dieses Dokument... weil das ist ja eigentlich der totale Lifesaver.
Total. Wie viele Leute haben einfach so...
Ein Stapel von Briefen und Zetteln und Kram und würden das ganz gerne irgendwie
durchsuchbar machen, um da noch halbwegs einen Überblick zu bekommen. Das ist der Grund.
Warum ich da habe.
Ja genau, aber da bist du ja nicht alleine auf diesem Planeten.
Haben aber dann das Problem,
dass eben dieses reine Scannen und auch OCRen an sich erstmal nicht viel bringt,
weil du dann halt eine Festplatte voll hast mit irgendwie Datum,
Uhrzeit, PDF und dann musst du dir jeden Scheiß irgendwie anschauen und weißt
halt hinten und vorne nicht, was Sache ist.
Und du hast mir ein Beispiel gezeigt, das fand ich so total überzeugend.
Da war dann halt so ein PDF und als Titel oder Beschreibung,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo das aufgetaucht ist,
war dann so Bestätigungsbrief für Tarnliste oder PIN für irgendeine neue Kreditkarte.
Also so ein typischer Brief, den man von der Sparkasse kriegt.
Bestätigung, dass ein Konto eröffnet worden ist.
Oder sowas.
Bei der Stadtsparkasse Wasserburg.
Also diese klassischen Briefe, von denen man immer nicht weiß,
ist das jetzt irgendwie für irgendwas wichtig oder nicht, aber dann diese eine
Zeile sagt einem sofort, ob man es noch braucht oder nicht.
Und das ist wirklich grandios und mal wieder so eine Anwendung,
wo ich sagen muss, da haben LLMs ihre totale Berechtigung.
Das funktioniert super. Ich habe viele US-Dokumente, als wir in den USA gelebt
haben und als ich in Deutschland,
das ist ein super Deskriptions, also das ist halt, man braucht nie beides oder
so gut wie nie beides und es existieren halt auf beiden Kontexten viele Dokumente
in irgendeiner Form und das kriegt es halt auch,
Praktisch hundertprozentiger Sicherheit hin. So diese Unterscheidung,
ist das US, ist das Deutsch und sowas. Das funktioniert erstaunlich gut.
Und ich bin so gespannt, ob Apple da vielleicht...
Ob die das auch irgendwann mal einbauen.
Ob die vielleicht sowas auch nochmal einbauen. Oder zumindest jetzt einfacher.
Ein bisschen Intelligenz entwickeln und mal auf die Dateien mal schauen,
die da auf dem Computer liegen.
Und mal schauen, was ist da eigentlich drin, was ist das eigentlich.
Machen die nie.
Meinst du?
Das funktioniert dann aber nur für US-Dokumente.
Genau.
Und fünf Jahre später vielleicht auch so halb für Deutsche.
Trotzdem, ich will jetzt einen Orden für diese Überleitung.
Ah, fantastisch.
Denn wir müssen ja jetzt auch mal nach zwei Stunden, nee, anderthalb Stunden,
müssen wir ja auch langsam mal auf das heiße Thema kommen, was alle bewegt.
Und das machen wir jetzt.
Also, es begab sich in gestrigem Zeit, weiß nicht, kann man sagen,
in Copertino, im Internet.
Im Internet begab es sich, dass die Worldwide Developers Conference von Apple
2024 eröffnet wurde und dies geschieht ja traditionell mit der sogenannten Keynote,
was ja früher mal eine lustige Veranstaltung
war und jetzt mehr so eine Druckbetankung von Informationen ist.
Wobei ich mich halt auch frage, also wenn ihr so viel zu erzählen habt und jetzt
nicht mehr auf der Bühne stehen musst und ihr nehmt das alles vorher auf,
dann macht es doch länger. Das ist nicht so.
Aber es war noch anderthalb Stunden oder so.
Zwei, knapp zwei Stunden. Oder zwei Stunden.
Stunde 40. Also noch länger hätte ich jetzt nicht unbedingt gewollt und meine Blase auch nicht.
Naja, man kann ja auch Pause drücken. Pause drücken, genau.
Ja, aber dann ist ja nicht mehr live.
Ja, du hast recht.
Ja, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall. Ich bin dann doch ein bisschen überrollt von dieser Dichte.
Sie tun immer so, sie hätten keine Zeit, als müssten sie jetzt aufs Klo,
aber dabei ist das ja alles vorher aufgenommen.
Wer weiß, wer weiß.
Also die sportlichen Einlagen waren schon sehr gut bis unglaubwürdig.
Ich habe mich gefragt, wer hat jetzt in seinem Lebenslauf stehen,
den Stunt-Trainer für Apple-WWDC-Keynote.
Das war doch alles.
Also das Fahrrad fand ich sehr geil. Das war wirklich so übertrieben,
dass es halt überhaupt nicht mehr glaubwürdig war.
Die lassen nicht ihren gesamten Vorstand aus dem Flugzeug rausspringen.
Das lässt die Versicherung nicht zu.
Ja, das ist auch klar, aber...
Das waren alles Special Effects. Okay, gut.
Also wir wollen ja jetzt nicht die ganze Keynote erzählen. Ihr werdet das sowieso alle gesehen haben.
Also wollen wir schon, aber wir verhörten.
Ja, weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt so das Wichtigste ist. Wir können es natürlich
gerne noch zu diesem Einstiegsclip äußern. Ich fand ihn unterhaltsam. Der war irgendwie kurz.
Ich fand ihn auch unterhaltsam.
Sehr lustig. Wir haben ja hier eingangs auch schon das schöne Liedchen,
den Song A Day von Jonathan Mann gehört, der das dann gleich umgesetzt hat.
Der hat auch dieses Lied damals über das iPhone 4 gemacht.
Ja, ja, genau.
Hat er. Er ist ja auch so ein Fanboy.
er hat dann diesen kurzen Satz,
den Phil Schiller, der halt vorne dieses Flugzeug aus dem dann rausgeht.
Genau, der da so saß und dann mit seinem Ur-iPod, mit seinem initial erste Generation-iPod
irgendwie die Musik macht, was ich großartig fand.
Und dann halt dieser Spruch I'm too old for this.
Ja, genau. So fing das irgendwie an und dann sind sie alle über Diese Nostalgie.
Langsam wird es zu viel.
Welche Nostalgie?
Na ja, erstens der alte iPod, die alten klassischen Streifen.
Ich habe dann noch bei der State of the Union war noch sowas,
wo sie den Chatbot anschmeißen.
Die alten klassischen Streifen. Die Streifen sind doch in Apple Park in der Mitte.
Ja, aber in Produkten und so sind die schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren.
Sind irgendwann mal wieder aufgetaucht. Irgendwann kamen sie mal wieder hoch.
Wenn sie dieses Flugzeug tatsächlich verkaufen, darfst du dich beschweren. Vorher nicht.
Ich find's ein bisschen arg.
Das ist schon so ein Element, was...
Sag mal logisch. Du beklagst dich, es wird schon zu viel und im selben Atemzug
sagst du, sie benutzen es nirgendwo.
Sie haben es jahrelang nicht an Produkten genommen, aber sie nehmen es halt
immer wieder in ihren Videos um.
Guck mal, damals als Apple noch cute war und wir noch kein, nicht die größte Firma der Welt.
Ich weiß nicht, dieser Regenbogen, der ist ja immer noch da.
Der ist super, aber der ist, der war zwar schon durch meine Welt.
Also ich fand, ich fand Phil Schiller da eigentlich auch in seiner Rolle sehr gut.
Perfekt, ja, ja, also grandios.
Und der,
Der Helm von Craig, Herr Force One, der hat die Veranstaltung schon gerockt.
Ich dachte so, oh, wird der der nächste CEO?
Der wird der nächste CEO.
Ja, ja.
Der war sehr viel auf der Bühne auf jeden Fall mal.
Und dann auch seine Parcoureinlage, die fand ich auch schon sehr heftig, von iOS zu macOS. ist.
Also ich muss sagen, Craig Federini, wenn man bedenkt, ich glaube,
das war sein erster Auftritt, da war der so nervös, dass seine Hand so gezittert
hat, dass er das Trackpad nicht bedienen konnte.
Ein legendärer Auftritt. Und wie der auch seine Live- Auftritte,
der war ja schon auch noch, jetzt würde man sagen, okay, jetzt filmen sie es
einfach und machen dann 5000 Takes, bis es irgendwann mal halbwegs funktioniert.
Aber der hat ja auch schon vorher solche Live-Shows performt.
Er ist super fotogen, aber CEO wird er nicht.
Eins nicht. Vielleicht nicht. Keine Ahnung, das weiß ich.
Er ist der Software-Guy und er ist natürlich auch mittlerweile der offizielle Super-Casper.
Und die Rolle ist ja toll, zusammen mit Phil Schiller.
Also es ist ja gut, dass sie solche Leute haben, die einfach über ihre eigentliche
Rolle hinaus noch eine Rolle spielen.
Man nimmt ihn ja fast gar nicht wahr als den Chef der Software-Abteilung,
sondern er ist halt auch irgendwie so ein bisschen der Super-Clown.
Und das ist gut. Aber ich glaube, der, wie heißt er, Williams,
der wird der Nachfolger von dem Tim Cook werden, denke ich mal. Der halt jetzt CEO ist.
Der Williams?
Ja, Jeff Williams heißt er, glaube ich. Nee, den kennt man halt nicht so richtig,
genauso wie man auch Tim Cook vorher nicht kannte.
Die Diskussion gleitet jetzt etwas ab, weil ich glaube, es ist auch nicht so
spannend, wer jetzt als nächstes... Ach, der.
Doch, das ist sehr spannend. Ich finde, das sollte...
Jeff Williams, genau. Genau, Chief Operating Officer, der tritt halt selten.
Also ist natürlich die Frage, was sie meinen, was so die nächste Generation ist.
Aber Tim Cook hat ja schon angedeutet, dass er in zehn Jahren hier nicht mehr
steht. Und das war, glaube ich, schon ein Jahr her.
Wir werden es sehen.
Der Gunter und läuft.
Joss Wihack wäre wahrscheinlich auch noch eine Option.
Weiß ich aber nicht, inwiefern der wirklich auch Bock hat auf so eine Rolle. Ja.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so ein Thema, was man zwischendurch mal eben zwischen
zwei Schnitten verarbeiten kann in so einem Podcast.
Nein, nein. Egal. Wollen wir auch nicht weiter drauf eingehen.
Also Keynote fing irgendwie an und die ganzen Protagonisten,
die halt dann später auch so die Hauptrollen in dieser Keynote spielen,
springen aus diesem Flugzeug und mit schönen Regenbogen-Fallschirmchen,
springen sie irgendwie in den Apple Park rein und dann steht Tim Cook oben auf
dem Dach und sagt in seiner unwiderstehlichen, attraktiven Art Hallo und dann
geht's los. So, aber wir...
Er sagt zu laut Hallo. Hallo! Ich bin im Tipp, guck, redet immer zu laut.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, warum.
Die halbe Keynote war zu laut, aber das habe ich ja schon beklagt.
Anyway. So, wir haben uns, glaube ich, darauf geeinigt, das Feld von hinten aufzurollen.
Weil ihr wisst ja sowieso schon alle, was kommt. Es wurden dann tausend Features
runtergebetet und wir werden auch noch mal darauf eingehen.
Aber ich denke, der wesentliche Teil ist halt der, den sie nach hinten gestellt
haben, als sie eben mit ihrem großen Brimborium die Apple Intelligence vorgestellt haben.
Da habe ich so lautlos gelacht.
Da müssen wir erst mal über den Begriff. Hast du das Gerücht vorher nicht gehört?
Nee.
Ah ja, okay. Und was war dann so dein erster Gedanke dann?
Die wollen mich verarschen.
Wieso?
Weil, also ich meine, einerseits ist es natürlich cool, dass AI zur Apple Intelligence
wird, das haben sie schon gut eingefädelt.
Andererseits, seriously, naja.
Also sie haben bis dahin ja das Wort AI, also den Begriff in der Keynote, nicht verwendet.
Es kam zwei, an zwei Stellen war von Machine Learning die Rede, wie früher.
Aber von AI kein Funken, nichts.
Dann kam halt Tim Cook und hat gesagt, so jetzt, aber hier habt ihr ja alles
schon mal gehört, hört hier AI und wir haben jetzt auch was dazu zu sagen und
we call it Apple Intelligence.
Und ich finde diesen Move eigentlich ziemlich geil, weil wenn du dir die ganzen
Keynotes von allen anderen anhörst, so AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, es kommt die ganze Zeit.
Ja, auch wenn man sich die iPad, die letzte iPad Keynote anhört.
War auch relativ viel.
Nicht relativ, das war auch viel.
Das stimmt. Das hat mich auch überrascht, dass sie das gemacht haben.
Aber wie auch immer, sie haben sich jetzt entschlossen, das so zu machen.
Und ich finde den Move in zweierlei Hinsicht ganz interessant.
Also erstens, dass sie halt dieses Artificial einfach aus dem Raum nehmen,
ohne dass man sich groß drüber beklagen kann, weil es ist klar,
okay, Apple setzt dem Ganzen jetzt hier einfach den eigenen Hut auf und das
Wort Intelligenz ist ja, also das Wort Intelligence ist ja im Englischen,
hat ja eine andere Tönung als wir, was wir jetzt unter Intelligenz verstehen.
Wir assoziieren das halt immer mit dieser Fähigkeit des Gehirns kluge Sachen
zu machen und Intelligence ist ja,
Im Englischen mehr ein Begriff, der halt so das Sammeln von Informationen,
das Zusammentragen von Informationen bezeichnet.
Deswegen gibt es ja auch die CIA, die Central Intelligence Agency,
weil die sich halt um Intelligence kümmert, also um das Zusammentragen von Informationen
und nicht, weil die so superintelligent sind.
Ich fand, diese Assoziation ist dadurch gleich viel stärker geworden,
durch dieses Apple Intelligence.
Ja. Und das fand ich nicht gut.
Welche?
Naja, halt zur CIA.
Ja gut, aber das ist jetzt unser Problem. Das ist im Englischen,
das ist halt ein Wort wie jedes andere.
Vielleicht wird es auch Apples Problem, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Nennen es halt Apfel-Nachrichtendienst.
Naja, aber am Ende muss ich sagen, das ist eigentlich auch genau das, was sie gezeigt haben.
Also sie haben wirklich diesen Begriff Intelligence als solchen in den Vordergrund
gestellt. Was haben sie jetzt getan?
Ich würde jetzt mal unterstellen, dass das eben auch so Framework-Charakter
hat, auch wenn es jetzt nicht unbedingt ein einzelnes technisches Framework
ist, was sie dem Betriebssystem hinzugefügt haben.
Aber sie stellen jetzt all die Funktionen, die schon immer da waren und die
quasi AI-Technologien, also Machine Learning benutzt haben,
jetzt unter diese Überschrift und fügen dem dann eben noch weitere Dinge zu,
indem sie halt es noch mehr und intensiver ins Betriebssystem einbauen.
Also eigentlich ist auch dieser Schritt gar nicht so revolutionär,
sondern eher evolutionär, weil vieles davon haben sie schon gemacht.
Machine Learning ist nichts prinzipiell Neues.
Teilweise, manche Funktionen gibt es sogar schon länger, als es Machine Learning gibt.
Also so Text Summary ist irgendwie ein macOS Feature von vor 20 Jahren. Ernsthaft?
Ja, wobei, also der Kern der ganzen, also ich stelle mir das,
wir haben noch nicht wirklich viele Details, aber das, was sie vorgestellt haben,
ist eigentlich so ein Drei-Layer-Modell.
Du hast einen Kern von einem Large-Language-Model, der lokal auf der Maschine
läuft und der überhaupt nicht nach Hause irgendwie telefoniert,
sondern sich selbst genug ist.
Der ist wahrscheinlich ziemlich hoch komprimiert und ziemlich runter reduziert.
Da gibt es ja auch durchaus Paper von Apple zu, die man in den letzten Monaten
schon finden konnte, was sie da wie mit Quantisierung und so weiter alles anstellen.
Das hat sich ein bisschen abgezeichnet. Das heißt also, das ist ein Modell,
was relativ wenig Weltwissen wahrscheinlich hat, aber dafür hinreichend gut
mit Sprache an sich erstmal.
Sie haben mehr als ein Modell. Sie haben Modelle für Textzusammenfassung,
Sie haben Modelle für, nicht nur das, auch für E-Mail-Replies generieren.
Also irgendwo haben sie eine Liste mit den ganzen Modellen, die sie haben und
das ist extrem kleinteilig.
Audio-Transkription.
Nein, auch für eine Funktion, also für Push-Notification-Zusammenfassung.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es dafür ein eigenes Modell gibt, aber es würde mit
reinpassen in die Liste der Modelle, die sie da gezeigt haben.
Für mich die Frage wäre, sind das dann wirklich,
eigenständige Modelle, auch im Sinne von mit eigenen Installationen und eigener Datenhaltung?
Oder ist das letztendlich ein LLM, was mit unterschiedlichem Priming halt entsprechend
einfach nur angegangen wird?
Ich glaube, das sind alles separate Modelle.
Ich glaube auch eher das. Weil du musst es auf einem iPhone zum Laufen bringen.
Aber du brauchst ja jedes Mal quasi wieder die Grundsprachintelligenz.
Es gab die ja auch schon vorher. Also das ist ja, das hatten wir auch schon
im letzten und im vorletzten OS, waren die alle schon drin.
Fotos, Inhalterkennen ist ein Feature, hat, das gibt es jetzt schon seit zwei oder drei Jahren.
Also da ist jetzt das LLM gar nicht der entscheidende Faktor.
Das MLLM-Ding, was sie ja jetzt überhaupt erst im Paper Anfang dieses Jahres
veröffentlicht haben, das ist sozusagen neu und das ist meiner Auffassung nach
vor allem eben für die wirklich auch neuen Funktionen die Basis, also für die Bilder,
Zusammenbau, ist jetzt auch ein bisschen gedeutet, ich weiß es jetzt natürlich nicht, aber,
das neue Siri-Interface, also dass man sich vermutlich, nehme ich jetzt mal
an, wenn wir es in den nächsten Tagen erst erfahren, aber dass man jetzt sich
mit Siri mal ordentlich unterhalten kann,
dass sie jetzt die Old Siri aus dem Fenster geschmissen haben,
das ist sicherlich ein Ergebnis,
dieses LLMs, was sie am Start haben, aber wie Max schon sagt,
sie haben sehr viele Machine Learning Systeme, sie haben sehr viele Modelle,
die eben hochgradig spezifisch sind und von daher halt auch schnell ausgeführt werden, die nicht immer,
ein Riesenmodell braucht und.
Die vor allen Dingen auch wenig RAM und wenig, also nicht so viel Ressourcen brauchen sollten.
Ja.
Und, also das ist ja so ein...
Dank Tim Cook haben ja alle Apple-Devices extrem wenig Arbeitsspeicher,
weil Arbeitsspeicher kostet ja Geld und jetzt braucht man plötzlich wahnsinnig
viel Arbeitsspeicher und das ist ja bei so einem LLM wahrscheinlich im Augenblick
das größte Problem auf so einem iPhone oder auch auf einem MacBook,
da den entsprechenden Speicherrand zu schaffen.
Und ich glaube, darum haben sie diese extrem optimierten Modelle,
die genau einen Task können, was natürlich dann auch die Gefahr reduziert,
dass sie irgendwelche Scheiße bauen.
Sie können halt nur den einen Task.
Genau, sie können nur den einen Task.
Und das mit dem gröber Quantisieren, also Ihre komischen 4-Bit-Parameter-Werte,
das hatten Sie in dem Plattform-State-of-the-Union nochmal betont,
dass Sie da irgendwie die Modelle sehr stark datenreduziert haben.
Wobei das auch keine Apple-Kunst ist. Das ist einfach State-of-the-Art. Das machen sie alle.
Dieses Quantisieren von Modellen, das fand ich auch ehrlich gesagt ziemlich unehrlich.
Und mein Eindruck war an einigen Stellen, dass Apple sich da mit Dingen schmückt,
die gar nicht ihre sind. Da haben sie so irgendwie Sonoma, dieses Modell,
wie schnell ist das und wie viel RAM braucht es?
Gegenübergestellt jetzt mit Sequoia. Und ja, Moment mal, ihr habt das Modell
ausgewechselt und das ist jetzt ein quantisiertes 4-Bit-Modell und das kann ich auch auf Sonoma.
Vielleicht habt ihr nochmal ein bisschen was optimiert, will ich euch nicht
unterstellen, aber das war ein Äppel-und-Birn-Vergleich.
Das gibt es aber nicht dazu. zu?
Ja, also ich meine, gut, das ist ja immer schon klar gewesen,
dass sie das dann halt als jetzt den Fortschritt der im Wesentlichen sich zeitlich
an diesem Betriebssystem Wechsel festmacht, weil.
Um es mal klar zu machen, wo der große Vorteil ist, die Integration des gesamten
Betriebssystems und der Apps und aller Funktionalitäten, die das iOS.
MacOS und iPadOS, das sind ja sozusagen die einzigen Plattformen,
die das jetzt bekommen, diese Apple Intelligence, das ist der eigentliche Vorteil.
Und dass sie ja eben diese ganzen AI-Funktionen in das System reinschieben und
ihm auch Zugriff auf diese ganzen lokalen Daten geben,
ohne dass es halt gleich eine Privatsphären-Hölle wird.
Das ist ihr großer Vorteil, also neben der Tatsache, dass sie eben die einzigen
sind, die so eine riesige Installed Base haben mit so vielen Neural Engines,
die halt da draußen sind,
also sehr viele Telefone da draußen,
sehr viele iPads, sehr viele Macs, können einfach jetzt auch schon komplexere
Modelle lokal auf der Maschine machen und das, was sie nicht lokal auf der Maschine machen,
weil entweder das Modell zu kompliziert ist oder die Maschine zu langsam ist
oder beides, Dann haben sie zusätzlich noch diese Secure Cloud Compute,
die sie da beschrieben haben,
rausgeworfen, was halt im Wesentlichen Apples eigene Serverfarmen sind mit speziell
für diesen Zweck hergestellter Hardware,
wo die Maschinen halt schon bei der Herstellung zusigniert werden und sozusagen modifikationssicher.
Weiß man das schon? Haben sie so beschrieben. Also sie bauen die Maschinen und
quasi schon direkt aus dem Fertigungsmoment heraus sind die quasi tamperproof.
Also das ist jetzt ihre Aussage. Und außerdem, wenn sie dann betrieben werden,
werden sie halt nur mit signierter Software und mit Secure Enclave und Verschlüsselung
und so weiter nur mit Software bespielt, die dafür auch abgesegnet ist.
und vor allem haben diese Maschinen keinen persistenten Speicher.
Das heißt, da ist keine Festplatte drin,
Die haben quasi nur RAM und wenn dann eben so eine AI-Nachfrage in das... Zu teuer.
Nein, es geht ja darum, dass es keine Spuren hinterlässt.
Und wenn du halt keinen persistenten Speicher haben, dann kannst du halt auch
keine Spuren hinterlassen, wenn es das nicht selber nach außen spuckt,
sozusagen an andere Systeme.
Was ich nicht ganz verstanden habe, war diese Ansage, dass die Software irgendwie
von Third Party geprüft und überhaupt offen und alles ist und dass man da gucken
könnte, ob das alles so seine Wichtigkeit hat.
Ja, sie haben wohl ausgewählte Teile als Source-Code oder als Beschreibung, wie es funktioniert.
Also es ist nicht komplett alles Open Source, sondern sie lassen halt eine Analyse von Dritten zu.
Da muss man jetzt mal abwarten, was da jetzt am Ende wirklich dran ist,
aber sie gehen halt schon sehr weit. Also ich meine, sowas macht halt sonst niemand.
Also sie stellen das erstmal auf und sagen so, das ist unser Ansatz,
damit können wir es verantworten.
AI-Anfragen, die wir nicht auf dem Gerät abwickeln können, weil sie zu komplex sind,
in der Cloud zu machen, indem wir dann sicherstellen, dass wir ein Environment haben,
was eben weitgehend temper-proof ist, was irgendwie bei Design nichts wegspeichern
kann, weil einfach kein Festspeicher da ist und das soll diesen Vertrag,
den sie quasi mit dem Kunden schließen mit,
wir sind die Privatsphäre,
Marktführerschaft das dann eben auch sicherstellen soll. Das ist quasi der Deal.
Da muss ich sagen, an der Stelle ist bei mir extrem der Zynismus angesprungen.
Ich habe gesagt, das klingt mir alles sehr nach Marketing-Bullshit.
Und gerade so dieses, wir schreiben nichts auf Platte, ja, das macht keine von diesen LLM-APIs.
Also das per Default sind die alle komplett stateless. Du schickst hoch,
was du haben willst und dann kriegst du die Response und dann wird da eigentlich nichts gespeichert.
Das ist natürlich, da macht jetzt Apple mit versprochen und wirklich und ein Pinky obendrauf.
Aber so gerade dieses, wir speichern keine persönlichen Informationen bei uns.
Es sind halt sehr viel persönlichere Informationen, die sie da hochschicken.
Ja, ja, genau. Und wir speichern davon nichts.
Die ganzen Chat-Verlaufe werden bei ChatGPT schon gespeichert und zwar zentral.
Ja, aber wenn du die API von denen benutzt.
Dann nicht.
Dann nicht. Dann ist die komplett stateless. Das ist einfach nie...
Und bei ChatGPT, der Grund, warum die gespeichert werden, ist halt,
weil es ein Produkt ist, dessen Aufgabe darin auch besteht, mir meinen Chatverlauf anzuzeigen.
Und ansonsten gibt es auch keinen zwingenden Grund, das zu tun.
Da war ich so ein bisschen so, ich will nicht sagen, dass das per se nicht der
Fall ist und dass die sich da nicht eine gute Lösung ausgedacht haben,
aber ich habe an einigen Stellen das Gefühl gehabt, dass sie da,
da möchte ich erstmal unabhängige Audits sehen, ob das wirklich so gut ist oder
ob die jetzt einfach nur, die Leute haben Angst vor AI.
Sie hätten ja auch sagen können, uns war scheißegal, es sind unsere Server Trust
Us, aber sie sagen halt, wir legen quasi auf diesen Trust Us Level noch verschiedene
andere Faktoren mit drauf.
Aber einige von den, ich will nicht sagen, dass da nichts dran ist,
aber zumindest ein, zwei von den Argumenten waren, Moment mal,
das ist bei anderen auch nicht anders.
Ihr habt gerade sehr sophisticated im Marketing-Bullshit eine API beschrieben, die stateless ist.
Ja, aber die API ist ja das eine, die andere ist, wie sind diese Server abgesichert,
wie ist sichergestellt, dass da auch wirklich die Software draufläuft, von der gesagt wird.
Ich will die Audit sehen, bevor ich da Air Force One glaube.
Kannst du ja machen, aber ich meine, sie gehen in ihrer Ankündigung schon mal
weiter, als man es wahrscheinlich von ihnen jetzt erfordert hätte.
Also an der Stelle, hat jemand sich die Demo von Microsoft auf der Microsoft-Bild-Konferenz,
also ihre Co-Pilot-Plus-PCs angekündigt haben und dieses in Flammen aufgehende Desaster,
hat das jemand mitbekommen? Ja.
Okay, Microsoft hat vor wenigen Wochen ein großes Event gehabt.
Es wird hoffentlich mal spannend wieder.
Snapdragon-PCs, also Prozessoren, die schnell genug sind, um angeblich M3s das
Wasser reichen zu können oder sogar schneller zu sein, je nachdem,
wie man fragt und so weiter und so fort.
Ohne Kühlung, ja.
Scheuchen. Und all hell broke loose, jedenfalls in meinem kleinen Universum,
in dem innerhalb kürzester Zeit, ja okay, danke, Microsoft installiert mir Spyware auf meinem PC.
Und was ich auf der einen Seite, obwohl alles local on device,
on the edge, wie hier Sataya erster sagt,
wird das alles verarbeitet und sowas, aber es ist halt nicht hinreichend gesichert.
Es ist, du kannst es theoretisch, wenn du einmal auf dem System drauf bist,
kannst du auch remote einschalten. Es wird nicht als Malware erkannt.
Was ist mit den Fällen, wenn jemand in einer abusive relationship ist?
Hey, ich habe hier diese Software, die standardmäßig mitläuft und per Default
eingeschaltet ist, die alle Kreditkarteninformationen mitliest.
What could possibly go wrong? und da hat Apple schon deutlich,
deutlich, deutlich, deutlich besser abgeliefert, indem sie nicht nur einfach
dreimal Privacy gesagt haben wie Microsoft und gehofft haben,
dass es damit alles schon gut geht, sondern,
auch ja, halt,
eine Story erzählt haben, wie wichtig das ist.
Klar, weil es Ihnen ja auch...
Aber es kann trotzdem nur eine Story sein. Oh, I'm saying.
Ja gut, was heißt, es kann nur eine Story sein? Ich meine, erst mal haben,
Sie stellen ja was ganz anderes vor, als alle anderen bisher vorgestellt haben.
Diese ganzen Chat-GPT-Dinger und so weiter.
Ja, das sind halt super riesige Modelle, die eine ganze Menge können.
Das ist ja auch alles beeindruckend. Haben wir ja auch alle schon tausendmal
diskutiert und ausprobiert. Apple macht aber was anderes.
Apple führt diese Technik in das Betriebssystem ein und macht sie halt nützlich für den Kunden,
indem sie diese Systeme mit den sensibelsten Daten, die man hat, verbindet.
Das System nährt sich halt aus all meinen E-Mails, aus all meinen Dokumenten,
aus meinen Kontakten, aus meiner Kommunikation quasi Software dockt quasi an mein Innerstes an.
Ja, weil das ist das, was dieses Telefon oder auch das iPad und natürlich auch
mein Mac gespeichert hat und selbstverständlich ist das ein sensibles Problem.
Allerdings ist es halt auch der Gateway zu diesem Knowledge Navigator,
der ursprünglichen Apple-Idee.
Naja, das war ja im Prinzip genau das. Du redest mit deinem Computer und sie
haben ja auch viele Beispiele gesagt.
Wie lange brauche ich jetzt irgendwie, um da hinzufahren, wo man so einen Baseball spielt?
So, da musst du so viel Kontext schon am Start haben,
das kannst du eben nur durch diese enge Verzahnung haben und selbstverständlich
ist es dann angemessen, dass wenn man eben nicht garantieren kann,
dass das alles lokal läuft und
Server damit verbunden sind, dass man dann alles dafür tut, dass es eben.
Naja, safe enough ist. Ob du der Meinung bist, dass es safe enough ist,
das steht auf einem ganz anderen,
Blatt, aber sie haben zumindest dieses Problem schon mal erkannt und sie tun
eben jetzt in Software etwas und das finde ich bemerkenswert,
dass sie das alles verzahnen und das geht ja auch so weit, gerade wenn man das
mit diesem Recall-Feature vergleicht, Screenshots.
Ja, okay, Screenshots ist das eine, aber sie können halt über ihr OS richtig
in die Apps reinschauen.
Das könnte Microsoft auch. Also sollte man hoffen, dass sie das könnten.
Aber sie machen es nicht. Dieses Recall wirkt im Nachhinein wie ein erster Prototyp.
Also erschreckenderweise leider.
Es ist aber eben schon ein ganz interessanter Perspektivwechsel,
den Apple hier jetzt macht.
Weil so etwas wie ChatGPT hat halt ziemlich viel Weltwissen und null Wissen
über mich und meine Daten und was mich jetzt als Individuum ausmacht.
Das war auch nie der Use Case.
Aber das ist eben das, womit wir jetzt irgendwie AI die letzten zwei Jahre irgendwie
verbinden. Und Apple macht es halt jetzt genau 180 Grad umgedreht.
Hat wahrscheinlich nur übersichtlich viel Weltwissen, zumindest lokal.
Ansonsten muss es halt dann irgendwie dann doch auch raus in die Cloud,
aber hat dafür halt maximal viel Wissen über all das, was halt meine ganzen
Datenbestände halt vor Ort sind.
Die praktische Frage, die ich mir stelle, wir hatten ja gerade eben schon diese
zwei Layer, also On-Device auf der einen Seite und dann in dieser Secure Cloud
von Apple auf der anderen Seite.
Das On-Device ist ja relativ eingeschränkt, auf welchen Geräten das eigentlich laufen wird.
Also alle M-Prozessoren vom M1 an, aber bei den iPhones dann nur ab dem 15 Pro,
wo ich mich frage, wie passt das denn eigentlich zusammen?
Jenseits von, wir wollen halt mehr aktuelle iPhones nochmal verkaufen.
Weil doch, also, letzte vorletzte Sendung, dass doch die M-Prozessoren,
der M1 war abgeleitet von welchem iPhone aus, also in Bezug auf wie die Neural Engine ausgebaut war.
Aber die Größe der Neural Engine ist wahrscheinlich entscheidend,
wie viele Neural Engine Prozessoren sind da drin.
Und RAM.
Und wenn entsprechend zu wenig da sind, um das sinnvoll oder zumindest einer
für Apple vertretbaren Zeit zu rechnen, dann war es das halt.
RAM wird wichtig sein.
So, die Frage ist aber, wird dann auf den älteren Geräten dann einfach halt
das lokale Processing umgangen und dann aber mir zumindest die Option angeboten,
dieselben Features mit mehr Latenz, es dauert länger,
aber die dann eben komplett in der Cloud rechnen zu lassen?
Oder heißt das dann, nö, du hast jetzt zwar ein iPhone 14, herzlichen Glückwunsch,
aber 90% der Features, die in der gesamten Keynote vorgestellt werden,
werden bei mir nicht funktionieren?
Ich würde jetzt davon ausgehen, ohne einen Beleg zu haben, dass sie das Erste ist.
Also das war ja ein wesentlicher Teil dieser ganzen Keynote,
war ja zu sagen, wir haben da diese Intelligenz, also diesen Mechanismus,
der entscheidet, kann das on device gemacht werden oder kann das in der Cloud gemacht werden.
Und dieser Mechanismus wäre ja einfach Quatsch, wenn das einfach ein hartes
Set wäre und dann auf einem iPhone 15 nicht Pro die Aussage wäre,
nee, geht einfach nicht.
Aber sie haben es nicht adressiert.
Ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass sie auch selber sehr viele von diesen Sachen noch nicht wissen.
Vapor. Also das war sowieso, ich war verstört, wie häufig, also das war,
also eigentlich macht Apple ja wirklich selten so Vaporware-Ankündigungen.
Aber so jede zweite Formulierung so, irgendwann in diesem Jahr und etliche Dinge,
aber dann auch erst im nächsten Jahr,
das hat für mich so ein permanentes Störgefühl gemacht, so das ist man von der
Apple Keynote nicht gewohnt, sondern
heute Abend kann man das eigentlich normalerweise alles ausprobieren.
Also wenn Later This Year kommt, heißt das nicht zum Release im September.
Den Eindruck hatte ich auch, nicht zum Release.
Und also zum Release war ja, also ich habe auf diesem iPad habe ich iPadOS 18
drauf Und da sind, bis auf diesen Taschenrechner, diese Smalen-Funktion,
ist glaube ich nicht eine, also konnte ich nicht eine von diesen AI-Funktionen finden.
Same here, ich habe Sequoia auf meinem MacBook Pro drauf und da ist der Schlüsselbund
hier der neue, das Passwort. Ja, ist eine Beta-Version.
Aber das war auch nicht verbraucht.
Ja, aber normalerweise, also in den bisherigen, also eigentlich,
wenn auf einer DubDubDC irgendwas vorgestellt wird.
Ist aber nicht normal. Ist halt was Großes. Und es hat auch ein bisschen was
damit zu tun, dass unter Umständen ihre Serverfarm noch hochziehen und nicht
wissen, wann die Scheiße ist.
Die Scheiße ist einfach noch nicht fertig. Nichts davon ist fertig.
Natürlich ist sie nicht fertig.
Also nicht nur nicht fertig, sondern viele Sachen.
Ja, aber es wird fertig werden. Ich bin gespannt. Ja, dann lass es halt Winter
werden. Ist ja scheißegal. Es kommt halt irgendwann raus.
Wichtig ist ja, was soll es tun und wie kann es uns helfen.
Also Siri wurde nie fertig.
Dass sie später mal Features nachliefern, das hatten Und vor allen Dingen,
dass die erste Beta nicht läuft.
war auch immer normal.
Nee, das ist nicht richtig. Ich habe seit mindestens fünf OS-Versionen immer
die erste Developer-Beta drauf und die war immer zu 80% schon Feature-Complete
und lief so, dass ich im täglichen Einsatz damit praktisch nie Probleme hatte.
Das ist diesmal komplett anders.
Das kriegen die schon alles hin, alles was wir gesehen haben wird funktionieren. Ich hoffe das sehr.
Ich bin gespannt.
Ich sage aber nur, Sie haben es die letzten 15 Jahre bei Siri nicht hinbekommen.
Siri ist ein anderes Thema. Das brauchen wir nicht anzusprechen.
Aber dass erste Betas sehr rough waren, das ist eigentlich üblich gewesen.
Sie ist nicht rough. Es ist nicht. Es existiert.
Es ist nichts da.
Die neue Siri ist nicht so, dass die Animationen rough wären oder dass irgendwie
die Stimme nicht stimmt. Es ist einfach nicht vorhanden.
Ja und? Wo ist das Problem? Dann ist es halt nicht da und kommt es halt in der
nächsten Beta. Also das wird schon alles noch kommen.
Wir werden es sehen. Ja, wir werden es sehen.
Und dann kommt es halt in der übernächsten oder keine Ahnung,
dann kommt es halt in Version 18.2. Ist ja vollkommen egal, es kommt halt.
Finde ich jetzt auch jammern auf hohem Niveau, dass die erste Beta noch nicht perfekt ist.
Was heißt, nee, nee.
Nee, Moment mal, Moment mal, wir reden nicht über nicht perfekt,
sondern wir reden darüber, dass
gefühlt 90% der AI-Demos, die wir gesehen haben, komplett gefakt waren.
Okay, können wir trotzdem darüber reden, was sie eigentlich angekündigt haben
und was sozusagen kommen soll? Ja, naja, ich glaube... Doch, die waren gefakt.
Weil es ist nicht hier. Es ist nicht auf diesem Device drauf.
Ja, aber sie haben es ja auch nicht mit deinem Device gefilmt.
Sie haben es mit der Software, die auf dem Stand war von meinem Device.
Max, das wissen wir nicht. Sie können durchaus schon einen Teil ihrer Farm online
haben und da haben sie dann ihre Spezialgebiete schon.
Das könnten sie tun. Ja, wir wissen es nicht.
Du warst halt bei Facebook. Du kriegst das später. Ist doch klar.
Das war ein bisschen gemein, aber auch ein bisschen lustig. Okay.
Also, bisher hatten sie das nicht nötig.
Ich finde es nur ein bisschen überflüssig, uns darüber zu streiten,
dass irgendein Feature, wann es jetzt kommt oder nicht kommt oder so.
Ich meine, glaubst du ernsthaft, dass sie das jetzt alles angekündigt haben
und sie werden es nie liefern?
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie, also es ist die Frage, also bei AI-Features,
so, wenn ich mir Sora angucke, wenn ich mir sprechendes ChatGPT angucke,
wenn ich mir die ganzen Ankündigungen von Rabbit AI und,
wie heißt dieses PIN-Ding hier, was jetzt schon pleite ist.
Ich bin's inzwischen gewohnt, dass einfach 90% von dem, was mir versprochen wird, nicht zutrifft.
Und ich gehe davon aus, dass Apple eigentlich nur Dinge ankündigt,
die sie auch halten können.
Aber diese Beta lässt nichts, lässt.
Aber du weißt, dass die Veranstaltung Worldwide Developers Conference heißt
und nicht Worldwide Endusers Conference.
Darum haben wir ja Developer-Version.
Dass es darum geht, dass die Developer eine Version kriegen,
mit der sie die neuen APIs testen können. Die nicht da sind.
Nicht, dass du irgendwie deinen Spieltrieb ausleben kannst.
Die APIs sind nicht da.
Ich glaube, wir haben es jetzt gehört.
Deine APIs sind nicht da und sie kommen irgendwie später und wir können uns
jetzt lange darüber unterhalten, ob sie jetzt hätten schon da sein müssen oder
nicht. Sie sind halt jetzt nicht da, also kommen sie halt später.
Sie haben sie angekündigt, als wären sie da und sie sind nicht da.
Nein, sie haben gesagt, das ist jetzt erstmal nicht dabei.
Bei manchen Sachen, aber bei weiten nicht bei anderen Sachen.
Sie haben gesagt, das kommt später in diesem Jahr komplett.
Sie haben gesagt, du kannst jetzt.
Oh Max, komm, wirklich, das ist jetzt egal. Egal. Also, lass uns mal...
Nee, das ist nicht egal. Das ist wirklich nicht egal. Wenn mir gesagt wird,
du kannst hier einen X-Code eingeben, das und das, und dann passiert das und
das, und es passiert nichts davon.
Und es gibt nicht mal diesen entsprechenden API-Code.
Hast du den Sequoia auf deinem Mac drauf?
Nee, aber ich hab auf meinem iPad drauf und ich hab einen X-Code,
was auch immer die aktuelle Version ist, drauf und es gibt einfach die API-Codes noch nicht.
Und dass APIs noch nicht fertig sind und dass die...
Aber, dass die Menge Anfänge an Funktionalität, die schlicht nicht vorhanden
ist, habe ich bei Apple noch nie so gesehen.
Und das ist bemerkenswert. beenden,
weil, ja okay, bemerkenswert ist es nicht da, okay, aber es kommt.
Und ich finde es interessanter mal drauf zu gehen, was sie halt eigentlich vorhaben und was sozusagen,
dabei rauskommen soll, weil diese Idee des Knowledge Navigators folgend geht
es ja quasi darum, dass wir jetzt wirklich mit der Maschine,
mehr oder weniger intuitiv kommunizieren sollen.
Das ist ja eigentlich der Pipedream schlechthin, dass man sagt so hier,
Star Trek-mäßig, Computer, weiß ja ihr alles über mich, do the right thing.
Das ist ja eigentlich das, was sie hier angekündigt haben.
So der Do-What-I-Mean-Button, der irgendwie einfach mich versteht und.
Xcode hatte schon mal so ein.
Button.
Fix it. Die haben Gott sei Dank wieder ausgebaut.
So, und wie oft haben wir solche Sachen auch schon gehabt und sind daran verzweifelt
und denken, das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein, dass das nicht geht und wir wissen aber auch,
dass die technologische Basis dafür im Prinzip jetzt da ist und in dem Moment,
wo es halt einem System gelingt, Daten und vor allem sich auch dynamisch ändernde
Daten immer wieder in so ein Modell so intensiv einzubeziehen, ziehen, dass es,
mehr oder weniger sich in Echtzeit weiter trainiert, das ist so ein bisschen
der heilige Gral an dieser Stelle, weil das wäre ja dann schon sehr cool.
Wenn sowas funktioniert und es wird sich jetzt zeigen, ob sie das machen und
ich finde, dass sie sich ihre Kriegsschauplätze, die sie jetzt beziehen,
sehr interessant ausgesucht haben, weil sie sich, und darüber hatten wir eigentlich,
glaube ich, in der letzten Sendung, als wir das so alles mal ausgekäst haben,
was wir so erwarten, eigentlich auch genau darüber gesprochen.
Sie werden sich halt bestimmte Sachen im Betriebssystem anschauen,
wo es sinnvoll ist, sowas einzuführen.
Kann man jetzt drüber streiten, ob sie das geschafft haben, sinnvolle Orte zu
finden und sich dann darauf konzentrieren, die versuchen richtig zu machen,
aber nicht mit so einem Universalansatz daran zu gehen, mit irgendwie die eine
LLM, die alle Fragen und alle, die alles kann,
sondern das eben spezifisch ist und mit diesem Also sowas wie,
das haben sie ja dann angekündigt, diese Notification,
wie hieß das, Priorisation, also die Priorisierung der Notifications.
Das ist halt ein echtes Problem.
Du machst dein Ding auf und dann so tausend Notifications und weißt schon gar
nicht so, was ist denn das jetzt hier alles und so weiter.
Da halt Intelligence zu sammeln und das eben sinnvoll zu platzieren oder zusammenzufassen
oder Empfehlungen zu geben, worum man sich als erstes drum kümmern muss,
das kann einem irgendwie helfen unter Umständen.
Und genauso eben diese Hilfen, die sie in E-Mail einbauen also.
Gut, Zusammenfassung in dem Sinne ist schon fast normal, aber was war das noch?
Schöner formulieren.
Schöner formulieren, friendly.
Das ist aber wirklich ein totaler Standard. Und das ist sowas, was bei Kunden kommt.
Ja gut, aber das Schöner formulieren quasi in jedem Textview im System geht,
ist schon auch nochmal ein anderer Schnack.
Ja, ja.
Gut, aber die ganzen Grundfeatures hat Microsoft uns schon vor anderthalb Jahren noch gezeigt.
Also da sind sie jetzt eher late to the party. Die sind schön implementiert,
es sieht auch alles sehr sleek aus. oh so, es hat mir alles total gut gefallen,
aber davon war jetzt nichts originell.
Nee, ich glaube, dass der eigentliche Mehrwert...
Gar nichts davon ist originell. Weil das Besondere ist, dass sie sich die Zeit
genommen haben, es ins Betriebssystem an der richtigen Stelle ordentlich zu
integrieren und im Idealfall halt auch Dritt-Apps zur Verfügung zu stellen als APIs,
so wie sie es schon immer mit allem gemacht haben.
Also es ist selten, dass Apple mal mit irgendetwas die Ersten waren,
sondern sie waren immer nur die Ersten, die es vollständig ins Betriebssystem integriert haben.
Das ist eigentlich so das Ding.
Ja, und ich glaube, das ist auch der Mehrwert, den Apple da bietet,
ist, dass sie wirklich das ordentlich einbauen,
und nicht, dass das so ein, naja, so ladet ihr dieses Ding und dann hast du
da ein Textfeld und wenn du da was reinkippst, kommt unten im anderen Textfeld was raus.
Sondern, dass es wirklich integriert ist und dass es gut integriert ist.
Ja, ich hätte ja...
Viel mehr Freude und Hoffnung in meinem bubbernden Herzen, wenn sie eben nicht
so einen desaströsen Track Record hätten in ihrem klassischen Siri-Produkt.
Und ja, es ist doch ganz was anderes.
Ja, es ist ganz was anderes. Aber wenn wir jetzt eben von sehr kleinen,
spezialisierten LM-Modulen ausgehen, dann müssen sie die eben entlang ja von
konkreten Use Cases trainieren und daraufhin optimieren.
Und das ist exakt das, was sie seit zig Jahren bei Siri Tag um Tag um Tag um
Tag verkacken und zwar brutalst.
Das werden wir ja dann sehen, ob sie das jetzt wieder verkacken oder nicht,
aber dass sie jetzt einen neuen Ansatz wagen oder sagen wir mal so,
oder jetzt einen mit neuen Technologien, also mit den aktuellen Technologien weitermachen,
ist ja offensichtlich.
Also selbstverständlich werden
wir jetzt auf ein anderes Modell zugreifen, wenn wir mit Siri reden.
Wird das gut sein? Keine Ahnung. Besteht die Chance?
Selbstverständlich. Weil so doof sind die jetzt auch nicht, dass sie noch nicht
gemerkt haben, dass man das mal auf ein anderes System umstellen muss und dass
man jetzt so ein Transformer-LLM-Modell braucht, um den Dialog richtig zu machen.
Also der Punkt ist halt, wie viel Fehlerrate können sie sich erlauben?
Weil diese ganzen Beispiele, die sie gezeigt haben, die waren ja schon sehr, sehr cool.
Wo also die ganzen verschiedenen Ebenen auf dem Gerät so verbunden waren.
so, guck, wann wird meine Oma ankommen und dann wird erst in der Mail nachgeguckt,
so, welche Mails sind von der Oma und aha, und da ist der Flugplan drin,
dann wird live abgegriffen übers Internet,
so, hat dieses Flugzeugverspätung und dann, ja, wie weit muss ich bis dahin
irgendwie zu meinem Lieblingsrestaurant und sowas.
das hat ja alles, das sah ja total toll aus, wie sie uns das gezeigt haben.
Was passiert aber? Ja, es ist eben, da bin ich ein bisschen Team Max,
es ist eine Demo. Was passiert, wenn an einer einzigen Stelle,
Jetzt der KI-Vektor mal in die, weil die Hotness ein bisschen eingestellt war,
in die andere Richtung ab.
Und dann wird halt dein Opa eingeladen oder deine Oma mütterlicherseits statt
väterlicherseits kriegt dann die automatisierte E-Mail rausgehauen.
Und dann gehen die Leute aber ganz schön schnell auf die Barrikaden.
Das heißt also, wie robust ist wirklich dieses System?
Das wissen wir doch nicht. Ja, eben.
Ja, aber wollen wir uns die ganze Zeit darüber unterhalten, was vielleicht unter
Umständen alles schief gehen kann?
Aber man kann das ruhig ein bisschen skeptisch sehen.
Ja, aber doch nicht ausschließlich nur. Wir haben ja noch nicht mal aufgezählt, was sie gemacht haben.
Und ihr beschäftigt euch seit 10 Minuten damit nur mit, dass es vielleicht alles
nicht funktionieren wird.
Ja, okay, gut, das kann ja sein. Nein, aber das ist kein Inhalt für einen Podcast,
sondern wir müssen jetzt auch mal darüber reden, was sie machen und was ihr
Ansatz ist. Lass mich mal ein Beispiel rausgreifen, zwei Stück.
Nämlich, was hier auch als nächstes quasi steht, ist dieser Image-Playground.
Was ja im Prinzip ein Wir bauen uns Bilder Jetzt haben wir alle schon sehr viel
Zeit damit verbracht ChatGPT beizubringen Irgendwie Bilder zu machen Ich hier
immer mit meinen Episodenbildern und so weiter Und man verzweifelt ein wenig
Man verzweifelt an allem möglichen Man verzweifelt an sechs Fingern Man verzweifelt an.
Irgendwie Monsterfressen Man verzweifelt an Diversen Dingen So großartig die
Dinger auch sind Aber die Chance, dass da auch was komplett entgleist, ist mega hoch.
Das wird natürlich hier der Lackmustest sein.
Wie viel Image-Fail wird jetzt kommen?
Aber mein Eindruck war, und das war ja dann sozusagen gut zu sehen,
wie sie das aufgebaut haben, dass sie sich eben beschränken,
dass sie quasi aufbauen.
durch Accuracy, durch Beschränkung machen. Als Beispiel, wenn man so ein Bild
erstellt, gibt es nur drei Arten von Styles, die man umsetzen kann und die sind sehr klar definiert.
Du hast halt eine Animation, du hast irgendwie eine Illustration oder du hast
ein Sketch, das waren so die drei Kategorien, die sie haben.
Das heißt, ihr Ansatz ist, dass sie das eben super reduzieren und meine Vermutung
ist, dass eben ihr ganzes Training darauf ausgelegt ist, dass sie sich in einem
sehr definierten Output-Bereich bewegen.
Dass sie nicht versuchen, alles Mögliche zu machen, sondern dass die Qualität
gerade darin liegt, sich zu spezialisieren.
Und noch etwas weiter geht es mit diesen Genmojis, wo du halt so deine Emoji-artigen
Bilder erzeugen kannst.
Du kannst ja nicht wirklich Emojis erzeugen, weil dann müssten die ja automatisch
im Unicode eingetragen werden. Ich habe mich gefragt.
Könnten die nicht vielleicht einen Unicode-String anfangen, dass sie sagen,
hier ist ein privater definierter Bereich, hier endet der Bereich und dann halt
über mehrere Unicode-Zeichen die Beschreibung des Bildes, was da reinkommt, reinpacken.
Ich halte das für möglich.
Dass das im Unicode endet.
Ja, aber da kommt ja nicht jedes Mal das gleiche Bild raus.
Aber es kann sein, dass sie die aus Vektoren zusammensetzen und dann eine Beschreibung
des Bildes haben, was sie tatsächlich verschicken.
Okay, aber du merkst.
Worauf ich hinaus will.
Ich will darauf hinaus, sie reduzieren den Scope.
Aber sie erweitern ihn dann gleichzeitig auch. Sie machen die Bilder mit Bildern
aus meinem Fotoalbum, dass sie der Person ähnlich sehen.
Und das erhöht die Gefahren von einem Nippelgate, gerade für eine Firma wie Apple, dramatisch.
Jetzt bist du schon wieder auf diesem… Ja.
Ja, bin ich. Ich bleib da auch die ganze Zeit drauf.
Das ist so deutsch irgendwie.
Nee, das ist nicht so deutsch.
Das ist der Grund, warum es in Deutschland keine Homecomputer gab.
Wenn ich in diesen Image-Playground hier auf meinem iPad jetzt hätte und das
ausprobieren könnte und sagen könnte, so gut ist es, so schlecht ist es, aber es ist nicht da.
Es könnte schief gehen. Aber damit du das nicht machst. Du bist der Erste,
der so ein Avatar, der aus dem Image-Playground kommt, im Internet.
Nein. Aber es ist nicht da. Ich wäre vielleicht der Erste, wenn es da wäre.
Also das ist jetzt der Scope, den sie machen. Sie nehmen die Techniken,
die jetzt gerade angesagt sind.
Ja, Bilder erzeugen, aber wir bauen jetzt nicht die, ich kann alle Bilder,
die es gibt, erzeugen, sondern wir erzeugen bestimmte Bilder.
Und wir schaffen damit was Nützliches und wir verbinden das eben mit diesen persönlichen Daten.
Und ähnlich ist es ja dann auch mit den Apps.
Und wo ich übrigens richtig gespannt drauf bin, ist halt die Integration mit dem Hilfesystem.
Also wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, wird es ja jetzt auch möglich sein,
dem System konkret mal zu fragen, wie kann ich dich bedienen?
Und das war für mich in den letzten Wochen ganz oft das Thema,
dass ich, weil ich ja alt bin, mittlerweile auch mit der Technik nicht mehr klarkomme.
und so vor meinem Victron Batterie Solar und nicht weiß, wie ich jetzt irgendwie
meine Batterien konfigurieren soll und dann wälze ich irgendwie,
dann schaue ich mir YouTube-Videos an, wo irgendwelche Hansels irgendwas erklären,
das ist alles am Thema vorbei.
Dann lade ich mir irgendwelche PDF-Manuals runter oder Webseiten oder stöber
durch irgendwelche Foren und versuche irgendwie draufzukommen, was jetzt ist.
Lese mir Wikipedia durch und sitze da und denke mir immer noch,
das ist doch alles scheiße.
Wo wolltest du die Batterien auswechseln?
Und dann habe ich mir halt irgendwie Chat-GPT gegriffen und habe festgestellt,
das konnte mir so viel über diese Produkte sagen, mehr als die Webseiten der Hersteller.
Könnte mir vor allem ganz einfache Fragen beantworten, wo sich die Hersteller
irgendwie zu fein sind, darüber irgendwie nennenswert Auskunft zu geben.
Und das ist schon bemerkenswert. Und wenn jetzt diese Apple-Hilfe halt wirklich
mal diese komplexen Fragen beantworten kann, wie, ich muss mir mal ein Beispiel suchen,
ich möchte gerne, weiß ich, dein, kennt ihr diesen Effekt, wenn man irgendein
Accessibility-Feature angeschaltet hat, was einen dann irgendwie nervt?
Ich kann gerade kein gutes Beispiel nennen. Aber man hat halt irgendwann mal
irgendein Accessibility-Feature angeschaltet und dann ist immer irgendwie Zoom
auf irgendeine Funktion.
Ich kann dir eins nennen. Und zwar dieses, ich habe im Auto Bewegung und dann
gehen da die Punkte über das Bild.
Das hatte ich bei dem iPad angeschaltet.
Ach so, diese neue Funktion.
Ja, ja, heute Nachmittag. Und dann hörte das nicht auf. Und ich so, ah.
Genau, und dann find mal die Stelle, wie du das abschalten kannst.
Aber wenn du dann halt das einfach mit Worten beschreiben kannst und im Idealfall
einem direkt dieses Setting dann auch noch präsentiert, dann wäre schon eine
ganze Menge geholfen und ich sehe da gute Chancen.
Klar, wenn es funktioniert, aber sie haben jetzt diese Granularität und den
Zugriff und sie haben die Basistechnologie, um das zu machen und ähnlich läuft
es ja jetzt auch mit Actions und Shortcuts für Apps,
so Apps beschreiben halt ihre Funktionalität,
die LLMs lesen sich quasi die Apps durch und sie kennen auch die ganze GUI in
ihrem kompletten Aufbau, sie wissen auch, woran sind irgendwelche Buttons geknüpft
etc. Da bin ich sehr gespannt.
Das wird interessante Angriffsszenarien liefern.
Ja, Angriffsszenarien, aber es wird auch erstmal Chancen bieten,
um überhaupt Apps besser benutzen zu können.
Aber wir sind doch hier nicht bei Siri, erklär mir, wie ich ein iPhone,
worum ich ein iPhone halten muss.
Also noch nicht. Noch sind wir nicht so alt. Noch sind wir eher bei den,
welche spannenden Angriffsszenarien gibt es da?
Das ist doch was wichtig ist, dass Technologie auch zugänglich wird,
weil Technik, die immer nur ihren Selbstzweck hat, cool zu sein,
weil sie neu und teuer ist, das bringt mich ja nicht weiter.
Sondern ich möchte ja gerne, dass Technologie auch etwas bewirkt und mir hilft
und nicht eine totale Barriere ist.
Und ich merke das halt einfach in unseren total durchgesmarteten Systemen wirst
du halt einfach irgendwann nur noch bekloppt, weil du einfach überhaupt nicht
mehr checkst, wie der ganze Scheiß überhaupt funktioniert.
Und ehrlich gesagt, ich bin mittlerweile selber auch schon von der Fülle der
Settings auf so einem iPhone völlig überrumpelt.
Also das war ja mal früher sehr überschaubar, aber hast du da mal reingeschaut,
was da alles einstellbar ist?
Irgendwann weißt du auch gar nicht mehr, was Phase ist. Und da halt einfach
mal direkt fragen zu können, mach mir mal ein paar Vorschläge,
was ich hier so einschalten könnte.
Ich habe folgende Einschränkungen, welches Feature könnte mir dabei weiterhelfen?
Das wäre so eine Frage, die ich stellen würde. Ich habe jetzt,
als ich auf der Fahrt nach England war, war ich ja nicht handsfree.
Und ich hatte dann irgendwie alle Podcasts durchgehört.
Tim macht Lenkradbewegung.
Und ich habe noch viele hunderte Kilometer Autobahn vor mir gehabt.
Und dann dachte ich mir so, hm.
Ich will mich jetzt mit jemandem unterhalten. Und dann habe ich halt diese Dialogfunktion
von ChatGPT eingeschaltet und habe halt mit AirPods im Ohr auf der Autobahn angefangen, mir,
von, ich habe einfach quasi einen Podcast mit ChatGPT gemacht.
Ist es gut oder schlecht.
Dass du es nicht aufgezeichnet hast?
Also ich bin in diesen Interviewmodus gegangen und habe gesagt,
ChatGPT, ich möchte, mir, möchte, dass du mir jetzt gerne mal Strom erklärst.
Und konkret möchte ich jetzt genau wissen, wie fließt ein Strom durch einen
Leiter, was passiert da jetzt eigentlich wirklich?
Und dieser Dialog, das war wirklich unglaublich. Ich glaube,
ich habe eine halbe Stunde mit ChatGPT geredet.
Zwischendurch auch mal so,
Promteinwürfe gemacht und gesagt so, ja, kannst du mal die Formeln weglassen,
Das bringt mich jetzt nicht weiter.
Ich will jetzt hier eine generelle Einführung haben und bleib mal ruhig bei
den Vergleichen mit Wasser.
Wenn sich das anbietet, das passt schon irgendwie.
Und dann halt erklär mal, was ist jetzt der Unterschied?
Elektrisches Feld, magnetisches Feld, wie interagiert das, in welche Richtung
läuft der Strom, wenn der Schaltkreis irgendwie 300.000 Kilometer lang ist und
wieder zurück, wie lange dauert es, bis das Licht eingeschaltet ist,
wenn ich den Schalter umlege?
Und so eine Frage, was ich halt auch in einem Podcast gefragt hätte.
Und es war wirklich bemerkenswert. Also es hat funktioniert.
Und so möchte ich mich halt auch gerne mit meinem Telefon unterhalten.
Mein Telefon ist mein Freund.
Und oft genug ist es das aber dann irgendwie nicht, weil es dann schnell zum
Feind wird, wenn es nicht funktioniert wird oder wenn es Dinge tut,
die ich nicht möchte oder nicht die Dinge tut, die ich möchte.
Und ich weiß, du willst das jetzt alles natürlich wieder nicht hören,
aber ich bin ja mental völlig bei dir.
Ich würde mir nichts mehr wünschen, als dass genau das so funktioniert.
Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob dieser Apple-Approach es eben sehr narrow zu halten,
ob der dann da wirklich hinführt oder ob man dann wieder bei jeder zweiten Idee,
die man hat, eine Rückmeldung bekommt, ja dafür habe ich jetzt leider noch nicht
die richtige Integration als KI-Modell.
Komm in einem halben Jahr nochmal wieder.
Ich habe Zeit.
Also ehrlich gesagt ist mir das lieber, wenn das, was Sie versprechen,
funktioniert, als dass Sie versprechen, ich kann alles damit machen und nichts funktioniert.
Also ich muss auch sagen, ich finde den Ansatz, spezialisierte Modelle zu haben,
die auf lokaler, relativ schwachbrüstiger Hardware laufen und da vernünftig
funktionieren, aber mir nicht die Welt erklären können oder herbeihalluzinieren
können, finde ich eigentlich den interessanteren Ansatz.
Ich habe so ein bisschen so dieses ganze AGI-Gefasel, ich glaube nicht dran,
ich kann es nicht mehr hören.
Ich glaube, das ist was, wo so eine LLMs wirkliche Stärken haben können,
eben Notifications zusammenfassen. Da kann nicht wahnsinnig viel schief gehen.
Famous Last Words, wir werden bald sehen, was da alles schief gehen kann.
Notification-Gate.
Aber es ist so, diese tiefe Integration, die sie da gezeigt haben,
ich will es sehen. Ich will es sehen, darüber freue ich mich.
Vor allem liefen dann ja hinterher die ganzen Icons über den Screen von den
ganzen Apps, die das dann unterstützen werden.
Habt ihr die eine App gesehen, die dort fehlte?
Ich kann mich an die Geile erinnern, die da überhaupt war. Was war denn da zu sehen?
Naja, halt Messages und E-Mail und Kalender und Maps.
Also jetzt nur die Bild-In-Apps?
Genau, die Bild-In-Apps. Und eine einzige fehlte. Und das ist aber die,
die mich jeden einzelnen fucking Tag zur totalen Verzweiflung bringt.
Eine, eine, eine...
Musik! Spiele bitte das Hörspiel von meinem Sohn, was er heute Morgen gehört hat, die nächste Folge.
Jeden fucking, jeden fucking Tag.
Achtung, spiel bitte die vierte Episode von Schlau wie Vier.
Ich spiele den letzten Hit von Tina Turner, bitte sehr.
Jeden fucking Tag. Das heißt also, es ist völlig aussichtslos,
Musik mit Siri bedienen zu wollen, wenn du nicht irgendwie nur exakt dein Album und irgendwie...
Ja gut, also...
So, und das wäre...
Musik haben sie nicht gezeigt und ich gebe dir recht.
Da ist noch sehr viel Luft nach oben. Ich habe es sekundengenau abgescrollt.
Es ist kein Musik-Icon dort.
Und das ist das, wo aber der meiste Fallout passiert.
Musik auch nicht in dem Release-Cycle von den Major-Releases drin ist.
Ist das im App-Store?
Nee, das nicht. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie sich an den Features von Music
letzten Endes an die Major-Releases hängen, sondern wenn es da was Neues gibt.
Aber Musik wäre tatsächlich ein fantastisches Beispiel, wo sowas funktionieren könnte.
Meine Kriterien sind immer große Datenlage, aber auch geringe Fallhöhe, wenn es schief geht.
Also nicht schreib eine Mail an meinen Chef, dass er ein Arschloch ist,
aber freundlich formuliert, sondern halt so, wenn da das falsche Musikstück
kommt, dann ist das kein Weltuntergang und das kostet niemand den Job.
Außer für meine Kinder.
Ja, ja.
Deinen Kindern kostet das der Job?
Und ich bin da, ihnen kostet es den Job.
Also hat er erzählt, wie toll das ist und wie viele Bilder er gemacht hat und
wie großartig das alles ist. Er braucht das für die Schule.
Ja, und wenn ich mal einsam bin, dann kann J.J.P.T. mein Freund sein. Ungepromptet.
What have you done to my child?
Ja, aber du hast recht, bei Musik wäre es tatsächlich, es wäre ein perfektes Einsatzszenario.
Aber das ist wiederum was, wo man das nicht auf die Weiß macht.
Das könnte man perfekt auf dem Device machen. Deine History lernen.
Was hast du gehört? Ich meine, 90 Prozent der Leute hören vier Songs immer wieder.
Naja, schon. Aber die gesamte Apple Music Library ist ja nicht auf deinem Device,
sondern das ist ja bei Apple.
Und wenn du jetzt was über die Apple Music Library haben willst,
dann sagt natürlich die Cloud von Apple, hier, ich habe da noch diesen Special-Aufnahme von 1834.
Ja, das soll man nicht machen.
Also auf der einen Seite geht es halt um das, was Ralf braucht.
Es geht darum, irgendwie einfach die richtigen Sachen zu finden.
Und auf der anderen Seite geht es um das, was der HomePod ja auch schon immer hat.
Wir erinnern uns an die HomePod Original-Werbung.
Diese großartige, dieser großartige Werbeclip. Einer der besten Werbeclips,
den Apple jemals gemacht hat im Übrigen.
Da lautet die Frage ja auch Hey Siri, play something I'd like.
Bevor sie dann mit ihrer Tanzerei dann anfängt Erinnerst du dich an diesen Werbeclip?
Also an das Tanzen, aber an den Slogan nicht Genau.
Sie kommt halt rein in die Wohnung, völlig gestresst Regen, U-Bahn,
irgendwie Arbeit Stress, ich muss mich aufs Sofa legen und dann so weiter und
dann einfach nur Serie Spielen wir irgendwas, was mir gefallen könnte Da ist
sozusagen dieser persönliche,
Anknüpfungspunkt, da können sie sicherlich jetzt noch mehr machen Weiß ich nicht,
aber ich glaube aber es geht auch erst mal ums Verzeichnis, dass sie das richtig hinkriegen.
Mal gucken, wer schneller ist, der VÖBB oder Apple Music.
Genau, wir bauen da mal was. Also das Problem ist einfach, dass Apple Music
einfach mit Hörspielen nicht umgehen kann.
Die haben einfach die Entität Hörspiele nicht verstanden.
Das können sie alle nicht.
Die sind halt ein Outlet der klassischen Musikindustrie. Mit allem,
was da nicht reinpasst, können sie nicht gut umgehen. Das ist schon so.
Ja, sollte man eigentlich erwarten, dass sie es können.
Schreibt übrigens Steffen gerade richtig im Chat hier. Eine meiner größten Enttäuschungen,
den HomePod haben sie nie genannt.
Ergo bleibt Siri dort, erstmal dumm wie Toastbrot.
Ja und das ist genau der Punkt, also da wo man es bisher am meisten eigentlich
vermisst, da ist die Chance wahrscheinlich wirklich so, dass es erstmal noch
zwei, drei Jahre genauso bleibt.
Sie haben Siri sowieso meiner Meinung nach eher weniger erwähnt und auch eher
nicht gesagt, dass es jetzt die große Siri-Revolution wird.
Dieses ganze Apple Intelligence war doch eigentlich nur Siri.
Nee, war es ja eben nicht.
Naja, das hat immer schon an der Seite geblüht.
Ein paar Mal, aber es war nicht die ganze Zeit. Deswegen sind meine Erfahrungen,
dass sich jetzt Siri einen Quantensprung hinlegt, auch nicht so riesig, ehrlich gesagt.
Also da war mein Eindruck exakt gegenteiliger.
Ums Bilder verfassen und ums...
Also ich glaube, dass sie an der Stelle einfach mal den Ball flach gehalten
haben. Weil wenn sie jetzt gesagt hätten, jetzt ist Siri richtig geil.
Also abgesehen davon, dass sie damit zugegeben hätten, dass es bisher nicht richtig geil war.
Sie haben es auch nicht umbenannt. Nebenbei, das hatten wir auch überlegt.
Hätten sie unnötigerweise jetzt eine Erwartungshaltung... Es ist sowieso klar,
dass alle das jetzt testen werden, wie blöde.
Und wenn sich rausstellt, dass es es dann auf einmal besser ist und funktioniert,
dann werden alle schreiben, boah, jetzt gucke mal, wir haben es entdeckt,
Siri funktioniert jetzt wieder richtig gut, dann ist das eine Nachricht.
Wenn sie aber nur irgendwie einen Erwartungshorizont aufspannen,
den dann Einzelne nicht als erreicht sehen, dann wird es gleich wieder relativ schlecht sein.
Also sie haben eine Story gebracht, wo jemand auf die Bühne kommt und sagt,
plane hier, ob das mit dem Termin von meiner Tochter für ihr,
Schulstück nicht übereinstimmt und wo Siri aus iMessage ein PDF rausholt,
aus dem PDF, das den Zeitpunkt rausliest, die Wegstrecke ausrechnet,
den Termin ausrechnet, eine iMessage an die Tochter schickt, etc.
pp. Das war ein ganzes Universum. Die haben den
Was so diese persönliche Integration angeht, finde ich, haben sie extrem viel aufgespannt.
Diese Story hier, was du gerade erzählt hast mit dem, wann kommt das Flugzeug
an mit meiner Mutter, so halt aus irgendeiner Nachricht, irgendwann mal vor
Ewigkeiten den Flugnummer rausgeholt etc.
Ich fand, sie hatten, was Siri angeht, haben sie schon sehr,
sehr hochgelegt die Latte.
Ja, aber trotzdem ist es so, dass der Teil war zehn Minuten,
Viertelstunde vielleicht.
Und es ist nicht so, dass Apple Intelligent vor allen Dingen Siri war,
sondern es gab halt den Siri-Teil.
Aber es gab halt den, wie hießen die, Genmoji-Teil und das Bildermal.
Aber der war 20 Sekunden lang.
Die Dingselkringel.
Der Jan Mosey-Teil war 20 Sekunden lang.
Und das war halt auch so, dass man es alles schon gesehen hat.
Aber dieser Integrationsteil, wo wirklich die verschiedenen Elemente auf dem
Device plötzlich zusammenspielen, das ist neu und originell und hat man so noch nicht gesehen.
Gut, aber das haben einem andere auch schon versprochen.
Daher meine Skepsis.
Und dieser Rapid, oder wie das Ding hieß.
Aber Siri jetzt sozusagen als erstmal das...
Sie haben dem einfach ein neues Icon verpasst, das würden sie jetzt auch nicht
tun, wenn da nicht eine neue Versprechung dahinter steht, aber sie haben nicht
in dem selben Moment gesagt, es ist jetzt das beste seit geschnitten Brot.
Sie haben halt gesagt, wir haben neue Features durch diese persönliche Integration
und die persönliche Integration wird man sehen, ob das funktioniert,
ob da aber dann der reine Dialog besser wird, das steht nochmal auf dem anderen Blatt.
Also mir würde es ja schon reichen, dass wenn ich die Uhr hebe und direkt in
die Uhr reinspreche und Siri was machen lassen will, dass Siri dann auch merkt,
dass ich das auf der Uhr bitte hätte und nicht auf dem HomePod 3 Zimmer weiter.
Okay, lass uns mal weiter marschieren, weil ich denke, wir haben uns jetzt zu
Apple Intelligence im Allgemeinen ausreichend ausgelassen.
Ich würde gerne nochmal den Zyniker ein bisschen raushängen lassen.
Noch mehr? Ja, noch mehr.
Ich habe neulich ein Interview mit dem CEO von Zoom gehört, der erzählt hat
in einem Podcast, dass ich probiere es kurz zu halten.
Tims Uhr sagt ihm gerade Bescheid, dass es zu spät wird.
Nee, ich muss erst mal laden.
Sonst sagt die bald nichts mehr. Der hat in einem Interview gesagt,
dass wir bald alle nur noch am Strand liegen werden, weil unsere AI-Avatare
unsere Zoom-Meetings für uns machen.
Und was der Interviewer in dem Moment nicht einfach rausgeht,
lachend die Tür hinter sich zuknallt,
und der Grund, warum macht der Zoom-CEO so eine Scheiße, warum macht er sich
da so zum Clown vor seinen Mitarbeitern, liegt ja auch ein bisschen daran,
Nvidia war jetzt kurzzeitig die zweitwertvollste Firma der Welt.
Und die werden das nicht, das höre ich von Scott Galloway, heißt der,
und mit Carol Swisher macht der einen Podcast, die sind teilweise schwer erträglich,
aber hin und wieder hauen die auch mal extrem schlaue Sachen raus.
Und ich fand, das war einer dieser schlauen Punkte.
Nvidia ist gerade die zweitteuerste Firma der Welt geworden aus dem Stand.
Die haben eine solche krasse Performance hingelegt und all diese AI-Firmen werden
gerade so mit Geld zugeschüttet.
Und das Geld muss irgendwo herkommen und das wird aus anderen Unternehmen abgezogen.
Das heißt, irgendjemand sitzt da und schreit dem Zoom-CEO ins Ohr,
sag irgendwas mit AI, bitte, irgendwas mit AI, die Investoren springen uns ab
und dann denkt er sich halt irgendwas mit AI aus.
Und es gibt diesen berühmten Satz vom Microsoft-CEO, als sie damals die Chat-GPT-Integration
in Bing angekündigt haben, So, we made Google dance.
Also Google musste nach unserer Falve tanzen, übersetze ich jetzt mal ein bisschen frei.
Und Google hat getanzt. Und das Lustige ist, der Bing-Marktanteil ist null gestiegen.
Bisher hat Microsoft bei dieser ganzen AI-Strategie nur draufgezahlt,
aber Google tanzt immer noch.
Die haben gerade zu ihrer Google I.O. haben die...
krass was gezeigt und dann probieren die Leute das aus und sagen,
ah, Google erzählt mir jetzt, ich soll Steine essen.
Also ich meine, das ist ja das, was rausgekommen ist.
Mit den ganzen Rezepten?
Mit den Rezepten, dass man seine Pizza, dass man den Käse einfach Kleber nehmen
soll, um den Käse auf der Pizza zu halten, etc.
Die Zahl der Beispiele ist ja unfassbar hoch. Und ich habe das Gefühl,
dass gerade alle sagen, Ja, wir machen was mit der AI, AI, AI, AI.
Bitte zieht eure Gelder nicht aus unseren, wir sind zukunftsfähig.
Und ein bisschen werde ich das Gefühl nicht los, dass das der Apple-Moment war.
Und der Apple-Aktienkurs ist heute Morgen um vier Prozent gestiegen.
Ich glaube sieben.
Sieben sogar. Und ich bin zynisch.
Ich verstehe jetzt gar nicht, worauf du hinaus willst. Also was ist denn daran jetzt das Problem?
Jedes Tech-Unternehmen muss jetzt gerade sagen, dass sie AI machen,
weil Investoren in meinen Augen extrem fehlgeleitet glauben,
dass AI alles ändern wird und das Ende des Kapitalismus darstellt und dass Sam
Altman uns übernächste Woche die AGI bringt und wir alle arbeitslos sein werden.
Ja, also ich meine, dass der Hype-Cycle jetzt gerade total überdreht, ist vollkommen klar.
Und Apple ist jetzt Teil dieses Hype-Cycles.
Ja, aber, naja gut, aber ich meine, Apple weiß auch, wie ich auch, dass da was dran ist.
Weil das ist ja kein Bitcoin-Scheiß, sondern das ist halt schon die… Also ich
habe die gleiche Diskussion schon mal mit Bitcoin geführt. Ja, aber es ist… Ja.
Aber diesen Auto-Podcast, den Tim aufgenommen hat über Strom, den hat es ja gegeben.
Ja, ja, ja.
Das ist ja auch meine Rede, darum machen wir auch diese Föpp-Geschichten so,
auf einer gewissen Ebene funktionieren diese Dinge eben verstörend.
Es ist nicht so, dass es gar nicht funktioniert.
Der Scheiß ist wirklich geil. Und ich glaube auch, das, was Apple jetzt hier
vorgestellt hat, ist wirklich geil.
Das wird vielleicht nicht alles beim ersten Mal funktionieren und wahrscheinlich
sind bei dir ein paar Features halt nicht freigeschaltet, weil du mal bei Facebook gearbeitet hast.
Aber ich bin relativ sicher, das meiste davon wird schon ganz gut funktionieren.
Und das, was nicht funktioniert dieses Jahr, wird nächstes Jahr funktionieren,
weil diese Algorithmen sich bewährt haben, jetzt schon.
So, nach zwei Jahren Superhype und der ist natürlich, natürlich sind jetzt alle
Leute, die jetzt Bitcoins nicht mehr verkauft bekommen, rennen jetzt rum und
sind jetzt AI-Berater, ist ja vollkommen klar.
Das wird auch mit dem nächsten großen Ding so sein.
Trotzdem ist halt dieses Machine Learning, AI-Konglomerat, wie immer man das
auch nennen will, ist halt jetzt nach …,
Internet und Telefon und so weiter das große Ding.
Ich glaube aber auch das, was Apple da macht und dadurch, dass es so unglaublich
zugänglich ist für Otto Normalverbraucher und selbst der CEO von einer Firma
wie Zoom versteht dann langsam mal, was AI ist,
dass eventuell das auch so ein bisschen den Hype-Cycle killt,
weil alle sagen so, so viel ist ja dann doch nicht dahinter.
Was hier jemand gerade im Chat sagt, ist, was finde ich sehr richtig,
das Geile bei Apple wird nicht die Qualität der AI sein.
Das haben wir schon woanders gesehen, definitiv. Das Geile ist,
dass es integriert und kostenlos kommt.
Ich meine, wir nutzen alle Siri nicht, weil Siri so geil ist, sondern weil es,
gelegentlich dann doch mal okay funktioniert. Und halt, ich kann Chat-GPT Einmal stellen geht immer.
Ich kann mit Chat-GPT mir eine To-Do-Liste zusammenstellen und es wird wahrscheinlich
eine tausendmal bessere To-Do-Liste, aber sie ist halt null in meine To-Do-Listen-App integriert.
und was ich bei ChatGPT wirklich anstrengend finde, ist, wenn man dieses Gespräch,
was du gerade beschrieben hast, wenn man das beenden will und dann sagt,
so, jetzt beende mal das Gespräch und leg mal auf, dann kannst das einfach nicht.
Dieses unfassbar schlaue Modell kann einfach nichts, wenn man es genau nimmt.
Es kann ein bisschen Bilder generieren, es kann ein bisschen Text generieren, aber das war's.
Und es kann halt, es ist nirgendwo integriert und das ist bisher bei,
das ist auch bei diesen, und Microsoft hat ja Copilot integriert in sein ein
Betriebssystem und dann kann man sich von Copilot hey,
wie mache ich einen Screenshot und dann erklärt Copilot, ja,
dann gehst du auf die Seite und wo dann die Leute sagen, ja,
da kann ich auch Google nehmen.
Ich will, dass du das machst für mich.
Und das wird jetzt, da werden wir noch mehr als einen Lackmustest sehen.
Und ich habe in letzter Zeit zu viele Versprechen in der Richtung gehört,
als dass ich noch einfach so sagen werde, dass es alles, dass diese,
also wir werden auf diese Demos zurückkehren und wenn die in dem Jahr,
mal gucken, wie viele von diesen Demos in dem Jahr funktionieren werden.
Okay, ich verspreche dir, das wird schon ganz cool werden.
Das wurde mir über Siri auch schon mal erzählt. So, jetzt fließen wir aber dieses
Kapitel mal wirklich ab.
Wir haben jetzt hier tausend Sachen, die wir uns hier notiert haben,
was so bei iOS 18 und iPadOS 18 und den anderen Betriebssystemen,
so vorgestellt wurde, noch an Features, ich will jetzt auf gar keinen Fall, die alle durchgehen.
Aber wir können jetzt ja mal ein paar Sachen mal raus. Jeder kann sich ja mal was rausklinken.
Sucht euch mal was aus, was ihr sozusagen davon besonders bemerkenswert fandet
oder interessant aus irgendwelchen anderen Gründen.
Ich sag mal so, vielleicht jetzt nicht besonders interessant,
aber ich hab's zumindest schon mal ausprobiert.
Das waren die Math Notes für den Calculator.
Da dieses, ich scribble mir irgendwie meine Formel hin oder schreib halt handschriftlich,
was da gerechnet werden soll.
Und das hat selbst bei meinem, ich schreibe ohne meinen Pencil,
sondern nur mit dem Zeigefinger, krakeligen Schrift erstaunlich gut funktioniert.
Bis auf, dass er 3x-7 interpretiert hat als 3 mal minus 7.
Also da hat fast alles aus der Demo, die sie gezeigt haben, bei der WWDC funktioniert.
Ich habe die Formel eingetragen, ich habe das Gleichheitszeichen,
ich habe das Ergebnis hingeschrieben.
In meiner Handschrift, die haben ein Modell, was meine Handschrift lernt.
Ich kann Variablen definieren und habe dann diesen kleinen Slider,
mit dem ich die Variablenwerte ändern kann.
Das ist, ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendjemand jemals benutzen wird,
also ich wahrscheinlich nicht, aber es ist sehr, sehr, sehr beeindruckend.
Also ich fand, das war, glaube ich, die überzeugendste Demo,
die ich seit vielen, vielen Jahren von Apple gesehen habe.
Und die funktioniert tatsächlich.
Also auch von der Inszenierung her, so auch dieses Yay, dieser Sound,
den man schon zigmal gehört hat, so als so ein Standard.
Das fand ich noch ein bisschen, ehrlich gesagt, creepy. So endlich Calculator
und alle dachten so, ja gut, jetzt kommt halt Calculator und der erste Screen,
den du siehst und dann auch irgendwie,
gut, sie haben 30 mal mehr Buttons drauf gebaut jetzt, weil sie den Platz halt
hatten und dann kommt diese Handschriftnummer und du denkst so,
okay, das ist diese fucking Zukunft, von der sie immer einem was erzählen.
Lass uns mal kurz beschreiben, was es macht. Also Mass Notes ist quasi,
man kann jetzt Mathe in eine App, also entweder in diesen Calculator reinschreiben
oder in die normalen Notes.
Man nimmt den Stift und kann einfach mit Handschrift oder was hinschreiben.
Ich vermute mal, man kann es auch mit der Tastatur eingeben,
aber es ist natürlich noch ein bisschen beeindruckender, wenn du es einfach hinmalst.
Und es erkennt eben automatisch Formeln, Variablen, Zuweisungen, Werte.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man es auch mit der Tastatur kann. Sie wollen auch die Stifte verkaufen.
Nee, aber ich glaube, es gibt tatsächlich keine Tastatur.
Interessant ist, dass man tatsächlich die Notizen-App braucht.
Also die kommt bei der Beta nicht mit dabei. Ich habe da auf die mathematischen
Notizen geschaltet und gesagt, hier, lad erst mal die Notizen-App aus dem App
Store runter und dann sehen wir weiter.
Ernsthaft?
Das hatte ich nicht.
Die normale Notes-App ist nicht bei der Beta dabei, oder was?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Die Beta war auch relativ klein. Nein, also es ist glaube
ich ganz schön abgespeckt.
Auf jeden Fall, man kann also das hinschreiben, man kann dann sich auch quasi
Werteverläufe automatisch plotten lassen, also so einen Graph machen.
Also wenn man halt jetzt irgendwie ein paar Variablen hat und dann sagt man
Y ist gleich la la la, Werte abhängig von diesen Variablen, dann kann man eben
dann für bestimmte Variablenverläufe sich dann Plots machen.
Also im Prinzip ist das so das Hausaufgaben-Matte-Lernen-Tool.
Das fand ich schon ganz nett, aber es ist auch schön, dass sie jetzt endlich
mal einen Taschenrechner auf iPadOS nachgeliefert haben, warum es das nicht
gab, keine Ahnung. Okay, what's next?
Angeblich, weil sie nicht dazugekommen sind im ursprünglichen iPadOS und es
dann in jedem Release immer wieder hinten runterfiel, weil es keiner für wichtig betrachtet hat.
Also ich habe zwei Sachen. Das erste ist, ich habe ja gestern Nacht mir hier
auf meinem Mac schon die Beta installiert und da ist jetzt die Passwort-App drauf.
Auf die war ich doch ein bisschen gespannt. Also sprich, das war es bisher im
Schlüsselbund irgendwo vergraben war und man ansonsten halt mit One Password
oder ähnliches gemacht hätte.
Jetzt das Versprechen, das halt schön gesynkt über alle Devices halt entsprechend
von Apple direkt. perfekt.
Design ist soweit auch irgendwie ganz schön, da habe ich jetzt gar nicht so
viele Schmerzen. Es gibt aber halt,
Finde ich so zwei echte Probleme. Das erste ist der Import.
Sie haben halt einen CVS-Import, der aber beispielsweise, wenn ich jetzt mal meine ganzen...
CSV.
CSV, ja genau.
CVS war was anderes.
Wenn ich jetzt meine ganzen Daten von One Password einfach mal rein importiere,
dann kommen so die simplen Sachen an, aber alles, was irgendwo ein bisschen
strukturierter von mir aufgebaut ist in One Password, kommt nicht rein.
Das heißt also, die haben da wirklich nur Key-Value halt, was sie an der Stelle übertragen.
Ohne Sektionen.
Ohne eine Sektion, ohne erweiterte Daten. Und One Password hat ja ein eigenes,
Exportformat, das kriegst du halt nicht rein importiert.
Da hätte ich jetzt, also wenn ich Apple wäre, würde ich da in Sachen Importfunktion
nochmal eine Schippe drauflegen.
Was aber, glaube ich, schwierig wird, weil deren internes Datenmodell das,
so wie ich das im Moment sehe, nicht hergibt.
Das heißt also, ein Standardfall von mir ist, dass ich in One Password meine
Kreditkarten komplett rein modelliert habe.
Also nicht nur irgendwie diese dreistellige
Nummer, sondern auch noch die Internet-Banking-ID, die da dran hängt.
Also an jeder Kreditkarte hängen zumindest bei mir, in Diba irgendwie drei oder
vier verschiedene Passworte noch dran.
Ich weiß, verschiedene Kontexten, die man selten braucht.
Aber wenn man sie braucht, dann willst du sie wirklich den einen Ort wissen,
wo sie sind und willst nicht an den Aktenordner gehen und versuchen noch irgendwie
aus einem Papierordner das rauszubekommen.
Sowas kannst du in der Password-App, so wie Stand derzeit, ist nicht modellieren.
Das heißt also wirklich auch dort nur Key-Value.
Nicht mit irgendwie verschiedene Elemente von allem zum selben.
Ich glaube, One Password wird weiterhin das Power-Tool bleiben.
Ja, aber müsste es nicht. Also da frage ich mich, da hätten sie ein bisschen
mehr rein investiert, hätten sie hier One Password Sherlocken können.
Das wäre nicht so schwierig gewesen.
One Password kann ja noch viel mehr. Also der Scope,
ist bei One Password mittlerweile viel, viel größer. Ich finde das okay,
dass sie das machen, weil eigentlich ist es schade.
Apple waren die allerersten, die überhaupt dieses Prinzip eines Passwort-Speichers hatten.
Diese Keychain-Access gibt es seit macOS 8.
Stimmt, das gibt es schon. Oder 8.5.
Oder so.
Bei Classic Mac OS?
Ja, ja.
Das gibt es richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig lange. Das ist über 20 Jahre alt.
Also sie hatten diese Idee schon immer und es war ins Betriebssystem integriert.
Es war dann in, ich glaube es war sogar schon, war das schon Cyberdog?
Nee, das nicht. Aber mit Safari auf jeden Fall war das schon voll integriert
mit vielen anderen Sachen aus, aber es wurde nie so richtig benutzt.
Und insofern fand ich das jetzt ein bisschen schade eigentlich,
dass sie diesem Keychain-Access keine Liebe gebracht haben, weil es ja so alles aufmacht.
Es geht so auf Systemebene runter und zeigt einem tausend Sachen an,
die einen überhaupt nicht interessieren.
Und es wäre ja eigentlich nur eine Frage des Weglassens gewesen und dann hätten
sie irgendwie schon eine ordentliche App und ein User-Interface kriegst du eigentlich
auch an einem Wochenende irgendwie hin.
Und dann haben sie es in die Systemeinstellungen jetzt reingeschoben im aktuellen
Betriebssystem, wo ich mich auch gefragt habe, was soll denn das jetzt?
Teilweise tauchen dann die Passwörter auch in Safari nochmal auf und jetzt wird es ordentlich.
Aber sie müssen nicht gleich One Password ablösen, weil One Password macht viel,
viel, viel, viel mehr und das ist so für so detailversessene Supernerds,
aber die meisten Leute wollen halt einfach mal nur ihre Passwörter aneinander schicken.
Nee, aber sie hatten ja, also zumindest bei macOS ist es ja so,
dass die Internet-Passwörter in dieser Internet-Keychain waren ja immer in Safari
drin und alle anderen Passwörter waren in der, in Anführungszeichen,
richtigen Keychain. Also WLAN-Passwort zum Beispiel.
Oder irgendwelche Zertifikate oder sonst irgendeinen Scheiß.
Und es gibt ja jetzt zum Schluss, irgendwie haben sie ja noch nachgebessert,
dass wenn du die Keychain aufmachen willst, kommt ein Dialog hoch.
Willst du nicht vielleicht bei Safari deine Passwörter nachgucken?
Und da denkst du so, nein, ich weiß nicht, was ich tue, gib mir die Keychain.
Das bessert sich jetzt auf jeden Fall Also gut.
Der Form dieses Passwort-Tools in der Beta ist noch sehr rough Da ist noch,
einiges möglich, glaube ich Also richtig begeistert war ich da jetzt auch nicht von Aber da.
Würde ich sagen, gut, das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich eine erste Beta,
da kann man noch abwarten Ein erster Wurf,
Wobei normalerweise bei solchen Apple-eigenen Apps so richtig häufig,
habe ich das dann auch nicht gesehen, dass dann über Betas noch viele Features
hinzugekommen wären. Aber wir werden sehen.
So, und das Zweite, wo ich wirklich sagen würde, jucha, und gebt es mir bitte
sofort, aber auch das funktioniert noch nicht, iPhone Mirroring. Oh, ist das schön.
Das ist ein macOS-Feature.
MacOS, ja.
Das ist natürlich auch ein iPhone-Feature.
Also so bin ich jetzt nicht aus dem Häuschen, aber ich würde es wahrscheinlich
früher oder später irgendwie auch mal nebenbei verwenden.
Es gibt eben doch die drei, vier Apps, die wirklich nur auf dem iPhone laufen
und ich arbeite aber am Rechner und dann immer ständig wieder Gerät holen und
entsperren und da richtig hin navigieren und dieses und jenes.
Ja und die Möglichkeit einfach.
Banking, Authentication Apps zum Beispiel.
So, und einfach die Möglichkeit haben, das komplette iPhone ohne Wenn und Aber
mit Touch, mit Drag & Drop sogar aus MacOS heraus.
Ja, Daten übernehmen, Copy-Paste zu machen, irgendwie aus dem iPhone auf dem Mac.
Das wird herrlich, das werde ich täglich feiern. Auch schon wirklich relevant.
Einfach auf ein Gerät testen zu können, ohne das Gerät selber in die Hand nehmen
zu müssen, das finde ich schon spannend.
Vielleicht kann man es ja auch per UI, per XC-UI-Test irgendwie fernsteuern
oder sowas, das finde ich auch cool.
Und ein schönes Detail, wenn man halt dieses iPhone, also iPhone Mirroring bedeutet
ja, man kriegt quasi das komplette iPhone-Interface, den ganzen Screen-Inhalt
quasi auf dem Mac angezeigt.
Und während man das macht, also man kann dann alles damit tun,
man kann quasi mit dem Trackpad irgendwie mit der Tastatur, kann man das iPhone
benutzen, als wäre das ganze iPhone eine App quasi.
Aber das iPhone selber zeigt das dann nicht zwangsläufig an.
Das kann also nach wie vor gelockt irgendwo rumliegen und wenn Leute da rangehen,
sehen sie nicht, was jemand anderes gerade von seinem Rechner aus mit dem Telefon
macht. Das ist auch nochmal so ein schönes Teil.
Eigentlich auch keine große Sache, wenn man sich überlegt,
dass du irgendwie schon seit Jahren irgendwie den Inhalt des iPhones im Quicktime-Player
als Kamera auswählen kannst und dann einfach in dem Quicktime-Player-Fenster
siehst, was das iPhone tut.
Ich meine mit FaceTime, Screensharing und so weiter, also die Technologie ist
jetzt alles anders als neu, es sind halt nur die Integrationen.
Aber so Dreck und Drop ist natürlich schon nochmal ein anderer Level,
da ist sicherlich nochmal das ein oder andere API und die Abstraktionen dazugekommen,
aber schön, dass es das gibt, das ist in der Tat eine der besseren Sachen.
Ich finde ehrlich gesagt auch das Tap to Cash von der Wallet.
Finde ich eigentlich auch ein spannendes Feature, je nachdem,
wann das dann nach Deutschland kommt und wann das man auch mit deutschen Franken machen kann.
Also was sie gezeigt haben ist, dass man Geld, aber das funktioniert ja nur
mit Apple Cash und das gibt es nach wie vor nur in den USA.
Ach nur mit Apple Cash, also mit Apple Pay selber auch nicht.
Apple Pay Cash heißt das glaube ich.
Nein, weil Apple Pay geht ja immer über einen Payment-Dienstleister und das
ist ja sozusagen von Gerät zu Gerät. Das basiert auf Apple Cash,
das konntest du derzeit mit Apple Messages machen und das haben sie jetzt einfach nur mit Tab gemacht.
Dass sie das nie für andere Länder ausgerollt haben, das ist so ein praktisches
Feature, ich hab das so gerne genutzt.
Welches jetzt?
Per iMessage Geld verschicken zu können.
Nee, aber dazu mussten sie ja, also Apple Cash heißt ja auch Apple hält für
dich Geld, also ist ja quasi Bank.
Das war damals, das war eine Discovery Card, die sie da im Hintergrund für dich
angelegt haben, ohne dass du es gemerkt hast.
Also das könnten sie auch woanders ausrollen und inzwischen haben sie auch Ja.
Aber es ist halt ein Regulierungs Ja.
Suchen sie sich irgendeinen Partner Zwei Buchstaben EU.
Sie können das machen, aber Das ist auch in den USA.
Hart durchreguliert zu banken.
Aber das gibt es ja glaube ich noch nicht mal in Kanada Aber.
Habt ihr diese Animation gesehen, mit der das verbunden war?
Die ist sehr, sehr geil.
Da hatte ich ja voll die Infinity Wars Vibes bei Avengers Wenn Thanos mit seinem
Snip alles in Sand auflöst,
siehst du dann, wie sich dein Geldbetrag in Sandkörner auflöst und die dann
davon wehen auf das andere Device.
Sehr, sehr schön gemacht. Das hat so einen wehmütigen Moment,
bringen sie da in die Kui rein.
Ich muss auch kurz nochmal über Accessibility abranten.
Sind wir schon durch jetzt mit Apple Cash?
Ich denke schon. Sie haben ganz wunderbare Dinge vorgestellt,
aber es gibt immer noch nichts für Linkshänder.
Ich bin ja hier der Resident Linkshänder und muss mich dann ab und zu mal darüber
beschweren, wenn Dinge für Linkshänder nicht funktionieren.
Und es ist jetzt seit insgesamt 18 Versionen von iOS immer noch so,
dass Linkshänder einfach...
Ja Ich bin Linkshander erzähl mir dein Leid, also ich hab die Apple Watch,
die muss ich umdrehen und ich finde es nach wie vor dämlich,
dass die Crown hier nicht in der Mitte ist, sondern unten und das ist für mich scheiße.
Ne, ich dreh die nicht um, die Apple Watch ich benutze die so wie sie ist.
Ich hab's ausprobiert und das hat für mich nicht funktioniert Erzähl was.
Ne, das Problem ist folgendes, wenn du das iPhone in der linken Hand hast und
es mit dem Daumen benutzt und versuchst ein,
horizontales Swipe nach links oder rechts, zum Beispiel um eine Mail zu löschen,
dann springt sehr oft diese Navigation-Zurück- Geste an. Mach mal,
Dings auf Mail auf.
Ich nutze kein Mail, aber ich sehe deinen Punkt, mir fällt gerade auf,
dass ich mein Telefon häufiger mit rechts nutze als mit links.
Ja, siehst du mal. Also es ist so, dass gerade die horizontalen Swipe-Gesten
funktionieren mit der linken Hand einfach nicht richtig.
Da muss man sich angewöhnen, tatsächlich an einer Stelle loszuswipen,
die total nicht ergonomisch ist,
weil wenn du vom Rand aus swipes, denkt er, du würdest halt das als Rechtshänder
extra weit rübergreifen, um vom Rand zu swipen, was du natürlich nicht tust.
Tja, kann man nichts machen.
Wo wir bei Accessibility sind, schon vor der Keynote hat Apple ja ein paar Accessibility
Features, die sich später hier kommen, angekündigt. Habt ihr das mitbekommen?
Unter anderem Eye-Tracking. ging und da bin ich ja hellhörig geworden,
weil ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was so die Bedingungen dann sind oder was das
sozusagen alles noch mit sich bringt,
wenn man das einschaltet, aber die Möglichkeit jetzt auf einem iPad zum Beispiel
einfach nur mit den Augen irgendwas zu steuern oder auch auf dem iPhone ist natürlich grandios.
Also keine Ahnung, kannst ja dann im Auto sozusagen ohne...
ohne mit dem Finger irgendwo...
Alles, was man machen muss, ist nicht auf die Straße zu gucken.
Genau.
Aber die Hände können schöner am Lenkrad sein.
Ja, aber ihr werdet sicher... Oder, was weiß ich, wenn ich auf dem Motorrad
fahre und ich hab irgendwie das Navi vor mir, dann kommt wieder was weiß ich
und dann willst du aber nochmal kurz die Podcast-App starten oder so.
Dann mit dem Finger mit Handschuhen, also du hast die Hände so erstmal mal fest
so und dann der eine, der frei ist, hat dann noch Handschuhe.
Okay, mit Helm wird das dann wahrscheinlich sowieso schwierig.
Keine Ahnung, ob das funktioniert, wenn man so ein Visier hochklappt. Muss man ausprobieren.
Aber da kann ich mir ein paar ganz nette Anwendungen, wenn es nur Kunstinstallationen
sind, vorstellen, wo man so Eye-Tracking ganz gut benutzen kann.
Also das stimmt. Seit zwölf oder dreizehn Jahren träume ich davon,
das hatte ich bei einem Kindle irgendwann mal festgestellt, dass ich würde den
gerne einfach irgendwo hinlegen,
die Hände schön unter der Decke lassen, im Bett und jetzt nicht zum Umblättern
irgendwie ins Kalte greifen müssen und einfach irgendwo kurz hinpusten oder
irgendwas machen, was nicht mit den Händen zu tun hat, um jetzt einfach schön
kuschelig warm liegen zu bleiben.
Und ja, Eye-Tracking könnte cool sein.
Könnte cool sein. Dann ist mir noch etwas aufgefallen, ich weiß nicht,
ob ihr das schon bemerkt habt, aber was sie jetzt mit iOS 18 haben,
haben, wenn du eine Taste drückst an deinem iPhone, also die rechte Taste oder
die Lautstärketasten, dann gibt es jetzt so eine visuelle Delle im Bildschirm.
Das sah bei diesem Siri sehr, sehr schick aus.
Ja, das haben sie generell, dass sozusagen der Rand jetzt immer so animiert ist, wenn so Siri kommt.
Aber es ist halt auch konkret so, dass wenn du jetzt die Lautstärketaste oben
drückst, dann drückst du quasi so einen schwarzen Balken in deinen Bildschirm rein.
Das hat der Serie auch.
Also du siehst sozusagen direkt an der Stelle, wo du den Button drückst,
auch visuell, dass du diesen Button jetzt gedrückt hast. Fand ich irgendwie cool.
Wir können jetzt alle raten, was das bedeutet für die Hardware der Buttons für
die nächste Generation.
Good point. Dass das nur noch so Non-Buttons sind. Meinst du?
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ein Feature, wo ich denke.
Das war ja schon für das letzte iPhone gerüchtelt, dass die nur noch per Haptic
Engine und eigentlich Solid State Buttons sind.
Kann schon sein. Aber es könnte auch so ganz hilfreich sein.
Ja, es sieht auch so ganz schick aus. Du wolltest gerade was erzählen.
Als Freund der Metadaten bekanntlich. Also ich glaube, was ganz gut funktionieren
kann, ist ein neues Feature auf Safari, auch macOS, Summary oder Highlights.
Das heißt also, dass egal auf welcher Webseite ich gerade bin,
es wird im Hintergrund durchgescraped, was für Metadaten und Entitäten sind hier vorhanden.
Also ist hier irgendwo eine Karte oder eine Adresse drin, auf die ich zugreifen
kann, um dann gleich in Karten zu kommen oder Kontaktdaten oder Telefonnummern oder was auch immer.
Ist das nicht schon ewig?
Nein.
In Mails war das immer so.
In Adressen auch.
In Mails wird es gehighlighted, aber jetzt hast du es halt, egal auf welcher
Seite du bist, du musst halt nicht suchen, bis du unten hinten,
wo der Webdesigner sich entschieden hat, das dann doch irgendwie mit hellgrauer
Farbe aufschieben kannst.
Ach, du meinst in diesem Reader-Modus?
Genau, also neben dem Reader-Modus. Im Reader-Modus ist es auch interessant.
Da machen wir nochmal ein Inhaltsverzeichnis rein und nochmal eine Summary und so.
Das wird, glaube ich, auch ganz gut funktionieren. Aber daneben hast du quasi
nochmal so eine Schaltfläche.
Zeig mir alle Entitäten auf dieser Webseite an.
Also alle Geolocations, alle Personen mit Kontaktdaten und so weiter.
Das wird, glaube ich, sehr, sehr nützlich, um irgendwie schnell...
So, ich will jetzt... Wen kann ich hier anrufen? und ich habe keinen Bock,
jetzt fünf Stunden auf dieser bescheuert designten Seite rumzusuchen.
Ist aber leider auch nicht da.
Auch dieser Video-Viewer fällt da ja mit rein. Dass wenn ein Video irgendwo
versteckt ist, dass man sich das gleich groß machen kann.
Und rausziehen, irgendwo auf dem Desktop.
Aber meine Erschauung ist ja eher, der genaue Gegenteil dieses Videos,
was mir diese News-Seite zwangsläufig einblendet, kann ich das nicht einfach
komplett killen und den Designer, der es eingebaut hat, mit einer Voodoo-Puppe zerstören.
Bist du aggro heute?
Total, total, total.
Du liebst die falschen Seiten vielleicht?
Nee, ich habe zu viel AI gesehen.
Zu viel AI.
Oder du hast nicht den richtigen Werbeblock.
Ja, ich muss den Designer, der Designer kann auch nichts dafür,
aber die Person, die sich das ausgedacht hat, dass da dieses Autoplay-Video,
um irgendwelche Engagement-Scheiße zu erhöhen, automatisch losgeht.
Niemand widerspricht dir.
Danke.
So, ja, was ist noch schön? Also es gibt so eine Art Window Management jetzt in macOS.
Man kann irgendwie die Fenster an den Rand schieben und das Betriebssystem bietet einem zumindest an,
dann die Fenster automatisch zu resizen in so Quarters, wenn ich das richtig
sehe, so eine Viertelgröße, oder?
Sie haben es exakt von Windows 7 kopiert.
Hälfte.
Du kannst es nach oben ziehen, an die obere Menüleiste, dann ganzes Fenster,
auf die linke Hälfte, dann linke Hälfte, rechte Hälfte und Viertel.
Also du meinst, es funktioniert genauso wie bei Windows?
Es funktioniert genauso wie bei Windows
7. Windows ist inzwischen deutlich weiter. Bei Windows 7 war es so.
Das Window-Management bei Windows ist dramatisch besser. Das ist echt peinlich.
Ja, abgesehen davon, dass man bei Windows nicht ausschalten kann,
dass er irgendwie einem das Window-Vollscreen machen möchte,
wenn man es nach oben schiebt.
Das geht mir so dermaßen auf den Senkel.
Okay, also was ich bei Windows sehr, sehr angenehm finde, ist,
du kannst über diese Resize-Box hovern und dann erscheint so ein Pop-up,
wo du, ich glaube, das ist bei macOS tatsächlich sehr, sehr ähnlich,
wo du dann, ja, hier erscheint ein Menü, wo du sagen kannst,
auf die linke Hälfte, also du kannst sagen,
erstes Drittel, letztes Drittel oder wo du es gerne halt hin hättest,
das Fenster und dann wird das dahin gepackt und dann geht der Rest des Bildschirms
in einem Modus, wo du angezeigt wirst. Und hier sind deine ganzen anderen Fenster.
Ja, das ist schön.
Und jetzt klick das mal an und dann wird der Rest des Bildschirms mit diesem anderen.
Weil du willst nicht nur ein Fenster auf den halben Bildschirm machen,
sondern du willst was auf den Rest der Fläche packen.
Und das dann in eine so eine Geste zu packen, ist einfach sehr nice.
Und da könnte sich Apple gerne mal was abgucken. Sie haben alles,
was man dafür braucht. Sie haben alles, was man dafür braucht und sie machen es einfach.
Außer vielleicht das Patent.
Also das ist wirklich hier, Tim, guck mal, Vielleicht ist das Patent ausgelaufen.
Windows 7 ist jetzt alt genug, dass wir es jetzt klauen können.
Ich kann jetzt relativ einfach mein Safari-Fenster hier nach rechts legen.
So, und jetzt will ich aber irgendein anderes Fenster links daneben legen,
um den Bildschirm genau in zwei Bereiche aufzunehmen. Wie? Jetzt nehme ich das hier so.
So, und bei Windows, wenn du das erste gemacht hast, kriegst du halt alle anderen
hier rechts schön zur Auswahl, welches davon willst du in die andere Hälfte packen?
Weil ich weiß ja, du hast das zur Hälfte gesetzt und die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass du die andere Hälfte jetzt auch besetzen möchtest, ist verdammt hoch.
Das macht einfach total Sinn. Es funktioniert. Ich nutze es täglich.
Darf ich mal ein Tool für dieses Window-Management auf dem Mac empfehlen?
Das heißt Swish. Das ist von Highly Opinionated Co.
Also, Moment, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp. Ihr wisst, dass das Feature existiert,
was du gerade beschrieben hast.
Ja? Wo?
Aber du meinst mit diesen, ja, ja, nee, nee, nee. dann müssen die aber im Fullscreen-Notus
sein und dann nee, ich will einfach einen normalen Desktop haben.
Das hat jetzt keiner verstanden, Max, was du gerade gesagt hast.
Okay, erzähl dir jetzt die Geschichte.
Also du kannst, nicht dass ich das Feature toll finde, aber es ist nicht so,
dass es das nicht gibt. Du hast den grünen Button in deinem Fenster.
Ja. Hast du da mal drauf gezeigt?
Dann habe ich ihn im Fullscreen. Naja, da kannst du dann erstmal sagen,
in welche Ecke willst du es hinschicken.
Ja, du kannst Fenster auf der linken Bildschirmseite anordnen und dann gehen
auf der rechten Seite alle anderen Fenster, die es gerade gibt,
auf und das suchst du aus und dann erscheint das da.
Aber dann sind die im Fullscreen-Modus.
Ja klar, aber es ist nicht so, dass es dieses Feature nicht gibt.
Aber ich will es ja einfach nur so.
Nimm dieses Ja, ich finde es auch nicht praktisch. Ich benutze es nicht.
Es nervt. Ich finde sowieso, dass dieses ganze Fullscreen-Management ist eigentlich
eine Katastrophe und müsste mal komplett neu gemacht werden.
Ich bin mir jetzt bloß nicht so sicher, ob jetzt der neue Ansatz da so einen
großen Fortschritt darstellt.
Also ich glaube, es wäre fast einfacher. Sie machen einfach mal die API dafür
auf für diesen ganzen Window-Management-Kram. auf. und erlauben Third-Party-Apps,
das zu customizen, dass man sich mal was raussuchen kann, was man haben will.
Stattdessen müssen diese Programme einen riesigen Aufwand betreiben.
Aber ich benutze auch, ehrlich gesagt, diese anderen Apps auch nicht so richtig.
Von daher bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, ob ich wirklich was vermisst habe.
Also ich möchte an dieser Stelle hier gerne pluggen. Swish, S-W-I-S-H,
von Heilig Opinionated, kostet 12 Euro.
Ich glaube, als ich es gekauft habe, waren es noch 5 Euro über Inflation.
Es ist auch 12 Euro wert. hat, man, das basiert darauf,
dass, also wenn man Trackpad-User ist, wenn man Maus-User ist,
bringt es glaube ich nicht so viel, dass man dann halt diese,
wenn man auf der Titlebar ist und mit zwei Fingern nach oben scrollt,
also als ob man so eine Scroll-Geste machen würde,
dann geht das Fenster auf Fullscreen-Modus und wenn man nach links scrollt,
dann geht es auf die linke Hälfte und wenn man nach rechts scrollt,
auf die rechte Hälfte und dann gibt es noch ein bisschen komplexere Gesten in
die obere rechte Viertel und so weiter und so fort. Diese ganzen Gesten kann man damit machen.
Ist eines so dieser Apps, die ich immer als erstes auf einem neuen System installiere,
weil man muss halt nicht die Maus bis zum Bildschirmrand nehmen mit dem,
Fenster oder sowas, sondern man macht einfach diese Geste, die man eh den ganzen
Tag über macht, eine Scroll-Geste und macht sie einfach über der Windows Titlebar
und es macht diese ganzen Animationen fantastisch und das finde ich nach wie
vor besser als Apples Lösung,
aber immerhin ist Apple jetzt an einem Punkt, wo sie auf dem Windows 7 liegt.
Das ist doch schon mal was.
Das ist doch was.
Windows 7 war ein Meilenstein. Ich weiß nicht, was ihr habt.
Ein Meilenstein vor sehr langer Zeit. Das aber.
So, was gibt es noch hervorzuheben eurer Meinung nach?
Ich denke, was auf jeden Fall großes Ding sein wird für viele Leute,
sind diese neuen Adjustments für den Homescreen.
Also man wird jetzt beim iPhone dieses Anordnen von Icons ist halt bisher eine
totale Katastrophe, weil die ja immer in so einer natürlichen,
Auffüllreihenfolge sind und das lässt sich jetzt wohl anders tun.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob ich das von den Demos her richtig verstanden
habe, aber im Wesentlichen gibt es jetzt die freie Platzierungsmöglichkeit,
also man kann auch bewusst jetzt mal,
in einem Grid kann man aber Leerraum ja, der Grid macht ja auch Sinn,
also willst du nicht alles durch die Gegend schieben.
Sonst sind wir doch bei Windows.
Ja, sind wir wieder beim Desktop und so, das hat ja auch nie funktioniert.
So sind wir bei Android 2.
Und außerdem gibt es halt für Icons die Unterstützung des Dark Mode.
Das habe ich mal gespannt.
Endlich.
Ob die da auch alle mitziehen, dass die Apps auch entsprechende Varianten haben.
Sie haben keine Wahl.
Also bei uns in der Firma habe ich dem Oberdesigner schon Bescheid gegeben und
er hat schon gesagt, ja, ich gebe es dem und dem, bis wann braucht ihr es denn?
Und ich so, ja, es dauert noch, dauert noch.
Das wird lange dauern.
Bis da alle mitziehen. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass dieses mit dem Dark Mode
und den Icons, das sieht schon strange aus, wenn alle anderen Icons plötzlich
dunkel sind und dann leuchtet einem das Nicht-Dark-Mode-Icon entgegen.
Und vor allen Dingen diese einfarbigen Icons, die scheinen lieber die Dark-Mode-Icons
zu verwenden als die Light-Mode-Icons. Das heißt, die...
Die invertieren dann die Light-Mode-Icons und färben sie dann mit der Farbe
ein und dann siehst du überhaupt nicht mehr, worum es geht.
Also es ist irgendwie, ja, aber ich glaube, viele werden mitziehen.
Meinst du? Ja, die Großen auf jeden Fall, aber die ganzen Staubsauger-Steuer-Apps
und so weiter, die werden nie irgendwas machen in dieser Hinsicht.
Also von daher wird es immer scheiße aussehen.
Aber ich meine, das ist so der Lauf der Dinge.
Die Staubsaugersteuer-Apps hat man ja auch nicht auf dem Homescreen wahrscheinlich.
Insofern ist es sehr okay.
Wo denn sonst? In dieser App-Library oder was?
Ich nehme die Siri-Suche. Ich nutze eigentlich immer die Siri-Suche, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ja gut, aber irgendwo liegt es ja rum. Hast du alles in der App-Library?
Hast du alles weggenommen? Hast du auf deinem Homescreen wirklich nur so fünf
Apps, die du immer benutzt?
Ich probiere auf dem Homescreen nur das zu haben, was ich relativ...
Was mir nicht peinlich ist, sagen wir es so.
Auch dafür gibt es ja jetzt eine Funktion.
Welcher App ist dir denn peinlich?
Sowas eben wie irgendeine Staubsauger-Steuerfunktion würde ich nicht auf den ersten Screen packen.
Gucken wir mal, ob ich hier eine habe.
Aber dieses Tinten, ich weiß nicht. Irgendwie hätte ich mir da mehr gewünscht.
Das haben wir noch gar nicht erwähnt. Also Tinting ist, dass man quasi eine
Farbe wählt und dann werden alle Icons in so eine Art Single-Color-Modus überführt, wo sie dann, ja...
Alle gelb, alle orange, ich weiß nicht, wer das will.
Also geil aussehen tut das, aber man erkennt die Icons überhaupt nicht mehr.
Ja, eben genau.
Ich glaube, nur ganz spezielle Leute da draußen werden dieses Feature benutzen
und alle anderen werden es benutzen.
Ich glaube, bei Apple ist halt
aufgefallen, dass es gibt halt diesen Homescreen-Individualisierungsmarkt,
die dann mit irgendwelchen Shortcut-Icons,
denen sie Custom-Icons verpassen und so, dann ihre ganzen Icons anpassen und
ich glaube, dem wollten sie ein bisschen nachkommen, aber ich finde es ehrlich gesagt relativ,
ich fände es ja schön, wenn man es so auf einer Per-Icon-Basis machen könnte.
Also hey, dieses Icon färbe ich um, weil ich das oder nach Kategorie,
ich habe hier alle Finanz-Apps sind grün, alle Apps sind das,
aber so dieses alles hat dieselbe Farbe finde ich extrem hässlich.
Da sind wir zu alt. Das ist nicht für uns.
Mir würde es pro Seite ganz gut gefallen, weil ich immer zumindest ein bisschen
versuche, die Bildschirmseiten vom Homescreen nach Themen zu ordnen.
Jetzt ist es aber so, es gibt ja auch nicht per Seiten Hintergründe,
was auch nicht verkehrt wäre.
Und wenn man jetzt pro Seite einen eigenen Hintergrund und eine eigene Farbe
der Icons hat, dann würde man die visuell sehr stark voneinander unterscheiden.
Und dann würde zumindest für mich das Thema mehr Relevanz oder mehr,
weiß ich nicht, Sinn ergeben, aber jetzt irgendwie alle Icons nachtblau zu machen
oder schönes Türkis ist ein schönes Türkis, aber ich meine….
Kids wollen das einfach haben. Ich persönlich brauche die Farbe, um mich zu orientieren.
Kann man das mit Fokus-Mode verbinden? Das fände ich ganz schön.
Also was ich mache ist, ich habe eine Uhrzeit, zu der mein Bildschirm die Saturierung verliert.
Also wo das Bild weitgehend nicht komplett schwarz-weiß wird,
aber so wo die Farben rausgenommen werden. Und er versucht es so ein bisschen
dahinter, so diesen, hey, jetzt solltest du langsam mal das Telefon weglegen-Modus klarzumachen.
So dieses, die bunte Clicky-Welt ist vorbei, jetzt wird es einfarbig.
Und das ist eigentlich ganz cool, so in diesem Modus dann halt nur noch so sehr
wenig saturierte Bilder zu haben.
Und es ist auch lustig, wenn man dann das wieder ausschaltet,
den Farbfilter, wie knallig das plötzlich alles ist.
Aber so dieses einfach nur irgendwo einen Button hinmachen und jetzt färbe alle
Icons für immer in diesem Modus ein, finde ich.
It's not for you.
Finde ich too little too late.
Also it's not for me, das kann ich schon mal so sagen. Allerdings,
wenn sie tatsächlich auf der Straße weitergehen und wir sehen bei iOS 19 so
Dinge, wie ich sie angesprochen habe oder du sie angesprochen hast,
dann wird es vielleicht mehr Sinn ergeben.
Also wie viele Jahre hat sich jetzt nichts geändert? 18 Jahre?
Also sagen wir so in 18 Jahren, dann kommt dann vielleicht das nächste Feature.
Ich kann gerne mit dir dann so auf dem Balkon sitzen, wie Waldorf und Stadler.
Jetzt geht's! Kategorienbasiertes Umführen.
Guck mal, was ich hier gemacht habe.
Ich kann nicht mehr sehen, aber egal.
Jeder darf hier sich noch ein Feature aussuchen.
Control Center. Jetzt will ich Control Center. Finde ich ganz cool.
Eigene Control Center Buttons. Ist eigentlich, wenn man ehrlich ist, die 28.
Kurz beschreiben, was passiert.
Man kann im Control Center, das ist dieses Ding, was wenn man von rechts unten,
wo man den Flugmodus einschaltet, rechts oben runterzieht, wo man Flugmodus
aktiviert und die Airpods umschaltet und flucht, warum es immer noch nicht auf
die Airpods umgeschaltet hat.
Dieses ganze Screen, das kann man jetzt deutlich besser individualisieren.
Unter anderem können auch Third-Party, also zum einen es gibt mehrere Pages,
durch die man durchscrollen kann.
Ob ich das so gut finde, weiß ich noch nicht, aber Aber Third-Party-Apps können
eigene Control-Center-Buttons und Widgets hinzufügen, was jetzt ungefähr die 48.
Widget-API ist bei Apple. Die sind da ein bisschen so wie Messenger bei Google,
alle zwei Jahre was Neues.
Aber das ist was, wo es gefehlt hat, wo ich mich schon lange gefragt habe,
warum gibt es da eigentlich noch nicht einen Clipboard-Manager,
könnte ich mir da super vorstellen.
Ich könnte mir da tausend Apps gut vorstellen, die da einfach drinnen auftauchen
können, so mit einer leichten Wischgeste runterholen, hier klack,
fertig, rein und das ist nichts Geiles, ist jetzt nichts, wo man irgendwie,
das waren noch Zeiten vor iOS 18, als das noch nicht ging, aber es ist so was,
wo ich mir denke, so ja, das könnte sich im Alltag als sehr praktisch erweisen.
Das ist ja etwas, was man sehr oft benutzt.
Eben. Die Kleinigkeit, die man oft dann aufruft.
Ich entdecke hier gerade was Neues.
Hingegen auf dem Lockscreen diese Kamera- und Taschenlampen-Buttons zu ersetzen,
frage ich mich seit Jahren, warum das nicht geht.
Aber ich wette, ich werde es niemals ändern, weil Kamera und Taschenlampe nutze
ich halt wirklich ständig. Das sind die beiden Sachen.
Die man da haben will.
Da braucht man eigentlich auch nichts zu ändern. Aber es geht jetzt.
Aber es wäre mehr als genug Platz, um hier auch einfach nochmal vier,
fünf weitere Shortcuts hinzusetzen.
Und wisst ihr, dass sich beim Flashlight tatsächlich was geändert hat?
Man kann irgendwie einen Winkel einstellen?
Man kann, das gilt allerdings jetzt nur für ab iPhone 14.
Okay.
Weil also erst seitdem es diesen True Tone Flash gibt, der sich dann quasi aus
mehreren LEDs zusammensetzt.
Warten Sie nicht schon mal vorher beim iPhone 6 oder sowas?
Nee, True Tone fürs Bildschirm, aber der True Tone Flash ist ja sozusagen ein getinteter Flash.
Ich dachte, das gäbe es schon mal. Nee, das gab es vorher schon mal.
Bei einem uralten Telefon.
Jaja.
Egal, auf jeden Fall ab dem iPhone 14 setzt sich der Flash aus verschiedenen
LEDs zusammen und das hat eben auch den Effekt, dass du eben jetzt für die Taschenlampe,
je nachdem welche du da anschaltest oder wie du die anschaltest,
auch einen Abstrahlwinkel machen kannst.
Das heißt, du kannst jetzt auswählen, ob dein Flash gerade sein soll oder eher
breit streut und man kann ihn
jetzt auch nicht nur in drei Helligkeitsstufen, also hell, mittel, aus,
sondern fünf Stufen einstellen.
Also Customization bis hin zur Taschenlampe. Das ist doch mal eine Ansage, oder?
Endlich.
Final D Ralf, hast du noch ein Feature, was du preisen möchtest oder kritisieren
möchtest, weil du der Meinung bist, das wird eh nix Ich glaube.
Ich bin meiner alle losgeworden.
Gut, also ich würde gerne noch was zum Thema Developer sagen.
Developer, Developer, Developer, Developer.
Und zwar hat Apple ja jetzt dieses ganze Apple Intelligence auch auf Xcode ausgerollt.
Ich habe zwar das neue Xcode Beta schon runtergeladen, funktioniert mit Apple
Intelligence angeblich aber erst mit Sequoia. heißt. Sequoia.
Deswegen habe ich das noch nicht ausprobieren können. Ansonsten hat sich irgendwie
bei Xcode gar nichts getan. So wie ich das sehen konnte.
Also nicht mal irgendein Icon anders.
Was aber ganz interessant ist, dass sie jetzt tatsächlich Swift 6 vom Stapel gelassen hat,
was noch mal sehr viel zum Thema Concurrency und Nebenläufigkeit und Sicherheit von nebenläufigem,
Code und was der Compiler da einem alles an Hilfe anbietet, macht,
aber ich glaube, das sollte man jetzt nicht in Gänze ausrollen,
weil das ist, glaube ich, sein eigener CRE oder so.
Ich wollte es nur nochmal erwähnt haben, weil ich das super spannend finde.
Was ich sehr angenehm finde, was mir positiv aufgefallen ist,
dass sie jetzt auch diese Language Server, Wie heißen die?
Dieser VS Code hat ja irgendwann mal diese Language Server eingeführt,
dass sie angekündigt haben, dass sie diese Language Server mehr unterstützen werden, die dann,
die dann Editoren außerhalb von Xcode das Leben leichter machen werden.
Es gab zwar schon den offiziellen LSP.
Den Language-Server gibt es ja schon seit Jahren.
Der hat immer scheiße funktioniert.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Sie haben gesagt, während der Keynote, dass sie da mehr investieren wollen und
auch langfristig investieren wollen.
Was macht Language? Achso, Language ist das Tool, was sozusagen alles richtig
Syntax-Formatierung macht für die Programmiersparen?
Naja, also X-Code, ja für Autocompletion und diese ganzen Sachen.
Also das Problem für mich ist, dass ich jetzt lange Zeit gelandet VSCode genutzt
habe und wenn ich X-Code aufmache, mir denke, oh mein Gott, wo bin ich,
in welcher Vorhölle bin ich gelandet.
Mir geht es genau andersrum.
Also es sind so Kleinigkeiten. Ich habe neulich mal wieder probiert,
an einem fremden Swift-Projekt zu arbeiten.
Und wie stelle ich jetzt ein, dass die Indentation für dieses eine Projekt aber
nicht generell in meinen Einstellungen auf zwei Spaces und nicht auf vier Spaces ist.
Und ich weiß, es gibt die Einstellung, dass man auf so einer Projektbasis machen
kann, aber das Projekt ist komplett in Swift-Packages organisiert und da geht
das irgendwie, oder vielleicht weiß ich auch einfach nicht, wie es geht.
Und das ist so ein Problem, wo ich einfach, ich mache hier das Code auf,
ich habe eine TypeScript-Base, der formatiert das automatisch beim Speichern.
Ich mache mir um so eine Scheiße einfach keine Gedanken. Warum muss ich mir
darüber überhaupt Gedanken machen?
Wer benutzt bitte zwei Spaces?
Dieses Projekt. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ist mir auch scheißegal.
Ich will einfach nur dran mitarbeiten.
Zum Einrücken für Grund? Ich benutze es.
Echt?
So, bitte.
Warum nicht?
Warum sollte man das tun?
Warum sollte man es nicht tun?
Oh, das neue Tabs, wer so Space ist.
Ich meine, ist das nicht genug, oder was? Willst du mehr?
Naja, man sieht halt besser die Einrückungen. wenn es mehr sind.
Ja, ich kann zwei unterscheiden. Dann läuft das nicht so weit raus.
Naja gut, ich meine, wenn du mehr als vier Einrückungsebenen hast,
hast du sowieso ein Problem.
Das kommt noch dazu.
Egal, vielleicht nicht so wichtig.
Ja, es ist vielleicht nicht so wichtig.
Mein Problem mit VS Code war, dass ich es nie mal geschafft habe,
ein Hello World Projekt zu kompilieren.
Mit Swift oder was?
Nee, mit C++ Plus unter VS Code.
Ja, okay. Man muss eine Kommandozeile bedienen. Egal. Ich entwickle sehr gerne.
Aber dafür ist es eine Idee. Es ist keine Idee.
Es ist ein Editor. Das ist keine Idee.
Ralf baut ja schon ab, denke ich mal. Oder, Ralf?
Ja.
Vielleicht so zum Schluss mal noch ein anderer Punkt.
Division Pro.
kommt am 12. Juli nach Deutschland.
Deutschland! Deutschland!
Und? Ja, er kauft sich eine.
Die löst bei mir nicht so richtig haben wollen. Reflex aussieht gar nicht wie so.
Max?
Ich habe mal mit jemandem geredet, der eine hatte, bevor sie auf den Markt kam.
weil er dafür entwickelt hat.
Und ich habe ihn gefragt, und, holst du dir eine?
Und das war so der, wo ich dachte, scheiße, das Projekt ist echt dumm.
Du wolltest da eigentlich auch erst eine haben. Ich wollte mir auch eine holen.
Ich wollte eine holen. Ich dachte, ich wäre der Erste, der da ansteht und mir die holt.
Ich hatte die Gelegenheit, gestern sie auszuprobieren. Ich habe sie nicht genutzt.
Also ehrlich gesagt, weil ich es vergessen hatte. Aber es ist so.
Ich habe die noch nie ausprobiert. Das musst du natürlich auf jeden Fall machen.
Ja, das will ich auf jeden Fall auch machen, ganz ohne Frage.
Aber das Produkt an sich...
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe keine Ahnung. Es ist nichts da, was mich daran so richtig
reizt. Also nicht dreieinhalbtausend Dollar reizt.
Mich interessiert da alles dran. Ich muss sie nur erstmal ausprobieren.
Also du bist sozusagen wahrscheinlich der Erste, der sie dieser Runde besorgen wird.
Ich ahne, dass ich durchaus Zielgruppe bin und da einen Sinn für habe.
Ich habe mit der Quest nach wie vor viel Spaß.
Ich auch, ich auch.
Ich bin generell so Headset-affin, aber ich habe technische Bedenken,
weil ich glaube, wir hatten ja darüber gesprochen, Sichtfeld,
solche Geschichten, dann am Ende des Tages dann doch auch Auflösung und wie
sauber ist das alles so implementiert.
Du hast sie auch noch nicht aufgehabt.
Ich habe sie noch nicht aufgehabt, ich habe ein Angebot, das muss ich jetzt
endlich auch mal umsetzen und dann sehe ich hoffentlich klarer.
Also ich denke mal, sie werden jetzt hier auch in den Apple-Stores dann entsprechende Demos vereinbaren.
Also dass man da so einen Termin sich machen lassen kann, um das mal auszuprobieren.
Das haben wir in den USA so auch gemacht.
Das wäre natürlich so die eine Möglichkeit. Also ich kann euch nur raten.
Also das werde ich auf jeden Fall machen. Ganz ohne Frage.
Man muss, also das Gerät ist als Gerät ganz zweifelsohne hervorragend, aber die große Frage,
wir hatten ja gestern so eine Runde und haben uns gemeinsam ein Keynote angeschaut
mit ganz vielen Entwicklern, die auch alle schon mal diese auf hatten und es
kamen irgendwie zwei Use Cases hin,
so Macintosh benutzen, also sozusagen wirklich so diese Bildschirmoptionen,
wobei das war eine Person mit Kontaktlinsen, die also keine Probleme mit der Schärfe hatte.
Du kannst ja auch, also das würde ich machen, wenn ich die 3.500 Dollar oder
4.000 Euro ausgebe, würde ich mir auch noch die Prescription Lenses mit einbauen lassen.
Ja, wenn man die braucht ich habe ja in dem Sinne keine Brille,
ich habe ja nur Lesebrille,
Und ich weiß aber nicht, ob diese Lesebrilleneinsätze es dann besser gemacht hätten.
Aber ich hatte so leichte, unschärfe Probleme, wenn die Fenster weit weg sind.
Eigentlich sind die ja immer gleich weit weg.
Ja, sie sind eigentlich immer natürlich an derselben Stelle. Aber das war der Effekt.
Also in dem Moment, wo ich sie mir virtuell vor die Nase gezogen habe,
konnte ich alles sehr scharf sehen.
Aber ein bisschen weiter hinten hat irgendwas nicht so richtig mitgespielt.
Und deswegen bin ich etwas skeptisch, ob das quasi so als Macintosh-Bildschirm funktioniert.
Jetzt haben sie ja Vision OS 2 angekündigt, wo ja unter anderem größere Screens möglich werden.
Bisher gab es ja diese Beschränkung auf einen 4K-Bildschirm quasi,
der einem dort virtuell angezeigt wird.
Jetzt kann man halt so einen Riesenscreen machen. Das finde ich natürlich geil.
Also wirklich so ein Macintosh, der so komplett um einen herum geht.
Ich bin ja jetzt auch so ein Curved-Monitor-Nutzer und ich weiß auch warum. So, ist einfach cool.
Und wenn ich jetzt so einen riesen 180-Grad-Bildschirm habe um mich herum,
das werde ich auf jeden Fall nochmal ausprobieren, wenn ich die Gelegenheit dazu habe.
Möglich wird das, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, dadurch,
dass sie die Software jetzt auf dem Mac so angepasst haben, dass dieses Foveated
Rendering, also dieses selektive Scharfstellen,
was ja die Kamera macht, damit sie nicht alles immer,
berechnen muss, sondern eben nur da, wo man hinschaut, das wird jetzt wohl zum
Teil vom Mac dann übernommen.
Also der Mac hilft quasi der Kamera beim Rendern.
So habe ich es auch verstanden.
Habe ich gehört, keine Ahnung, ist alles noch nicht so richtig bestätigt.
Es wird auf jeden Fall kommen.
Es gibt so einen Train Support. Also bisher hat das ja in Zügen nicht so richtig
funktioniert, weil die Bewegung des Zugs dann sozusagen gestört hat.
Das kommt halt jetzt noch mit rein.
Also sie tun was dran, aber es ist natürlich klar, es gibt so richtig keine
große, klare Vision, was jetzt eigentlich so die Killer-App wird. Da muss dann Ralf ran.
Ich fand das wirklich geil mit dem Zug. Das ist auch so Ami-Land irgendwie.
Also es gibt einen Flugmodus, aber mit dem Zug fährt doch keiner.
Und die Europäer alle so, das funktioniert nicht.
Aber auch New Yorker fahren regelmäßig mit der Subway, die meisten zumindest.
Und die können Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ob ich in New York mit der Apple Vision Pro auf der Nase Subway fahren möchte.
Das ist die nächste Frage.
Aber das nur so am Rande.
Nee, das ist schon klar. Die haben einfach kulturell Züge. Das ist echt das Problem.
Da tun die sich ja auch bei den Maps so schwer, dass man bei den Maps rauszoomt
und dann sieht man die Eisenbahnverbindungen nicht mehr.
Das macht mich wahnsinnig. Das sind immer so dünne Linien, die dann auch sofort
verschwinden, wenn du mal so ein bisschen die Perspektive änderst und die Vorstellung,
dass eine Eisenbahnlinie eine nennenswerte geografische Orientierung darstellen
kann für jemanden, das ist einfach auch im amerikanischen Hirn noch nicht angekommen.
Das ist für die eher so ein geografischer Artefakt, so wie Strommast oder so.
Ganz ehrlich, so viele Videos.
Wie es gibt, wo Amis mit ihrem Auto irgendwie an Güterzügen hängenbleiben,
denke ich mir, das haben die auch einfach nicht auf dem Plan,
dass Eisenbahn halt auch irgendwie bewegte Masse ist.
Naja, aber so viele Autos, wie ich auch auf deinem Zehnstrecker sitzen sehe,
das ist auch in Deutschland noch nicht so vielen, also gibt es auch in Deutschland
durchaus noch Probleme. jemand.
Übrigens, jemand hat im Slack behauptet, die Vision Pro würde in Deutschland
4.000 Euro kosten. Das ist eine hemmungslose Lüge.
Sie kostet 3.999 Euro.
Hast du die Preise jetzt raus?
Wenn man den Link da anklickt, Apple Vision Pro, da steht er. Was ich ja mit...
Übrigens, ab.
Es gibt zwei Modelle, oder? Wenn man den USB-C-Anschluss für 400 Euro extra nehmen will, oder was?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, es gibt da zwei verschiedene...
Guck mal, es gibt drei verschiedene Speichergrößen. Drei, drei.
Ein Terabyte, vier, fünf.
Natürlich, natürlich.
Dann gibt es noch Apple Care dazu.
Aber schreiben Sie auch, was die ganzen einzelnen Teile noch dazu kosten?
Oder muss man dann sich durchklicken hier?
Da unten ist es zu behören.
Da unten. Also mit 256 GB sind es 4.000.
4.300 für 512 12 Gig und für 1 Terabyte sind es 4,5.
Nee, 4,25. Für 512.
4,25, oh Mann. Ich tue Apple so unrecht.
Ja, also. Das sind doch nur 250 Euro, die diese 256 Gigabyte Fleisch kosten.
Und dann kannst du natürlich nochmal für 550 AppleCare Plus dazu.
Okay, also Lesebrilleneinsätze 115 Euro.
Das ist nicht mal so teuer.
Nö. Also in the grand scheme of things.
Kann ich meine Brille tragen, wenn ich die Apple Vision Pro auf habe?
Nein.
Da steht noch mehr.
Aber Da steht noch warum das eine dumme Idee wäre, aber,
was ich ja was ich ja hübsch fänden würde, wenn man,
diesen Bildschirm, den man vom iMac oder von welchem MacBook auch immer gespiegelt
kriegt, wenn das einfach kein Bildschirm mehr wäre, sondern wenn das einfach
Fenster wären, die vor einem im Raum schweben, genauso wie es halt,
also warum können sie diese, also ich nehme mal an.
Wieso ist das so?
Nee, du hast einen Bildschirm mit Fenstern drauf.
Was meinst du jetzt mit einem Bildschirm?
Jetzt ist es ein 4K-Bildschirm, jetzt ist es ein Widescreen-Bildschirm,
aber es ist nach wie vor ein Bildschirm, den du...
Du meinst jetzt nicht, dass da Chrome drumherum ist, sondern du meinst nur,
dass es der Mac-Bildschirm ist, genauso wie auf dem Mac.
Was ich gerne hätte, wäre, dass ich jedes einzelne Fenster irgendwo um mich
herum verteilen könnte.
Ja, das geht halt, wenn es eine Apple Vision Pro App ist.
Und dass Apple da nicht...
Ja, das macht ja keinen Sinn. Dann übersteigst du ja quasi die Grenzen des Kontextes,
die Mac selber darstellen kann. Der Mac weiß ja nicht, dass er gerade auf einer Vision Pro...
Das macht total, das macht sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr viel Sinn.
Sag nicht, dass es keinen Sinn machen würde. Es macht einfach Sinn.
Ich hätte es einfach gerne.
Aber das müsste eigentlich gehen. Also der Windowing Manager von macOS ist so aufgebaut, dass die,
Bildschirminhalte eigentlich alle einzeln vorliegen.
Und nicht, dass sie erst gerendert werden, wenn es angezeigt wird.
Das ist lange her, dass das so war.
Seit macOS 10 ist das nicht mehr so.
Ich weiß nicht, ich will ja eigentlich genauso arbeiten wie sonst auch.
Ich nicht.
Ich will einen Mehrwert von 4000 Euro haben. Du hast das Ding noch nicht aufgehabt.
Das stimmt. Aber du hast auch keine. Holst du dir denn eine?
Ich habe sie aufgehabt. Ich werde
mir keine kaufen, weil ich einfach keine Anwendung sehe für mich derzeit.
Und die Anwendung Macintosh, gehen wir mal davon aus, dass ich diese optische
Problematik durch irgendwas in Griff kriege.
dass es quasi immer scharf ist, das wäre schon mal die Voraussetzung,
dann würde ich mich halt fragen, wann nehme ich das Ding und setze es mir auf.
Und aus meiner 24-Stunden-Testerfahrung sind da mir einfach zu viele Faktoren,
die mich… Also du hattest sie sogar länger. Bitte?
Du hattest sie sogar länger. Also es ist nicht so, dass du sie mal aufprobiert hast.
Ich habe sie mal einen ganzen, ich habe wirklich so 24 Stunden mal mit meiner
Apple-ID, was das Problem war, dass ich halt deutsche Apple-ID,
dann konnte ich halt wieder diese ganzen 3D-Filme mir nicht angucken aus dem
Store und so weiter, wir wissen schon.
Also mit Einschränkungen, wobei ich jetzt 3D-Filme auch nicht so interessant finde.
Und ja, das hat ja, also es ist ja wirklich ein tolles Produkt,
das steht ja vollkommen außer Frage.
Bestimmte Dinge haben sie wirklich so hervorragend hinbekommen,
das übt schon seinen Reiz aus, aber am Ende des Tages will ich halt,
Das Ding, setze ich mir das Ding auf, um etwas Bestimmtes damit zu machen,
was ich nur damit oder damit besonders gut machen kann.
Und das könnte ich halt jetzt so nicht sagen, weil ich habe ja schon einen großen
Bildschirm an meinem Macintosh, damit bin ich auch zufrieden.
Und ich gucke vor allem eben mal nach links und kann auch scharf auf mein Telefon
schauen und auch mal meinen zweiten Macintosh und alle meine anderen Geräte,
die für mich auch noch wichtig sind.
Diese Brille nimmt mich ja raus. Das heißt, es geht ja nicht nur um den Computer
und was ich auf dem Computer sehe, sondern ich will ja auch mein Mischpult benutzen.
Ich will einen anderen Computer, eine Tastatur, weiß nicht, hier gibt es ganz
viele Sachen, mit denen ich die ganze Zeit interagieren muss und die Brille
stört dann irgendwann halt auch einfach, weil es eben nicht genau so ist wie ohne Brille.
IPhone Mirroring haben sie jetzt für Vision OS nicht angekündigt.
Das klingt, als ob es wirklich dafür gedacht wäre, oder?
Ein bisschen.
Vor allem, sie könnten es dir direkt in deine Hand reinmäppen.
Ich kann nämlich ein iPhone nicht mehr so richtig benutzen. Es ist dann einfach
sehr unscharf und also durch die Kamera ist dann einfach der Bildschirm,
also du kannst schon noch grob damit arbeiten, aber es ist eben so,
ja, dir wird was genommen.
Und das ist so ein bisschen das Problem. Und da es halt keine echte Killer-App
gibt für mich und ich halt mit Games überhaupt nichts anfangen kann und mit
3D-Filmen kannst du mich jagen,
also das finde ich furchtbar und es keinen wirklichen 3D-Content gibt,
wo ich sagen würde, das brauche ich aber jetzt auch unbedingt in meinem Leben,
es gibt ja quasi nichts außer ein paar Demos,
bleibt halt relativ wenig über.
Und da stecke ich meine 4.200 Euro, die mich das am Ende wahrscheinlich kosten
würde, erstmal woanders hin.
Aber ehrlich gesagt habe ich auch noch keinen 3D-Film gesehen,
wo jetzt die Experience nicht schlechter gewesen wäre, als wenn ich in 2D geguckt hätte. Also insofern.
Das geht gar nicht. Also ich weiß gar nicht, wer das gut findet.
Weil das ist ja nicht 3D.
Kinder.
Ja, aber es ist nicht, auch für Kinder bringt es nichts, weil es ist nicht besser.
Also ich bin überhaupt kein 3D-Verfechter, ganz im Gegenteil.
Ich habe jahrelang gesagt, das wird sich nicht durchsetzen und ein bisschen
habe ich das Gefühl, bestätigt worden sein.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass es nicht Situationen gibt, in denen es nicht einen
Mehrwert bieten würde, aber ja, im Großen und Ganzen stelle ich mich durch.
Ich hatte gehofft auf der Apple, also ich habe gehört, die Vision Pro ist das
beste 3D-Filme-Abspielgerät, was man sich derzeit haben kann.
Mit Sicherheit.
Und das würde ich gerne mal ausprobieren und würde es sehen.
Und entweder ich sage, wow, ja, das ist wirklich geil.
Oder ich sage, ha, auch auf dem besten Device ist es nach wie vor nicht so sonderlich geil.
Ich vermute in Richtung Letzteres, aber das bleibt zu sehen. Das weiß ich nicht.
Aber es stimmt schon. Ich finde, das ist auch bei all diesen VR-Sachen,
bei all diesen VR-Headsets, dass so, also ich finde für die Quest,
bei der Quest ist halt, die kostet, was kostet die?
350 Euro, nicht 4000. Also das ist halt ein Faktor 10.
Und das ist in dem Bereich, wo man sagen kann, ja, das ist halt ein Spielzeug
und dafür finde ich es absolut okay. Okay, aber die Frage ist prinzipiell die gleiche.
Wofür ist die eigentlich am Ende des Tages gut?
Und so eine richtig geile Antwort hat darauf bisher, glaube ich, wirklich noch keiner.
Und es gibt so ein paar, es gibt ein paar schöne Spiele und ich setze die Quest
jeden zweiten Tag auf, um Puzzling Places zu spielen, um mich ein bisschen zu
entspannen, um so ein nettes Spiel zu spielen.
Ja, das ist keine Killer-App, ganz ohne Frage.
Das ist vor allen Dingen keine 4.000-Euro-App.
Ja, 4.000-Euro-App erst recht nicht. 300-Euro-App finde ich absolut angemessen
dafür. Oder nicht absolut angemessen, aber ...
Und ich finde es sehr schade. Ich habe so das Gefühl, das müsste eigentlich
eine Plattform sein, auf der man noch spielen kann.
Das iPhone war ja am Anfang auch. Wie viel hat das iPhone dadurch gewonnen,
dass es irgendwelche Jailbreaks gab, die irgendwelche Sachen,
Funktionen hinzugefügt haben,
die Apple dann irgendwann später ins Betriebssystem übernommen haben.
Und für die Vision Pro gibt es sowas überhaupt nicht, sondern du bist halt von vornherein in diesem,
sehr von Apple spezifizierten System und ich habe das Gefühl,
dass Apple eigentlich selber nicht genau weiß, wofür das Ding gut sein soll
und was man damit anstellt.
Und die Hoffnung, dass die Entwickler das schon rausfinden, hat sich bisher für mich nicht erfüllt.
Das eine wird der Grund sein, weil es einfach nicht genügend davon verkauft
werden, von diesem Ding.
Und das andere ist in meinen Augen, dass das SDK einfach zu beschränkend ist.
Und das finde ich sind, zumindest ein weiteres Problem wäre eigentlich durch Apple lösbar.
Ich finde es ein bisschen schade. Aber vielleicht ist es auch einfach eine Totgeburt.
Naja, also ich sehe schon Branchen, wo das Gerät interessant ist.
Üblicherweise ist Apple,
nicht unbedingt so aufgestellt gewesen in den letzten Jahrzehnten,
dass sie in so super vertikale Märkte reingehen mit ihren Produkten.
Allerdings kann man auch sagen, auch der Mac Pro ist mittlerweile ein super vertikales Produkt.
Also die Zahl von Leuten, die so ein Mac Pro kaufen, ist glaube ich sehr überschaubar.
Das ist, keine Ahnung, ob die überhaupt fünfstellig verkaufen.
Ganz ehrlich, der Grund ist doch, weil sie es irgendwann mal vor Jahren laut
versprochen haben, dass sie den Mac Pro nicht aufgeben.
Es gibt Leute, die brauchen so ein Teil mit PCI-Slots. Die stecken das voll.
Vielleicht. Ja, im Audio-Bereich, im Studio-Bereich, den Bedarf gibt es,
aber der ist halt selten.
Trotzdem produzieren sie dieses Gerät. Jetzt ist es für sie natürlich einfacher,
weil es ist halt nur ein Mac und ein Gehäuse, was sie schon hatten.
Und da müssen sie jetzt, da stecken sie ein Mac-Studio rein und dann haben sie noch ein bisschen PCI.
Und das ist von der Hardware teuer. die lassen sich auch bezahlen, das passt schon.
Aber ich glaube, dass sie generell mit der Vision Pro ähm,
Eigentlich zwei Sachen verfolgen. Sie wollen diese Technologie nicht anderen überlassen.
Sie sehen schon, dass sie in VR, AR in irgendeiner Form präsent sein müssen,
dass sie das brauchen und dass sie dort auch eine Software-Story mitleben müssen,
wenn die sich entwickelt.
Die können dann nicht erst zehn Jahre später einsteigen, wenn alle anderen schon dabei sind.
Weil das eben schon sein kann, dass das für bestimmte High-End-Märkte wichtig ist.
Und diese High-End-Märkte, das ist glaube ich auch das, worauf sie derzeit setzen.
Während sie jetzt für die Öffentlichkeit so ein bisschen diese Story erzählen
mit hier Medienkonsum und lustige Spiele und so weiter, wir haben doch alles da,
das kann man halt der Öffentlichkeit verkaufen und darüber vielleicht auch eine
größere Zahl von Developern erstmal so weit interessieren, dass die dann sagen,
okay, ich stecke da jetzt mal ein bisschen Zeit rein,
ich lerne das mal kennen, ich probiere das mal aus, ich kenne mich aus,
dass es überhaupt erstmal Developer gibt, die sich damit wohlfühlen.
Aber das eigentliche Ziel sind die vertikalen Märkte.
Medizin, Engineering, Training, Remote Assistance, alles so Sachen im Industriebereich
oder im Medical-Bereich, wo so ein Teil durchaus wichtig sein kann.
Also im Medizinbereich würde mich das überhaupt nicht wundern,
wenn die Kamera eine Rolle spielt.
So für Operationen und Fernanleitungen und AR-Aspekte und da kann auch der ganze
KI-Bereich, wenn man den da drauf mappt, auch sehr sinnvoll sein.
Aber das sind halt keine Killer-Apps.
Das sind wahrscheinlich Apps, wo die Leute nochmal 10.000 Euro für bezahlen,
dass sie die zum Einsatz bringen können.
Und dann sind die Kosten für die Kamera ein Scheiß. Und die 15.000 Euro,
die sie dann auf so einen Arbeitsplatz geworfen haben,
ist dann für ihre lohnbringende oder wichtige Anwendung oder Militärbereich
zum Beispiel, ist für die dann sozusagen Pipifax.
Das kostet quasi gar nichts, weil es gibt ja überhaupt gar keine andere Technologie,
die auch nur ansatzweise diese Features so zusammenbringen kann.
In einem Bereich, wo es halt einfach wertvoll ist. Ja.
Teure Technik an fernen Plätzen, wo du Unterstützung brauchst.
Ölbohrplattformen, Techniker in der Wüste. Da gibt es so viele Anwendungen,
die wir so überhaupt nicht als Massenanwendung auf dem Zettel haben,
aber wo Leute unheimlich viel Geld ausgeben, um diese Operations überhaupt aufrecht
zu halten, wo so die Kosten für die Kamera,
ist halt unter ferner Lüfte.
Du hast natürlich zwei Beispiele genannt, wo ich mir die jetzige Vision Pro
überhaupt nicht vorstellen könnte, sondern dann bräuchte man schon ein Gerät,
was extrem robust ist und ruggedized, wie man so schön sagt.
Aber so wie man es jetzt für 4.000 Euro kaufen kann, ist es dafür nicht gemacht.
Du willst nicht in der Wüste mit Sandbrust packen oder auf der Ölplattform mit
ölverschmierten Händen und so.
Aber dafür ist es im Augenblick auch zu sehr Consumer-Produkt.
Also es gibt ja High-End-VR-Brillen, die dann 10.000 Euro,
ob sie das wert sind, weiß ich nicht, das Stück kosten, die dann einen Blickwinkel
von fast 180 Grad haben, die dann eine extrem hohe Auflösung haben,
die selbst die Vision Pro nochmal in Schatten stellt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die heißt. Es gibt so einen Hersteller, ich such dir gerne einen Link raus.
Die sehen aus, also da sieht es aus, als ob die einfach zwei 4K-Displays direkt
nebeneinander geschraubt haben. Und du musst das dann halt mit einem Kabel an
eine entsprechende Grafikkarte anschließen.
Und es ist alles super sophisticated und es kostet ein Schweinegeld und du wirst
es niemals bezahlen können.
Aber es hat halt eine Helligkeit und hat halt diese ganzen Werte,
die dann entsprechende Zielgruppen wollen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das die Zielgruppe da von Apple war. Dafür ist es dann eigentlich zu sehr...
weiß nicht, ob sie sich damit einfach nicht total verkalkuliert haben.
Naja, auf der anderen Seite, wenn du jetzt mal anguckst, was hat der erste Macintosh
gekostet? Der hat 6.000 gekostet.
Was hat das erste iPhone gekostet?
Waren es 600 Dollar, wo sich der Typ von Microsoft, wie hieß er,
da noch so beömmelt hat, dass das unglaublich viel Geld wäre für ein Telefon?
Barmer, genau, Steve Barmer.
Das war saubillig, das erste iPhone.
Insofern, ja, aus jetziger Verhältnis ist es natürlich billig,
aber damals war es nun wirklich, und es waren ja 600 Euro plus einen Vertrag von zwei Jahren.
Doch, doch, doch, doch. Du hast da den Vertrag noch dazu bekommen.
Hast aber trotzdem deine 600 bezahlen müssen.
Ich habe das erste iPhone, habe ich aus den USA importiert, da habe ich 200
Dollar für bezahlt, glaube ich, oder sowas. Das wäre mit AT&T Vertrag gewesen.
Ich habe es halt nie aktiviert.
Dann war es aber nicht mehr das allererste, oder zumindest nicht am Anfang.
Sie sind am Anfang dann schnell mit dem Preis runtergegangen.
Und ich meine, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass sie da so viel Technik reinbauen,
dass sie halt auch nicht wesentlich weniger Geld nehmen können,
ohne Verluste zu machen.
Vielleicht machen sie auch jetzt schon bei dem Preis Verluste, wer weiß es.
Aber ich glaube, wenn sie in den nächsten Versionen Vision 2,
Vision 3 nicht unter 2000 Euro kommen, dann haben sie ein Problem.
Also ich habe jetzt mehrfach gehört, dass sie entsetzt waren über die Verkaufszahlen
und dass… Niedrig oder hoch?
Sie sind entsetzt, weil sie einfach so wahnsinnig viel Geld verdienen.
Ich glaube, das war bei Apple noch niemand, weil sie extrem niedrig sind und
dass sozusagen die Entwicklung der nächsten Generation um ein Jahr schon mal
mindestens rausgezögert wird.
Und das war, ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt, keine Ahnung, das ist natürlich
immer, das war hier halt Bloomberg, wie heißt der, Mark Ruman,
hat das irgendwie rausgehauen und wer weiß, ob das stimmt und wer weiß,
ob da was dran ist und was da nochmal alles drin ist.
Aber falls es so stimmen sollte, dann wäre das für mich ein bisschen alarmierendes
Zeichen, weil ich glaube, das hätte ihn absolut, also wenn sie damit rechnen,
okay, das wird sich nicht gut verkaufen, das ist erstmal ein totales Nischending,
das ist für die Entwickler gedacht.
Aber so haben sie es halt nicht angekündigt. Sie haben es halt so,
bam, bam, bam, hier ist sie.
Und hier, 3.500 Euro oben auf der Couch im Groß weitwinkel Video.
3.999.
Der Chat hat natürlich mit einer Sache recht, auch wenn das nicht passieren
wird, nämlich der Hinweis, wenn Google Earth Native auf der Vision Pro ist,
dann sieht die Sache schon wieder ganz anders aus.
Sofort.
Ja, aber dann möchte ich auch gerne, dass es nicht Google Earth ist,
sondern dann hätte ich gerne mal Apple Earth.
Weil das ist eigentlich, Weil Google Earth hat einfach keine Zukunft.
Google scheißt auf dieses Produkt und pinkelt auch noch drauf.
Ja, das läuft halt ja auch nativ und nicht im Chrome. Ich sag dir,
wenn es im Chrome laufen würde, dann wäre das ganz anders.
Es läuft in Chrome und nativ, naja, auf dem Macintosh ist es immer noch Intel.
Sie machen nichts an dieser Software. Es hat sich einfach seit Jahren nichts
verbessert bei Google Earth.
Sie haben immer so Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt,
dieses und wie jetzt die größte Fortschritt der letzten drei Jahre war,
dass sie jetzt Bahnlinien mit so schwarzen Querstrichen anzeigen und nicht nur
als eine einfache schwarze Linie.
Der Praktikant hat mal einen Bug gefixt.
Das ist alles, was sie geändert haben.
Immerhin muss man ihnen zugute halten. Sie haben jetzt die Anzahl der Flughäfen in Berlin hingekriegt.
Es sind nicht mehr drei. Wir haben nur noch einen.
Auf Google Earth?
Nee, auf Apple Maps.
Ja, aber Apple Maps sieht halt viel besser aus als Google Earth.
Das Rendering ist viel besser, die Auflösung ist viel höher,
die 3D-Auflösung ist viel höher.
Warum können sie das nicht einfach mal, so wie Google Earth das macht,
rendern? und dann noch Space Mouse anschließen und dann kaufe ich ihnen gleich
zwei von diesen Teilen ab.
Weil dann brauche ich hier eine hier und eine auf dem Klo, dann würde ich irgendwie nicht klarkommen.
Ja, ich meine, das ist wirklich geil. Ich meine, Ralf hat ja hier mal seine
Quest angeschleppt und da hat er diesen Google Earth Hack gemacht und dann merkst
du schon, also es sah zwar furchtbar aus, aber du merkst halt schon,
dass das wirklich, das ist halt wie fliegen dann.
Also das ist mal wirklich, also alles andere, dieses ganze in Höhlen rumlaufen
und Monster erschießen und so weiter, kannst du mich mitjagen.
Aber wenn du mit dem Ding fliegen kannst, dann ist das mal im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes ablifting.
Tim, wir machen immer nochmal die ISS Experience mit dir.
Willst du fliegen? Willst du nämlich ein Flight Simulator kaufen?
Ja, ich will über diese Welt, ich will durch alle Straßenzüge fliegen,
ich will irgendwie diese, ich liebe es einfach Überblick zu bekommen.
Ich mochte schon immer Karten, ich war auch so ein Falkplan-Nerd und hat mir
irgendwie, wenn ich in eine andere Stadt gefahren bin, ich habe mir erstmal
8 Kilogramm Falkpläne gekauft und die habe ich mir dann erstmal durchgelesen,
bevor ich irgendwo hingefahren bin. So bin ich drauf.
So ist der Tim drauf.
Ja, so bin ich drauf.
Falk-Plan, Falk-Plan.
Hervorragende Technologie, der Falk-Plan. Und jetzt möchte ich gerne,
dass die digitale Welt mal nachzieht, aber es ist irgendwie keiner Schein.
Aber der patentierte Falt-Mechanismus.
Ja, der muss noch nachher erfunden werden.
Gut. Wir sind durch, Leute. Das war's jetzt.
Heute. Will jemand noch irgendwann ein Grußwort richten an die Menschheit?
Hört mehr WMR.
Munter bleiben.
Wir müssen reden.
Ein Gruß an alle die, die nicht die Faschisten gewählt haben.
Und überhaupt gewählt waren.
Aber das war ja schon nicht so funktioniert.
Das war jetzt mein Grußwort.
Das war dein Grußwort. Gut, das kann ich nachvollziehen. Ich denke, dann ist,
279. Ausgabe von der Freakshow ist eingetütet. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Vielen Dank fürs Dabeisein und mal schauen, wann wir uns wiederhören.
In ein paar Wochen, nehme ich an. Bis dann.
Tschüss.
Ich zeige das mit aus.